hey everyone welcome to simply learn's
youtube channel in this session we will
be learning about data analytics with
excel but before we begin let me tell
you guys that we have daily updates on
multiple technologies so if you're a
tech geek in a continuous hunt for
latest technological trends then
consider getting subscribed to our
youtube channel and don't forget to hit
that bell icon to never miss an update
from simply learn now before we begin i
would like to take a quick confirmation
from urine if i'm audible and everything
is clearly visible on the screen
if yes please type yes in the chat
section
great i see some positive responses so i
think we are good to go now we will
begin with the agenda of today's session
first we will have a brief introduction
to data analytics with excel followed by
that we will understand how to manage
spreadsheets and data in microsoft excel
so we will have some fundamentals in it
we will start with basics where we'll
try to create rows columns and try to
include data in them to the state where
we include a data validation on the data
in excel spreadsheet conditional
formatting and much more followed by the
fundamentals we will start with data
analytics from the basics where we try
to compare two columns and also we will
try to cover freezing columns rows etc
for the reporting purposes later we will
try to incorporate security to our excel
data which might include dashboards
charts and confidential organization
data followed by that we will learn to
merge cells columns rows and even
spreadsheets in excel next after that we
will learn how to transpose data in
excel it is obvious that all the time
you will not receive the data in the way
you need for analytics so prior to
analytics you might want to prepare your
data so that includes you know
transposing data adding filters etc and
after that we will enter into slices in
excel then we will learn about some ifs
in excel so subnets is conditional
statements in excel so we will have some
conditional statements in excel in and
around sum and sum fs in excel followed
by that we will try to learn how to
create a drop down menu in excel so you
might find it handy when you're
presenting your data using a drop down
list and then we will also include some
time calculation functions in excel like
calculating age or time in excel time
difference calculation in excel and
followed by that we will get into some
fundamental calculations which include
average calculation round of function
percentage calculation etc and then we
will get into customizing date formats
dax expressions in excel that is data
analytics expressions in excel followed
by that we have date diff function in
excel and after the fundamentals are
done we will dive into the pivot tables
in excel where we will understand the
fundamentals of pivot tables then we
will try to create a pivot table
followed by that we will try to explore
a little bit into pivot tables where we
will use multiple sheets to create a
pivot table then we will try to learn
pivot charts in excel speaking about
charts the major part of data analytics
is presenting your data in a visual
format which includes charts in excel so
we will also cover charts in excel in
this tutorial followed by that some
advanced excel functions such as lookup
functions which include vlookup hlookup
and xlookup as well then we will learn
v-stack function in excel followed by
that we will learn about hyperlinks in
excel which you can use to link web
pages different sheets documents and
much more and followed by that we will
dive into the data analysis and data
regression using excel then we will
enter macros in excel then we will have
a brief introduction to visual basics in
excel and also learn some fundamental
concepts of excel vba and finally we
will also cover data recovery part in
excel sometimes you might end up in
tough situations where you might have
lost the data so we will also cover that
particular tutorial in this how to
recover data using excel and finally to
make things interesting we will walk you
through some day-to-day shortcuts used
in excel so with that discussed we can
get started with our first topic and i
hope i made myself clear with the agenda
over to our experts
hi everyone let's continue learning
excel
so we will learn about functions and
formulas we will learn about conditional
formatting data validation pivot chart
and pivot table
now let's look at a scenario here so one
day in a startup
one professional speaks that their
business is growing and they would need
an efficient way to work with the data
they would have to find a way to work
faster with storing and analyzing data
now to that another colleague responds
well we can make use of microsoft excel
to do this job
the question is will excel be able to
cater to
their business needs
now
the colleague responds well we can make
use of excel in several ways and it also
is a cost efficient
option
now in that case the colleague who posed
the question
says let's go ahead with excellent let's
train our employees in excel
and
the suggestion is welcomed which would
make the job easier for them
and they would basically
decide on using excel so they decide on
taking a training right away and
basically starting to learn excel
now before we move to excel one of the
question is why should we use excel
so let's look at some of the points here
so excel proves to be a great platform
to perform various mathematical
calculation on large data sets which is
one of the biggest requirements of
various organizations these days
various features in excel like searching
sorting filtering makes it easier for
you to play with the data
and excel also allows you to beautify
your data and present it
in the form of charts tables and data
bars
now when it comes to reporting reporting
accounting and analysis can be performed
with the help of excel
it can help you with your task lists
your calendars and goal planning
worksheets
excel also provides good security for
your data excel files have the feature
of password protection
this way your information can be safe
now when we talk about what is excel and
how it can be used
so excel or you might have heard a
spreadsheet can be basically used for
a lot of different tasks than just
storing the information in so called
tabular format
now
microsoft excel is an application that
is used for recording analyzing and
visualizing data it is in the form of a
spreadsheet
let's have a look at few of the
functions and formulas used in excel and
before we do that we can also quickly
take a
small tour to understand how to work
with excel now to do that what we can do
is we can
type in in our search say for example
excel
and just select your excel app which is
installed and here you see you have a
lot of options which says take a tour
drop down list get started with formulas
make your pivot table
going forward with pie charts and much
more so we can click on this one which
says take a tour
and that basically pops up a window
which says welcome to excel and
if you have always wanted to be better
at excel
you have this
which can help you so let's click on
create and that takes us to the store
window now that says instructions for
screen readers which basically talks
about 10 different steps in which we can
learn excel
and using the spreadsheet app
so there are more than 11 sheets
which we see here at the bottom end and
each one gives us a simple example which
we can work on
so for example if i click on add
now that takes me to this page which
says
how do we add numbers now you might be
provided data which we can
upload by loading a file from our
machine or getting data from a web
source or even connecting to a database
so there are various options which we
will see in some time so here we have an
option which is called data
you can click on this one and this
basically has
options where you can use existing
connections if you have created some you
can always click on from other sources
and you can get your data from sql
server from analysis services
from o data data feed you can get in
from xml from data connection wizard or
also from microsoft query you can be
running in different queries here which
shows up in the option which says new
query there are connections which you
can use
and that basically will display all the
connections
for this particular workbook which we
did not have as of now but we can create
them but let's look at simple examples
now you can follow these instructions
here which says basically
adding up the numbers and that could be
easily done by just placing your cursor
here and what you could do is either you
can type in the formula that is
from which row to which row you would
want to add the data so for example i
could just do a sum here and that shows
up all the different functions which are
available then we can open up a
parenthesis and we can say i would be
interested in totaling the amount
from
column d and i would select for example
d4
so
i could be doing this and then i could
say d4
onwards till d7 so that's the data which
i'm interested in you can close your
parenthesis and hit enter and that gives
you the total
there is also a shortcut for this which
you can always do is we can first delete
this and you can just place your cursor
here and just
use your alt and equals that
automatically selects the numericals
which we can anytime
expand or basically collapse so i will
basically select this which says this
function needs two numbers which is
number one and number two and then you
can hit on enter and that gives you the
total
so similarly we can be getting in the
data
here by selecting all the fields
so here it also says that you can use a
shortcut now what we can also do is we
can add numbers over 50
by selecting the yellow cell here and
then giving a condition
such as so i can basically use something
like sum if
and then open a parenthesis i can select
i would be interested in this row and
then i can even drag and drop
till here so that tells me d11 to d15
you can then put in a comma here and you
can give your condition say for example
we would say i would be interested in
numbers only above 50 and we can select
this
close your quotes and then just close
your parenthesis and that's your formula
so you can do this and that basically
gives me the total is hundred now
similarly we could do that for the
amount here i could select this now
there is also an option i can click on
home and i can go for something like
auto sum so that's one more way of doing
it which anyway says sum is alt plus
equals so it automatically adds up your
values and i can try doing an auto sum
that automatically selects my rows and
then i can get my total now as per this
activity here it says try adding another
sum if formula here but add amounts that
are less than 100 and the result should
be 160. so what we can do is we can
basically
select all the numbers which are lesser
than 100 so the way we did earlier here
there can be always a shortcut so you
can always for example if you would want
to avoid typing in the formula you can
always copy it from here
and then
just hit on enter so you are back into
this cell and then i can basically go
here and paste
the number and then as per the
requirement we are required to select
anything which is lesser than 100 so
what i could do is i could select here i
could say let's say g
and then i can change this value to g15
and that's one more way now we see our
selected rows have been changed so i can
hit on enter and i can check what is the
result so we would be interested in
looking for numbers which are lesser
than 100 so i will have to also change
this one to
a lesser sign and that basically gives
me the total which is
160 so that's how you can simply add
numbers you can use autosum you can type
in the formula you can select the fields
or you can just place your cursor where
you would be looking for a sum and then
you can just do a alt equals and that
basically populates the sum
now let's look at
some easy options of filling your cells
or automatically populating the values
in your
cells within your excel sheet
now here we have an option which says
100 now we can click on this and that
basically says it is making a sum of
column c4 to d4 so if i click on this
one i can check that this is
row number four
which shows up here
and i also know this is column c i also
have d so this equals is basically
giving me a sum of c4 to d4 now what we
can do is we can always place our cursor
here at the right corner and then we can
just drag and drop and this basically
gives me a total of all the numbers for
all different rows
so this is one shortcut which we can do
to get the total excel will
automatically give the totals which we
call as filling down
now what we can do is in the same way if
we would want to get the totals here we
can first check what is this 200 and
this tells me it is c11 to c14 total so
it is totaling the rows from c11 so
column c and 11th row till 14th row and
that's the sum now what i can also do is
i can similarly like above we can do a
filling right which basically means
bringing your cursor here and then just
dragging and dropping it all the way
where you would need the totals and this
basically gives me the total there is
one more quick way to check if this is
right
so the easiest option would be to select
this cell now what i can also do is i
can just select all of these fields by
just highlighting and selecting all the
fields once it is selected
press on control r
and that gives you the total now if we
would be doing this top down then i
could select all these
rows
for this particular column and then i
could do a ctrl d so that's your
filling down and this one was filling
right so this is an easier option of
doing a fill
when you would want to have the formula
applied to every row as it occurs in the
first row or the last row we could test
this by for example selecting these
fields i could delete them and i have
here which says 130 i could just place
my cursor here and i could drag it all
the way up
and that should also do the same magic
which we were seeing from top down so
this is a simple way wherein you can
fill up your cells and you can also
automatically
propagate
or move your computation to all the
cells
let's
look at the split option which basically
helps us in splitting the data when we
have some kind of pattern
or when we have some kind of delimiters
in our data
in say one particular column and we
would want to derive the values out of
it so we can always use the splitting
option now the easiest option would be
so for example we have our email column
which has the email ids and which we can
clearly see has a first name dot last
name now i see that there is a last name
smith filled up here first name is empty
so what i can also do is i can just type
in say
nancy here
now that's the first name i can again
start typing the second name and as soon
as you do that you would see a faded
list of numbers and that's your clue to
hit enter and once you do that you would
see all the first names have been filled
in here if you would want to maintain
the case sensitiveness you can just go
ahead and delete these and let's type in
as it occurs so let's say nancy as the
first name go down to the next cell and
just type in andy and there is your
grade list so just hit on enter and that
basically fills up your first name
what we can also do is
we can just select this particular field
and either we can type in control e
which basically fills up all the options
now i can just do a undo by typing in or
clicking control z and that's basically
gone
what i can also do is i can select a
particular field
and then i can go into home option and
under home
you should have an option here which
says fill so you can select this and
then you can do a flash fill which is
what we are doing here so click on flash
fill and that automatically fills up the
values so in this way you can work
within your spreadsheet and you can be
filling up the values where a delimiter
by default is understood and we can
split the data now however sometimes you
might have some data which has a
different kind of delimiter and there is
again a smarter way of splitting your
data
so you can always scroll down here and
that says splitting a column based on
delimiters so we have some values in the
data column and
these values in each row are separated
by comma so
select this
your data is already selected text to
columns delimited
comma is selected
and now click on next so it basically
says
what is the destination let's select
this one
and i can choose
what would you want to have so that
shows me this would be my data preview
now i can basically select this one
i can say finish
and say okay
and now if you see our data has been
placed in
in the columns appropriately so this is
how you can split your data based on a
delimiter
and then organize your data in a better
way now there are some advanced options
which we can learn later but this
basically tells about using a formula so
this is something if say if we have some
name in one cell and if you would want
to split it into first name
your helper column
your middle name last name so that can
also be done using formulas and this
basically tells how would you extract
characters
from your left
cell and how would you place them in
your right cell so you can try this
activity which is a little more of
advanced option the benefit is that
you can always use this
wherein
if you
do some kind of transformation using
your formulas
if your original data gets updated then
the split data will also get updated and
that's the benefit of using formulas
where you can place values from one cell
into multiple cells based on execution
of your details in the formulas
how about using the transpose option now
you might have heard of situations where
you would want to
switch or turn your rows into columns
and your columns into rows and that's
where transposing comes into picture it
might be useful when you have your data
in your x and y axis or as i would say
in rows and columns and you would want
to switch your rows to become the
columns and columns to become your rows
so what we can do is the simplest way is
you can select all your
values so here we basically have six
columns and i would say two rows now i
can select all of these and then i can
select an empty field for example the
one which is highlighted here well you
can always do a ctrl alt v that's a
shortcut what you can also do is
once you have selected all your fields
you can just copy them so just do a ctrl
c
and then click on an empty cell and then
what you can do is you can do a special
paste or paste special so under your
home you have the paste option and here
you can go for paste special
and once you do that you need to select
the transpose option over here and click
on ok
and now you will see that the columns
and the rows have been transposed so
your row name was item and that has
become the column heading you had row
name as amount and that has become the
column heading and all your values have
been transposed
in
this particular format now there is
another way of doing that and again
that's using your formulas so what you
can do is you can transpose with a
formula also and that basically
works
when you have similar kind of data so
this has six columns
and basically two rows so you can
basically do this so you can
select this and earlier we were doing a
copy but now what we would want to do is
we would want to just look at the row
numbers which tells me it is c33c34
and it starts with c and ends in with
your h column so what we can do is we
know that we have six columns and two
rows so transposing that would actually
give me two columns and six rows so what
we can do is we can select
two columns
and six rows in our excel sheet i can
then basically start typing in the
message or i can just go to the address
bar and here i can say
transpose
let's go for c33 h34
it basically selects my data
and now i can just do a
control shift and enter and now if you
see all the values have been populated
now you can just place your cursor in
one of the cells but if you see the
address bar the formula remains the same
this is because this is an array formula
so we can read more about an array
formula here it's basically something
which performs calculations and on more
than one cell in an array
and in the example here the array is the
original data that is c33 to h34 so your
transpose is just changing
the horizontal orientation to the
vertical orientation so this is a very
simple way in which you can basically
use the excel's capability to transpose
your data and convert your rows into
columns and columns into rows apart from
working on
additions subtractions filling up your
data
sorting
the data or basically splitting your
data
transposing your data one of the other
requirements is
sorting and filtering your data now that
can be very handy when you're working on
huge data and you would want to sort it
in a particular order say ascending or
descending or might be based on a
particular field or if that field was or
if the cell was highlighted with a
particular color sorting the data so
let's look at how excel can be used for
sorting and filtering examples are
pretty simple here so
let's check that so if we're going to
sort and filter and say this is the data
i have say for example i would want to
sort the values in the department column
alphabetically so what i can do is i can
select department column and i'm already
in the home tab i can straight away go
here which says sort and filter i can
then say sort a to z and that's
basically alphabetically sorting your
department column
and once once i do this you would see
the data has been sorted but it's not
just this data we can just do a ctrl z
and check what are the values we have so
here we have meat which is beef and
ninety thousand
hundred ten thousand the values
then you have bakery which should
ideally be the first
row if we sort it in alphabetical order
which goes with bakery as deserts you
have the values so we can check this
again so select department and then just
do a sort and filter and let's say sort
a to z and if you see the data has
changed but it's not just in changing
your first column but then it has taken
care of all the data however the data
has been sorted based on the department
column so you have bakery which aligns
with deserts which has the values and
now we have all the data which has been
filtered now what we can also do is we
can sort december's amounts from largest
to smallest so what we can do is we can
basically click any cell in the december
column let's say 20 000
and then what i can do is i can go into
sort
filter and then i can say sort largest
to smallest so if you see bakery breads
is the row which has the smallest data
or might be you have delhi sandwiches so
that one looks also smaller so let's do
a
larger to smallest and if i do this you
would see the values have been shifted
now so it is no more based on the
department column
because now the data is being sorted
based on the values in the december
column and you see bakery which was
alphabetically the first one has become
second last
so either you can sort the data based on
a department column which goes
based on the values these are all string
values or words so it sorts
alphabetically if you have numbers might
be you can give some values and you can
sort the data
you could anytime do a custom sort and
you could basically select
if you would want to
select the data so i could do a custom
sort and then i could choose
which is the column which we would want
to use for sorting what is the sorting
needs to be done
is it cell values it's a cell color font
color conditional formatting and then
you can also choose the order so that's
one more way to do that
now if you scroll down that also shows
how you can sort by date
or a color so for example if you would
want to sort
based on the expense date so there are
different options so what i can do is i
can select this date field i can just do
a right click i can go into sort and
then i can choose i would want to sort
oldest to newest so since i selected the
date field
it basically has sorted all the data
and it has taken the expense date into
consideration now there are these
filters which you see on the row
headings we could have also used those
so i could have selected this and that
basically says or mentions which are the
dates i would be interested in looking
at i also have sort by color here i can
do a sort oldest to newest or newest to
oldest so i could also use these filters
which have been applied here now we have
the data which is in color so if i would
want to basically select
the color columns or color cells i could
select this i can basically do a right
click here and when i go into sort i
could choose
put selected color or cell color on the
top and that basically will make sure
that my data is sorted and it has also
sorted that in a descending order so in
this way you can sort or basically
filter your data
what we can also do is we can add
filters so sometimes we can go for
formulas which we would want to use what
we can also do is we can
basically select the filter which has
been applied here now how does the
filter come in there so if i would
select a particular row
i could select a particular row and then
i could decide if i would want to just
add a filter to this one and that's how
the filter has come in so we have the
filter what we can do is we can
basically click on this drop down
and then you have something like number
filters so we can always go here we can
basically choose one of these so we can
basically choose above average so i
could select this and then basically it
shows me the values we could also delete
the filter by clicking on this one and
we could say well i'm not interested in
this filter anymore so i could clear the
filter and that shows me all the values
or i could say
that let's click on some other field for
example food i can go in here i can go
into number filters and then i could say
well i'm interested in
values which are below average above
average might be greater than and then i
can choose what is the value so for
example if we say i'm interested in food
which is
greater than 25 dollars i could give a
value here i could say ok
and now i have applied the filter
similarly you can select this and then
you can just clear your filter and your
data is back
so remember
no data is lost
it is just hidden or basically based on
the filter not shown
so that's good enough for us and in this
way you can sort and filter the data so
for more details obviously in all the
sheets you have the links which point to
more information on the web and you can
always refer to these so this is simple
way in which you can sort and filter any
amount of data which has been stored
within your excel within a particular
sheet now that we have learned about add
fill split transpose sorting and
filtering it will also be good to learn
how to work with tables or basically
converting your data into a tabular
format and then doing some easy
computations
so click on this tables option here now
here we see there is some data which is
in
five columns and n number of rows so i
can basically select this data and then
what i can do is i can insert
choose the table option
and then it says my table as headers and
we'll be okay with that i'll say okay
and now if you see this is the table
created it basically has different
filters which we have learnt earlier how
to use and this is basically my table
which is a collection of cells which has
some special features
so we can easily add rows to this table
we can add columns to this table and we
can even do some calculations so for
example here i can click on this one i
can
basically enter some field and then i
can hit on enter and we see that this
row has been inserted wherein we can
easily fill in values for example i
would say chocolates
i could give some value here size 25
000
might be 35 000
and then basically i can given some
values here now what you can also do is
you can continue adding rows in this way
and say for example you would want more
columns so you can select this
option here in the top bottom right
corner you can just drag it towards the
right and that basically has
automatically created
columns for my next month
wherein i can feed in the data so this
is a simpler way wherein you can keep
adding more rows and columns to your
data if that has been converted in a
tabular format now let me just do a ctrl
z that basically deletes the columns
again control z deletes the last row
which we added and i can stop here or i
can even remove my values by doing
multiple control z
and removing my rows so this is how
i converted my data into a table and
then i can easily work on this what i
can also do is
i can do some calculations so what we
can do
we have a table here we have a total
field and what we can do is we can just
select one cell here now as we have
learned earlier we can do a alt and then
equals
and that basically says what
is this doing so it says it is
calculating the sum of
the last three months and if that's what
you would want to do just hit on enter
and it has automatically calculated
the totals for
all your rows for these three columns
so the sum formula is getting filled up
now i can select any particular cell and
i can look in my address bar so it has
already given me the formula where it
has started
calculating the sum from the october
column
till the december column and has given
me the calculated values of the columns
what we can also do is we can get total
rows in the table now that's a simpler
option so what we can do is we can
select any cell in this particular table
and then we see that there is a table
tools design option showing up here now
i can select this and then it says well
let's get a total row so let's select
this and it automatically populates the
total here
and if you would want the average then
we could select this and from the drop
down i can select what i'm interested in
so for example i would want the average
values and not the total i could just
select this and that gives me the
average of these values
so we can always do simpler computations
here
by converting our data into table format
let's learn about one more efficient way
of working with the data and that's
using your drop downs so let's see how
drop downs work here
now say for example you have this data
which has the values in the food column
and department is empty and say for
example you would want to
enter the values in department however
you would want to select the department
should either have
produce or meat and bakery and these are
the only three options which should be
available for any user to fill in the
values how do we do that so we can
basically create a table by pressing
ctrl d so what i can do is under my
department
here i can select one of the cells
and then i can do a ctrl t that
basically converts this into a table i
can say ok and my table is created now
what i can do is once this part is done
we can select all the blank fields here
where we would want this drop down to be
applicable
now under your data tab you can go in
and select data validation and this has
an option called data validation click
on this
which basically says allow any value so
here i will select i would want to give
a list of values and then i can type in
my values here which i can say produce
say for example meet and then say
bakery now these are the values
so we can click on ok
and once we have done that we basically
have a drop down here next to apples
which will only show us the values which
we can feed in under the department
column so i can go into every cell and
then i can basically choose
what is the department which handles
this
and then basically i can select one of
these from the drop down so this is an
easier option of creating your drop down
and then feeding in the values from the
set of values which you have defined
here on the right
so this is a simple example of using
your drop downs
working with your tables working with
your sort and filter transpose split
filling up your data adding in some data
here
and similarly you can use excel for more
than
one use case using its inbuilt features
to easily work with your data
let's see how we can import data or
bring in data into our excel from
your local machine or from an external
web source
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free
visit skill up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
so what we can do is we can open up a
blank excel sheet and say for example
you have been provided
a text file or a csv file and you would
want to import that data into your excel
sheet that can be easily done
so right now i've opened an
excel sheet now i can click on data and
here i have an option which says
existing connections from other data
sources
so or you can click on connections if
you have already created some so we can
click on from other sources
so this is one option where you can
connect to your different data sources
and you can get the data
from
one of these
what we can also do is i can click on
connections now it says there is none
i can click on add it says
well show the connections where
connection files on network
connection files on this computer so i
can say let's get some files from this
computer
now if that does not show up something
so say browse for more
and that basically shows you different
options so let's basically select a
folder where i have
some data sets i'll click in here
and this is basically a folder where i
have some data sets
now let me select this particular file
and i know it is a csv file
so let's click on
open now if you would want to verify
this you could have gone and looked into
the properties of the file and it says
it is a dot csv file which is what we
are interested in so i'll take this file
i'll say open now this basically shows
me
the text import wizard option which says
is the file delimited i'll say yes
click on next so i will select comma as
my delimiter i can say text qualifier is
none
now this is my data so my data preview
is already showing me the data is
what is the data in the csv file you can
click on next and then you have an
option which says data format is general
you can go for date format you can go
for advanced options so i'll just say
finish
and basically now this has been created
here
so we basically have this and now i can
click on
close now once you have done that you
can click on existing connections it
shows me the data
which we have here the connection which
we have created say open
and then it says do you want to
import this data or bring this data into
existing worksheet
you can also say add this to a data
model if you are doing some data
modeling so click on ok
and now this data is automatically
inserted in my excel file i can
basically save it
into
this particular sheet now what we can
also do is we can also start a new sheet
and that does not have a data and we can
get some other data from web so what i
can do is i can go into my github
and let's say i would be interested in
this csv file
so i can select this
and this is my github path a path on web
so i can click on draw and that
basically gives me
the raw path where this particular file
is now you can select this
copy this particular path
and here you can come back to your excel
sheet we would be interested in getting
the data from web might be from a text
file where we will have to specify the
delimiters or let's go to web
and here
i can given the web path from where i
would be interested in getting the file
let's give the github path which is
publicly available and then click on
import now once you click on import it
tells me there are two fields data and
value
these are
within double quotes separated by comma
so first let's click on import
now once we do this it will basically
get the data from web and put in here it
says existing worksheet so we had
already created a new worksheet so let's
click on ok
and now you have the data coming in but
then this basically shows me in one
particular field so what we can also do
is we can just do a control a that
selects all my columns here
and that's my data so we can then
basically
filter this out so we can say text to
columns
it's a delimited file click on next
we can select comma and
let the text qualifier be quotes
it shows me data
preview click on next
so you have the general format it shows
the destination that's the column click
on finish and now your data has been
split and you have the data which you
have imported from web so this is the
data which is coming in from web this is
the data which came in from my local
machine and similarly we can even create
connection with an existing database so
i can basically click on connections if
i would want to do that so i have an
option called connection here
and it says where the selected
connections are used
i can basically click on add
i can basically choose
if i would want to get the files from
network or from computer like we did
earlier
i can click on browse for more which
should
show me
different other options to create
connections say you would want to create
a new sql server connection you can
connect to a new data source coming in
from different place you could basically
choose what kind of connection you would
you want so these are all the different
options which we can go for
and we can basically connect to a
database for example
if i have some database
and say for example access database
i can see if there are some files with
that particular database and i can
import it
so similarly we can also
click in here which says new query and
that also gives you an option of getting
the data from your files from all these
folders from databases so you can
basically click here and then you can
import data from a mysql database
provided that is set up on your local
machine or on a particular server you
can go from cloud you can get it from
online services you can get it from
other sources which says from web
from your hadoop file system from active
directory from a blank query and you can
even combine queries wherein you can run
a power query editor
you can get the data from different
sources and then you can bring it into
your excel so in this way you can get
your data from different sources into
your excel into your spreadsheet and
then you can continue working on those
data sets
we have
already learned some basic operations
which you can do in excel and let's
implement our knowledge by working on
this particular data which is coming in
from housing data set now here if we see
some fields we have agent
date listed area list price and this is
basically the data which has been
sorted in newest to oldest order of date
listed
so how do we
arrive at this
so what i can do is i can just click on
data listed
and then i can either
go in here
i can select sort i can get into custom
sort
and then i can choose the column
based on which i would want to sort the
data so i would look for the newest data
to the oldest data that means that would
be in a descending order of dates
or you could say the oldest date or the
earliest month will be towards the lower
side of your sheet so here we can select
date listed now i can say let it sort
based on cell values and the order what
we have here so we have newest to oldest
so let's select this
i can say okay and now if you see the
date has been sorted so we have your
10 18 2007 on the top so that seems to
be the latest date and as we go down we
will see
an earlier month hour
and
earlier month than that in this date
listed so we have sorted our data
into
newest to oldest order and that's based
on your
date column so the result shows up here
now what we can also do is we can have
different questions which we would want
to answer so for example i would want to
sort the data in ascending order of area
and descending order of agent name how
do we do that so let's look into this so
this is here i already have the result
here and how did i get this so i am
looking for ascending order of area in
descending order of agent name so we can
start with any particular column that
does not matter so for example if i look
into this excel sheet i have my agent
name select this which we want in a
descending order so we could either do a
sort and then go for
descending sort z to a we could also use
the filter option here on the top right
and we could do it or i could just say
sort z to a and then it
has arranged the data
based on the agent column being in
descending order now i can go into area
and then i can again do a sort and i
wanted my area column
to be used for sorting the data
ascending to descending
and that basically not only changes the
order of this particular column but for
my complete data so let's do that and
now if you see we have the
data which has been sorted so
we can see how many values we have here
and the area values which we see and
this is how you get your result so i'll
just do a ctrl z
and
again and i'm back to my original data
and this is the sorted result which we
are seeing at
similarly we can answer other questions
for example sort the data according to
the following order
of area
that is we are saying county
central
and then your county so we can basically
choose
in which particular way we would want to
do it so it is county central and then
again county so if i look into my sheet
3 so here i basically have my data which
is
having some south county then you have
your central and then you have your
north county so we would want to
sort the data to solve our problem which
is
according to the following order so
first we go for area then we go for
south county central and north county so
what we can do is we can basically
have area field selected
and i would want to sort this particular
data so i have south county central and
north county so i can basically go for
custom sort
and then i can choose which is the value
or column which i'm interested in let's
go for area
we will go for something like
cell values well you can also try to
explore conditional formatting icon
if this is what you would want to use
or we can basically go for just sell
values
and here we can say
if i would be interested in first
getting my values for
south county so
for example i can say custom list
and then
i can basically given the new list here
so i can say s
dot
county and then i would want central
and then i would want north county
so let's select this
as it exists
we can
basically say add and that's basically
the order which we want to say okay
and then say okay here
and now what we would want is we would
want our data so we can compare that
with the values which we see here it
starts with kelly
you have in the 12th row something like
lang and that's what we are doing so we
can basically arrange the data in a
particular order by choosing a custom
list and then sorting your data
so that's one more simpler task of what
we have done where we have sorted the
data in the order
where
under our area column we first wanted
south county
then we wanted central data and then we
wanted north county so this is how you
can do it
now
let's look into one more problem so it
says find all the houses in the central
area
and we would want to basically apply a
regular filter let's let's see how do we
do that so we can click on this and here
we have the data so the problem
statement is we would want to find all
the houses in central area now how do we
do that we can do a sorting but
we would want to use the filter which
you see here
is implemented so how do you do it so
you can select this area
and say for example i would want to
apply filter i can just go in here and i
can say let's get a filter on my first
row and now i have filters applied so we
are interested in looking into the
central area houses let's go in here
it says
all these fields are selected that means
it shows everything
wherein your area has all these values
let's unselect this and then i will only
be interested in the central so let's
say okay
and then say okay so now you see that
the area
filter has been applied and we are
looking at the central column so what we
have done is we have applied a symbol
filter and we are looking at our data at
any point of time if you do not
want
the filter
then
what i can do is i can select this and i
can say well i'm interested in all the
data so i could do this or you can clear
the filters from area
and you get your data back
so
that's in one way you can filter out
your data so let's look at an example of
sort and filter where we might have to
filter the data based on two columns
or multiple columns with different kind
of values where it could be and and or
condition now say for example this is
the data i have and this is the question
which we need to answer such as find the
list of all houses
in the central region with pool
and south county without pool now if it
was a simple filter based on one cell i
could have
just selected my
header row
i could have then applied the
filter and once i have the filter i can
look in area where i have three regions
so i'm only interested in central and
south county so i can get rid of north
county and that's fine but then
we have two different conditions here so
we need
the
data in central region to have
the value for pool being true
and for south county the value has to be
without pool now how do we do that so
what we can do is we can first create a
copy of these headers here
so let me do that now the area has to be
south county so basically i can
either just select this and i can choose
this value
and then i can select this and then i
can choose central so that's the
criteria which i have
and the pool value has to be
so
central region should be with pool so
then this one
basically has to be true
and this one has to be basically false
so south county is without pool so let's
select one of the values here and this
is my criteria now
to get my result
we can always place your cursor here and
you can check this is m column and
eighth row
okay so we would want the result here so
let's go ahead and now click on data
and then in filter you have an option
called advanced and here what i can do
is i can say i would want to filter the
list in the place but that's not what i
would want to do so i'll say copy to
another location and here if you see the
list range will tell me that this is the
data so a1 to j126 so a to j column
selected and all the rows
criteria range is basically based on
what i have given here so that is m
from 1
to v
which is 3
so i am selecting these columns and then
i am saying all the way whatever
criteria i have given and copy 2 i am
saying m8
to v8 so that basically will give me my
filtered result so you could basically
just say ok
and now i have my data which has been
filtered
and i have my area which is south county
that is without pool central with pool
again south county without pool
and then if you look at your central
value that's pool so this is an advanced
filter which we have applied where
simply we have filtered the data based
on two columns and then we have our
result so in this way you can have your
customized filter applied on two
different columns and get your data
which can be either
replacing the existing content or
in the same sheet in different set of
columns and rows you can have your
result let's look at one more example of
filtering where you are trying to filter
the data based on an and condition
condition being met in two different
columns and then you would want to
filter out the data for only specific
columns so the situation is the agents
with a house in north county that should
be county
area having two
and a single type family so we are
talking about two bedrooms
and
we would basically have a single type
family and here the criteria is that we
would want to
only populate these columns which is
agent area bedroom and type now what you
can do is as i explained earlier that
you can get your result in
the same sheet in a different location
so here i have created these headers
which says agent area bedrooms and type
now this is basically a copy of all the
columns what we have here agent data
listed area list price bedrooms bath
square feet and so on so you can
basically create a copy of the headers
here and this is where we will give our
advanced criteria to filter the data
so the conditions which need to be met
is we need to look at north county
so for example here in area i can
basically go ahead and select one of the
values north county
now the criteria is having two bedrooms
only so let's say
bedrooms and let's say the value should
be two
and then basically i am saying a single
type family so when you would want the
single type family so here under type i
can give the criteria
single type
so
this is my and condition so we are
saying north county area having two
bedrooms and the type is single family
now this is the criteria which basically
means if i select this this one tells me
that this is m
one rho onwards till v
two
so this is what we have
and we would want to filter based on
this so let's go ahead and then go for
data filter advanced
and here in advanced it says filter the
list in place now that's not what we
would want to do so i'll say copy to
another location
this basically selects the list range so
which is telling me
a1
to j126
so that's the
columns and rows selected criteria range
is based on m1 v2 which we have given
here and copy 2 i would say for example
from
m7
to
p7 now this is the area where i would
this is the place where i want the
result let's say okay and now i get my
data which is
based on the question which has been
asked that you would want the agents
with a house in north county area having
two bedrooms and single type family so
in this way you can basically do
advanced filtering
get your data and get it stored in the
sheet anywhere at a different location
well i could have also done filtering in
place and that would have replaced the
data
which we have but that's not what we
want we would want the filtered result
in a different place so this is how you
can do some advanced filtering we can
also use excel to filter out the data in
one particular column which might be
conditional or say
using some numerical filters now here
say for example the problem statement is
that you would want to display all the
houses whose list price is between
45 000 to 600 000
or say for example we would want to
filter out the data to something else
say for example let's say i have
i would want to filter out the data
between 300 000 and 400 000 so we can
basically
update this
say for example i am saying i'm
interested in 300
000
to
400
000 and that's the criteria to filter
out the data now there are two different
ways or there are two easier ways to do
it one is
i would want to
look at the list price so i can select
this
i can go ahead and do a filter here and
in the list price now this is where we
would want to do the filtering so it's
pretty easy you can click on this one
and then you can go into number filters
and you can choose between now that's
one easier way of doing it so i could
basically select this
i could say i'm looking for value which
is greater than or equal to 300 000
and then is less than or equal to 400
000 so if i just do this
i have applied my filter and i have my
data which is filtered based on my
criteria right so that's one easier way
of doing it or let me do a control
z
now
let the filter be there which you can
anyways use but what we can also do is
as we have seen earlier methods so get a
set or get your column headers here
and then
you are giving two columns here now the
only difference between
my
this set of columns which i have one two
three
and then you have 7 and 10 columns and
if you see here
we have 4
5
6 7 8 9 10 11 right so whenever you want
a and condition you will basically
add the columns where i can give add
condition if it is the same column if it
was a different column then it would be
same number of columns but and
conditions will lie in the same line and
all condition would lie in a different
line now here i can give this value so i
am looking for listed price
being
between 300 000 so i am saying it should
be greater than or equal to
300 000 and then i can say less than or
equal to
400 000 now that's my criteria
and then i need my result here which is
in m7
so what i can do is once i have given my
criteria which i'll be using
to filter i can get into data i can get
into advanced
and then i can say copy to another
location
so it is selecting my a1 to j126
criteria range is based on m1 to w
2
and then i would want my result from
this particular column
so let's say okay and now you have your
data filtered out
in a different location in the sheet
which has been filtered based on your
and condition so you can filter out the
data in this way or you could just apply
a filter on a column and give the
conditions
now let's solve one more interesting
problem and here we would want to use
excel where we would have an and and an
or condition so say for example this is
the data given to you and the question
is that you would want to find all the
houses in north county again that's a
spelling mistake but then the
north county area with a list price
greater than 300 000
and having three or four bedrooms so the
bedroom
has conditional so it has or three and
four
and then basically you have
list price which is greater than 300 000
now i could have obviously
selected the columns and then basically
gone for a filter
so i can just do a filtering here
and then i'm looking for list price
being greater than 300 000 so which we
can always give a number filter and i
can say greater than
and then i can say
greater than or equal so i can say
greater than
and then i can give three thousand
thirty three hundred thousand
and that's basically the filter which we
would want
and
here i would want to select the bedrooms
which should be just either three or
four
so if for example here i go in here and
i unselect this and then i say three and
four
right so i am getting my data which is
greater than three hundred thousand and
it should have the bettering values
which will be either three or four
selected now that's one way of doing it
let's do a ctrl z and get it back
to as we were or you can even just say
clear filter so you get your data back
as it was so what we can do is we can
here
give the criteria
so for example i have my
list price now this is what i would want
as a condition so let's say greater than
300 000
300 000 and bedrooms should be three
and then i can say greater than three
hundred thousand
and then i can say four
so this one basically gives me a
situation where your list price has to
be greater than 300 000
and bedroom should be either three or
four so we have given our filtering
criteria now to get the result what we
can do is we can go into data we can go
into advanced
and we can say copy to another location
so our list range is selected which is
columns a to j row number 1 to 126. your
criteria range is given in m1 to v3
where we have specified and we are
saying the result would be in m7 to v7
so if i do this now i have got the same
data which we were seeing earlier and
here the bedroom values are 3 or 4
and basically the list price is greater
than 300 000. so this is a simpler way
in which you can create your filters and
all this advanced filtering what we are
seeing it will be saved with your sheet
you can always go back and change this
value or
you could do filtering where one person
has to look into the filter to see what
values have been selected
now let's understand what is a formula
in excel
in microsoft excel a formula is an
expression that operates on values in a
range of cells
all formulas in excel return a result
even when the result is an error
there are different ways to handling
errors which we'll see later
formulas allow you to perform basic
calculations such as addition
subtraction multiplication and division
you can also find out percentages and
average for a range of cells manipulate
date and time and lots more
now let me open an excel spreadsheet and
show you what a formula is
so here i have my excel worksheet
now let's say
i have some values under this a column
say 20
30 and 40.
now
i want to write a formula that will add
the values that are present from cell a1
to cell a3 so i'll give an equal to sine
and give my
cell green that is e1 plus
a2 plus a3 now if i hit enter it will
give me the addition of 20 plus 30 plus
40 which is 90.
now let's say
i want to divide
40
by
30
if i hit enter it will give me the
division of 40 by 30 which is 1.33 now
let's see what a function is in excel
when you're working in excel you will
often hear the terms formula and
function used frequently and sometimes
interchangeably
they are closely related but not exactly
the same
technically a formula is an expression
that begins with an equal sign functions
are used to perform complex calculations
that cannot be done manually
functions have names that reflect their
intended use
now let me take you back to the excel
sheet
and i'll show you what a function is
suppose
now i want to add
the values ranging from a1
to a4
either you can use a formula like we did
here we wrote a formula using multiple
addition operator
but there is another way which you can
use
that is to write a function
so excel provides a function called sum
that allows you to select a range of
cells so i'll select e1 to a4
and close the bracket and if i hit enter
it will return me the result of 20 plus
30 plus 40 plus 90 which is 180.
similarly there are other functions
let's say i want to find the average of
a range of cells
so you can use the average function to
do that
if i hit tab it will auto complete
i will select the same range of cells
from a1 to e4 and close the bracket if i
hit enter it will return me the average
of these selected cells which is 45. now
that you have understood the basics of
formulas and functions in excel let's
dig deeper into learning the different
types of functions available in excel
and use relevant formulas when needed
along the journey
on your screens you can see we have a
mathematical functions worksheet where
we will learn the different mathematical
functions present in excel
let's begin at looking at the simple
table
that has three columns the quantity
column price per unit and total sales
now let's find the product of quantity
and price per unit to get the total
sales value
for that we will write a formula using
the multiplication operator so here i'll
write the formula i'll give an equal to
sign i'll select the first quantity
multiplication operator and then select
my price per unit
and if i hit enter
it will give me the product of quantity
and price per unit so 10 into 30 is 300
now to copy that formula i will just
drag this down
you can see we have all our total sales
values
now
if you want to find the sum of total
sales you can use the sum function so
here i'll write equal to then use the
sum function i'll open the bracket then
i'll select
my total sales values close the bracket
and i hit enter it will give me the
total sales or the sum of sales
similarly
if you want to find the average of total
sales
you can use the average function so i'll
type average and hit tab it will auto
complete i'll select my sales values
close the bracket if i hit enter it will
give me the average total sales now
there's another function called sum
product that is available in excel
you can use the sum product function to
return the sum of the product of
corresponding ranges or arrays
so let's find the total sales using the
sum product function
the first array we will have the
quantity values while the second array
will have the price per unit
so i'll
select my sum product function
my first array i'll give the quantity
values
i'll give a comma
and i'll select my second array that is
price per unit
close the bracket
hit enter you can see we have the total
sales value that is
1165. now
moving ahead let's understand the types
of logical functions in excel and how
you can use it
to the extreme left
you can see there are a number of
logical functions i have noted here so
you have is even function resort
function is logical and so on
now let's use them one by one and see
how it works
the is even function returns true if the
given number is an even value and it
returns false if it's not an even number
so we have here two numbers 4 and 13.
now if i want to check if 4 is an even
number or not i can use the easement
function so i'll give equal to sign
and type is even
and i'll select this number or the cell
close the bracket
if i hit enter
it will return true because 4 is an even
number
similarly if i have to check for 13
i'll write this even
and select this cell which is a3 close
the bracket
i'll hit enter
it will return false because 13 is not
an even number
similarly
the is odd function returns true if the
given number is odd and it returns false
if it's not an odd number so let's check
if 4 is an odd number or not
so i'll write is
odd
tab
then i'll select this cell
close the bracket hit enter it returns
false because 4 is not an odd number
similarly
let's check for 13 i'll write is odd
select
a7 which has 13
i'll hit enter
it returns true because 13 is an odd
number
now
next we have the is logical function
this logical function returns true if
the given value is a logical value and
it returns false if it's not a logical
value
when i say logical value i mean true or
false now let's check if 30 is a logical
value or not
so i'll write equal to
is logical
let's select 30
if i hit enter
it returns false because 30 is not a
logical number
similarly
let's check for the next two values
i'll select this cell value which has
true in it
if i hit enter it returns true because
true in itself is a logical value
similarly
false should also return true because
it's a logical value
you can see it here then
we have is number function that returns
true if the given value is a number
numbers could be integers floating
values or whole numbers now we have a
number here which is 40.5
let's verify if it's a number or not so
i'll write equal to
then select is number
select the cell close the bracket hit
enter it returns true
similarly you have to check if 30 is a
number or not
you can use the same function which is
is number
select 30 close the bracket hit enter it
returns true because 30 is also a number
now
in the next cell we have a text value
you can see it's cnn so ideally it
should return false because cnn
is not a number there you go it has
returned false because cnn is a text
value and not a number
now let's explore a few other functions
that you can see here so the round
function rounds a number to a specified
number of digits
so suppose i want to round up
35.316 to two decimal places so i'll
write
equal to
and i'll give the round function
i'll provide my number 35.316
comma
since i want to round up to two decimal
places i'll give 2
i'll close the bracket if i hit enter
it gives me the rounded value of 35.316
which is 35.32 now the round down
function rounds a number down towards
zero
so let's see
i'll give the round down function
and i'll provide the same number that is
35.316
let's say
i want to
round down to two decimal places
if i hit enter the result is
35.31 similarly the roundup function
rounds a number up away from zero so
i'll write
round up
i'll give my number 35.316
if i give the number of digits say 2
it will return
35.32 so it rounds up this value
moving ahead
now if you want to convert a number into
integers you can do that using the int
function
so suppose i want to convert
35.316 into integers i can
give my integer function that is int
and provide my number 35.3
close the bracket if i hit enter
so you have the integer value of this
floating point number
similarly if you want to find the
integer of say equal to int
let's say a negative number
minus
35.316
it will return the negative integer
value that is minus 36.
now the truncate function translates a
number to an integer by removing the
decimal of fractional part of a number
so let's say i want to truncate 35.316
i'll write
trunk
which is the truncate function now let
me pass in my number that is 35.316
let's say i want to give the number of
digits as 2
i close the bracket hit enter it returns
me
35.31 so it has truncated the last digit
now similarly
if i
if the number of digits as one the
result will be 35.3
you can see it here
moving ahead
the ceiling function rounds a number up
that is to the nearest multiple of
significance so i'll show you what it
means
i'll use equal to then pass in my
ceiling function
i'll give my number 35.3
if i give say 2
close that returns me 36 because the
nearest highest multiple
of this number is 36.
similarly if i give let's say 5 it will
return 40 because the nearest highest
multiple of this number to 5 is 40.
now
talking about the floor function
the floor function rounds a number down
to the nearest multiple of significance
so for example if i
use the floor function
the same number 35.316
now let's say i want to give the
significance as 2 it will return 34.
the nearest lowest multiple of this
number that is
divisible by 2 is 34.
now if you want to change this number
from 2 to let's say you want to give as
7 if i hit enter it will give 35 because
35 is the nearest
multiple of 7
next let's talk about an important
function called subtotal now subtotal
returns the subtotal in a list or
database the sub maximum minimum sum and
others
let's explore a few of this let's say
i want to use
subtotal function
and let's say i want to find
average you can see here
1 is for average i'll give one
comma
i'll give my reference
this quantity column values
close the bracket
if i hit enter
it will give me the average of the
selected cells from
e2 to e4 now
let's say i want to find the subtotal
and this time i want to
let's say i want to count so i'll give 2
comma
i'll count all the values present
in the selected cells
from e2 to z4 and close the bracket hit
enter it returns me 9. you can see there
are 9 cells that are filled in here
next
let's say this time i want to find the
subtotal and let's take some now so i'll
give
9
comma
let's sum up the
price per unit column so f2 to f4
close the bracket
hit enter you can see the sum of price
per unit is 105.
now let's do one more
use the same subtotal function
now let's say i want to find the maximum
value
from the sales column select my total
sales column
close the bracket
write enter
returns me 480 because that's the
highest or the maximum value of total
sales
now
excel provides a factorial function
called fact so if you want to find the
factorial of a number you can use this
function
so
find out the factorial so i'll use the
fact function
let's say i want to find the factorial
of number five
i'll close it
you can see the factorial of 5 is 120
similarly if you want to find the
factorial
of let's say the number 7
it returns me 1 0 4 0
moving on now you can use the max and
min function to find the maximum and
minimum values in a range of cells so
i'll use the
max function let's say i want to find
the maximum from price per unit since it
has returned me the max that is 40.
similarly you can use the min function
i'll use the same column price per unit
now you can see the minimum value from
price per unit column is 30. excel also
has a function called rand between that
returns a random number between the
numbers you specify so if you want to
generate random numbers you can use 5
square
the result should be 25 you can see it
here
now i want to find the power of 4 raised
to 4
the result is 256.
moving ahead the most function or the
mod function returns the remainder when
a number is divided by a divisor so
let's see how to use it i'll use the mod
function
and give my number 10
let's divide 10 by 3 the result is 1.
now we have a few other numbers let's
try them also
use mod 12 let's say i want to divide 12
by
4
the result is 0 bit 9. similarly let's
see one more
i'll use the count function now let's
see i'll select from g1 to g4 if i close
the bracket hit enter it returns me
three because total sales the first cell
value is not a number it's a character
value hence it's skipped the count of
total sales and it counted the remaining
cells now next moving on to count a
function the county function counts the
number of cells in a range that are not
empty so for example if i use the county
function now let's say i'll select
from l1 to l4
close the break has returned me 3
because we had an empty cell so it
skipped that count and it counted the
remaining cells that were non-empty
similarly let's use the function once
more and type count a now let's say i'll
select from
l 2
to n
4
close the bracket hit enter it gives me
5 because
we have only five values that are bells
are empty so it skipped that count
moving ahead we have the count blank
function now as the function suggests it
counts the number of blank or empty
cells in a specified range of so if i
use count
blank
and let's say i'll select
this range from l1 to l4 close the
bracket
you can see it has returned one because
we had one
empty cell in this range of cells now
let's do one more count
blank
i'll select
from l2 to n4
close the bracket it has returned 4
because we you can see it here we have
3 blank cells here so total 4 hence it
has returned 4.
up next
we have the and function
the and function
checks if all the conditions or
arguments are true
it returns true if all the conditions
are true
if one of the conditions is false then
and function will return false
let's do this with an example
suppose i
write the and function
so the first argument or the parameter
has to be a logical
condition
let's say i'll select from
e2 to e4
and my condition will be
greater than 9 let's see my second
condition
is from f2 to f4
is less than
45 close the bracket hit it returns true
because you can see our first condition
from e2 to e4 all the values are greater
than 9
while the second condition from f2 to f4
all the values are less than 45 so since
both the conditions at one of the values
is not less than 450 you can see we have
a value 480 which is greater than 450
and
our second condition f2 to f4 all the
values are greater than 25 now since one
of the conditions is false
so and function returns false
moving on to or function
the or function checks whether any of
the arguments are true and returns true
if all the arguments do not meet the
condition it will return false so you
have to satisfy all the conditions
in order to return a true value i'll use
the or function now let's say i'll give
my condition from e2 to e4 greater than
15
comma from f2
to
let's say f4
less than 25 it closed the bracket i hit
enter
it has returned me false
because both the arguments are not
satisfying the condition you can see
from e2 to e4 none of the values are
greater than 15 and similarly
from f2 to f4
none of the values are less than 25 now
since both the conditions are false
our or statement false let us take one
more example i'll use the or function
again now the condition will be from g2
to g4 greater than equal to 300 comma
let's say from f2 to f4
less than equal to 40 i'll hit enter
there you go
it has returned us true
because both the conditions are true you
can see if all the values between g2 to
g4 are greater than or equal to 300
similarly all the values from f2 to f4
are less than or equal to 40. now let's
get to our second tab which is character
text functions
here we will learn various character
functions and how you can use them in
excel so first you can see we have is
text function so the is text function
checks if the given value is a text
value and returns true or false so if i
were to check if this value is a text or
not so i can use the is text function
i'll give reference to this cell close
the bracket it returns false because 10
is not a text it's a number similarly
let's check the next one i'll select
cell e3
if i hit enter you can see it has
written true
though the value is 10 but still it's a
text the reason is you can see on top we
have given an apo stop before writing 10
so i'll show it to you here in case i
write 90 hit enter the numbers by
default are right aligned now if i give
an apostol and then write 90 hit enter
it is now a text you can check that
using the x is text function select this
cell close the bracket hit enter it
returns me true so this 90 is a text
value
now similarly let's check for the next
one is equal to
is text
i'll select this cell hit enter it
returns me true because excel is a text
value now the next function we have is
the length function
as the name suggests
the length function returns the number
of characters in a string so it will
count the total characters including
spaces as well as special characters so
let's see how many characters does this
string india has
if i hit enter
it returns five
can count india has in total five
characters
similarly
let's check
for this sentence
i'll write ln which is the length
function
select this cell
close the bracket hit enter
it returns me 28
because it has counted the spaces also
now
there's a function called text that
converts a value to text in a specified
number format so suppose
i want to convert these date values into
text values
in a given number format so i can write
the text function i can give the value
by referencing the cell comma let's say
i want to
print the date value in the form of a
text in this format let's say dd m
and y by close the bracket you can see
this has converted the date value into
ddmy
now similarly you can change the date
value to text in some other format like
dd triple m then 4y and see it returns
30 june
2015
now if this is a text value or not you
can use the same function that is text
and give reference to this cell there
you go it has returned me true which
means it has converted the date values
into text now moving ahead next we have
the replace function the replace
function replaces the part of a text
string within a different text string so
suppose i want to replace
cell a 15 value which is a101 i'll give
my start num as 1
the number of characters let's say 1 and
my new text i want to replace the a
value with b close the bracket if i hit
enter you can see here a101 has become
b101 because we replace the first a
value to b now let's try out a few more
examples i'll use the replace function
i'll give my old text that is
that is a102 i'll give my start num as
one my number of characters as one
let's say the new text i want is a2
close the bracket
you can see it here from our old text
which had a it has replaced with new
text that has a2 now let's say i want to
use the replace function over adam i
will select this cell is 17 now let's
see i the start num is 1 the number of
characters is let's say 2 and i want my
new character as s a close the bracket
you can see it here the first two
characters from adam has been replaced
by s a that is what we did here so we
started our
start number one
then we chose the next two characters
that is a d
and a d we replaced it with s a
so the name becomes sam now moving ahead
the next function we have is substitute
the substitute function replaces
existing text with new text in a text
string for example if i use the
substitute function i'll give my old
text which has i work at simply learn
give a comma now i'll select
let's say i work which is from my old
text and i want to replace it with
he works
close the bracket
you can see
the substitute function has replaced has
replaced the second 2010 from our old
string to 2016. next
let's use the substitute function once
again i'll give the cell reference as
e22
this time i want to replace
2010 present in the old text to 2016.
you can see here at two places there
were 2010 it has replaced it to 2016 at
both the places
then we have the concatenate function
you can see it here concatenate means
combining strings so a concatenate
function joins or merges several text
strings into one text string here i have
two strings hello
and in another cell i have world i want
to concatenate these two strings
so i'll use the
concatenate function i'll select cell
e25
give a comma now i'll give two inverted
commas with a space give another comma
and select cell b25 that has world
close the bracket there you go now it
has concatenated both hello and world
now it's one word hello world similarly
let's concatenate these two cells i'll
use the concatenate function and select
my first cell that has xls
now you can use an amber sent to
concatenate as well
and then give to inverted
commas for space
give another ampersand and select the
next cell close the bracket hit enter
you can see
it has concatenated
the two cells
and it has formed a sentence excel is
fun to learn up next we have the repeat
function
now repeat function or rept function
repeats text a given number of times
you can fill a cell with a number of
instances of a text string now we have
some data here so
here
let's see these are the age groups of
women and there was a survey these are
the number of respondents we got from
each each group i want to create an
histogram i can use the repeat function
or rept function
i want to give my text as a special
character hit a comma
and i'll select
cell b32 which is the number of times i
want to repeat
that character hit enter you can see it
has repeated the special character 10
times now similarly you can do it for
the next few cells also if i just copy
paste this formula it will give me the
result so you can see it looks like a
histogram now let's say i want to repeat
hash tag and add the rate symbol for 10
times so i can write the repeat function
give my text as hashtag and add the rate
and the number of times i want is 10
close the bracket it returns me the
result which has hashtag and add the
rate printed 10 times
moving ahead next we have the type
function
now the type function returns an integer
representing the data type of a value
now here on the right you can see
suppose the type function returns 1 it
means
the value is a number or it's a blank
let's say the return type is 2 it means
the data type is a text
if it's 4 it means the data type is a
logical value that is either true or
false now if it's an error it will
return the value 16
and if it's an array it will return 64.
now let's try these examples
here we have excel
which is a text value
so if i use my type function
and select excel
hit enter it returns me true because
excel is a text value you can see it
here if it's a text it will return 2.
now similarly let's try this one
hundred
it has returned me one because one is a
number so it will return me one fifteen
point four five if i use the type
function fifteen point four five hit
enter so it has returned me
one now you can see these are some
errors now it's an error because we have
divided a 39 by 840 you can see it here
a39 had a text value and a40 had a
numeric value so you cannot obviously
divide a text by a number so it has
returned me an error now if i want to
check the type close the bracket hit
enter it has returned me 16. you can see
it here if if it's an error value it
will return 16. similarly this one more
error here let's try this out use the
type function give this error hit enter
this also has returned 16. now let's
check one more example for an array now
you can write an array inside the type
function itself to write an array we use
curly braces i'll give 1 comma 2 comma 3
and 4 as my array elements
i close the curly braces and the bracket
if i hit enter
it has returned me 64. you can see it
here if it's an array it will return the
data type as 64
which is an array now
there is a function called is blank
which checks if a cell is empty or blank
if it is empty it will return true else
it will return false
now if you were to check
if
this cell is empty or not
if i hit enter
it returns me true because you can see
it here
cell a47
is empty and there's no value in it now
if i want to find out
if cell e 48 is blank or not if i hit
enter it returns me false
because there is a value 40 in it
now
we'll see how to use trim function so
the trim function removes all the
unnecessary spaces from a string
but it won't remove the sink all the
unnecessary spaces except
the space between angela and stephens
i'll copy paste this value to the
remaining cells
you can see it has removed all the
unnecessary spaces from the original
string
now you can check the length once again
for the trimmed string if i hit enter
the length is 15 for defense you can see
it has removed at least six spaces from
the original string now let's copy paste
this formula
it has removed the unnecessary spaces
from all the original strings
next we have the find function so the
find function returns the starting
position of one string within another
string now you should notice that find
function
is case sensitive so
let's
use the find function here i'll write
find
i want to find where capital s is
located in the cell a52 that has angela
stephens into a comma select a52 hit
enter it returns me the starting
position that is 11 now
if i were to check using the find
function this time i want to find where
small e is located within a 52 which has
angela stiffens i'll give a comma and i
want my start num as 1 close the bracket
hit enter it has returned me seven you
can count it here on the top so where
the cursor is is the first position so
i'll now keep shifting 2 3
4
5
cell a52 that has angela stephens
close the bracket hit enter it has
returned me
11.
so basically it has returned me this s
but since search function is case
insensitive so it did not care if it was
an uppercase s or a lowercase s
similarly if i want to find where a is
located or capital a is located in
antonio myno
i'll use the search function
i want to find capital a within text
i'll give
cell a 54.
now let's say i want to give my starting
num as
5
close the bracket
it has returned me 19
so it has returned me this a
because
the only a that exists after 5 is this
so here also since b searched for
capital a but it looked for any a that
was present in antonio mino bit small or
capital
finally we have a clean function
so the clean function returns all
non-printable characters from the text
now you can see here this cell has three
lines of text now if you want to print
this
cell in one line i can use the clean
function
it will remove all the non-printable
characters i'll select cell a67 close
the bracket hit enter there you go it
has printed the address in one line
now
we have one more text which says i hope
you are doing well during the pandemic
now if i want to clean that cell
close the bracket it has printed the
same sentence in one line now there are
a few more functions let's see them one
by one we have a function called upper
so the upper function converts any text
string into uppercase
so we have a string called india now if
i want to convert india into uppercase
i'll use the upper function select that
cell you can see it here it has
converted india into uppercase
characters
similarly you can use the lower function
to convert any text string into lower
case
i'll use the lower function
select that string enter
there you go
so all the letters in the word india has
been converted into lower case now
there's another function called proper
which is used to convert any string into
proper case
so i can write a vlookup function
something like this i'll give equal to
search for vlookup now my vlookup value
will be stewart
with comma
then i'll select my table array
so i'll take my table array from a2
to
c7
if you want you can choose the entire
table also
give a comma
my column index number is this
department column which is the
third column
and range lookup is either true or false
i'll select false
which is 0 for exact match
if i hit enter
you can see it has returned marketing
and in the table also if you see stewart
is from the marketing department so this
is a simple example how you can use
vlookup
now
if you want you can choose the entire
table
so i can select from
a2
to e7 hit enter will give the same
result now suppose i want to find from
the marketing department
so
this is the person who is from the
marketing department i want to find the
city i'll use the vlookup function again
vlookup
now my lookup value is marketing
i meant column
is the leftmost lookup column
select the remaining table give a comma
now my column index number is 2
is the city column
and i'll give my range lookup as 0
because i want the exact match i'll hit
enter because it has returned me the
city to which
this person from the marketing
department belongs to that is kansas
let's see another example
suppose i want to find the city to which
the person with the last name
davis belongs to so i'll write my
vlookup function i'll take my lookup
value as device i'll give a comma
now my table array will start from the
last name column
and let's select the remaining columns
as well
now my
column index number is will be 3
as per our selection
for example let's say we want to find
the first name of the person who is from
los angeles city so we have our lookup
values los angeles and now we want to
find the first name so i'll again use
the lookup function
i'll give my lookup value as los angeles
comma now my lookup vector is the city
column
comma my resultant vector is the first
name column
close the bracket hit enter
you can see it has returned me stewart
which is actually wrong
you see our original table the person
who is from los angeles city is not
stewart
but it's lucy
so the mistake that we did was before
applying the formula we did not sort a
lookup column so let me short this
column in ascending order go to the data
tab i'll sort it i'll click sort now you
can see it has returned me lucy and you
can see there was an error because we
sorted the table so the values changed
so be aware of this
now let's try another example let's say
i want to find the department of the
person who was hired on this particular
date which is 10th of november 2001 so i
can use the lookup function
here better
first i'll
sort this date hired column in ascending
order click on sort now let's find the
department of the person with the last
name as davis
so you can see
davis and
the department it belongs to is sales
so i'll use the hlookup function again
select my lookup value as davis i'll
give a comma now my table array
i'll select from
g2
to m5
now in this selection my row index
number will be 2 which is the department
column give a 0 close the bracket hit
enter
it has returned sales so davis is from
sales department
moving ahead now
let's explore the if function so the if
function in excel checks whether a
condition is satisfied or met
it returns a value if true else it will
return another value if the condition is
not satisfied
so let me use
an if function here
i'll give my logical test as
say the value in cell 11
if it's greater than 5 then i'll return
yes
10
is greater else i'll return
no close the bracket hit enter
you can see the result
it says yes 10 is greater because our
condition 10 is greater than 5
now if i change this value to
4
it returns no because 4 is not greater
than 5. now we have a question here
i want to add
values to this result column
so our condition is
if the player scores more than 50 and
average is more than 42 then he is a
good player else he is not a good player
so we'll return not so good
so we have three player names the runs
they have scored
and the average they have so i'll use
the and give my condition
i'll write equal to
if
now since i am checking for two
conditions that is the player should
score more than
50 and the average should be more than
42
so i'll use and
and clause here
so i'll check
if
p
22 which has the runs is greater than 50
and q
22 is greater than 42
then will return is a
good player
else
not so good
close the bracket now if i hit enter
it has returned me good player because
both runs and averages the meter
condition
now let me copy paste this formula
for this cell you can see michael has
scored 40 runs and his average is also
40.
he's not so good because
our condition was he should have scored
more than 50 and average should be more
than 42. so both the conditions
was not met
the next function we have is
if n a now the if any function
will return the value you specify if the
expression resolves to any value
otherwise it will return the result of
the expression so
i want to find
the department of anthony will now you
can see the first name column there's no
name as anthony let's see what happens
if you want to find the department of
anthony so i'll write equal to if n a
now in value i'll use a vlookup function
i'll give my value as r12 which has
anthony and i'll choose my column as
from o2 to s7
give a comma now the department or the
column index number is 3 which is the
department column
i'll give 0
close the bracket
give another comma
now if the value results in n a
will return
such as
value not
found
hit enter
you can see it here it has returned me
value not found because
our vlookup function could not find any
lookup value as anthony in the first
name column
so it returned value not found
similarly there is one more function
called if a returned value not found
similarly there is one more function
called if error so the if error function
returns the error value if the
expression is an error otherwise it
returns the value of the expression if
there is no error so
these two cells you can see we have some
values 10 and 0 let's say i want to use
the f error function
and
the value i'll give is say i want to
divide
u 3
by
u 4 so i'm dividing 10 by 0
now
if the result is an error we'll return
cannot divide close the bracket hit
enter you can see it has returned me
cannot divide because you cannot divide
a number by zero
hence there was an error so it returned
this value now let's say i want to
divide let's say i want to use the if
error function again
and now i want to divide w3 which has
the value 10 by w4 which is the value 5
i'll give the value if error that is
cannot
divide
if i hit enter
it returns me true because 10 is
divisible by 5 so divided 10 by 5 and
the result was 2.
similarly
let's say i want to find
the city to which
again there is no
anthony try this out i'll use the index
function now the array i will give us
from
z
to ac7
comma my row num is 3 and the column
number i want is 2 close it returns me
davis which is this one the reason being
we skipped the header column our column
was selected from this cell so this is
our first row second row third row so
third row and second column we have
davis similarly let's check for fifth
row and fourth column i'll use the index
function i'll give my array from
z2 to
87 this time i am selecting the entire
table
i will give my row number as 5 and my
column as 4 close the bracket
hit enter
the result it returns is boston you can
see
the fifth row is this one and the fourth
column is city so it returns
boston now the match function
returns the relative position of an item
in an array that matches a specified
value so if you want to find
the position at which
events is located in the table so you
can use the match function something
like this
match i'll take my lookup value as
y 15 which has
evens
comma
now my lookup array
will be
the last name column because events was
from the last name column comma i'll
give 0 for exact match i'll hit enter it
gives me 5. events was present in the
fifth row let's check for boston now
i'll use the match function again my
lookup value will be boston comma my
lookup array will be the city column
comma i want the exact match close the
bracket hit enter
it returns six
so if you start from the beginning here
this is the first row second third
fourth fifth and sixth in sixth row we
have boston now you can use this index
match function to return a value in a
column to the left with vlookup you are
stuck returning a value from a i'll
select my lookup array from z1 to z7
comma
0
i close the brackets
hit enter
it has written kansas
you can see jensen the first name jensen
belong to city kansas
similarly
let's find the city to which the person
with the last name as evens belongs to
so evens you can see from the table
belongs to los angeles let's find out
using our index match function
i'll write index
and then
array i'll give as
ec1 to ec7 comma
my row num
i'll give my match function
lookup value will be evens
which is ab15 comma
lookup array
is
aa12aa7
which is our last name column
and 0.
if i hit enter you can see it has
returned
los angeles
now let's find out the department to
which
zampa belongs to
so i'll use my index function
now i'll select
my array from
aa1
to
ac7
comma
i'll find the row number using the match
function
so my lookup value will be zampa which
is ab18
comma
the lookup array will be
to aa7 comma
zero
i'll close the bracket
give one more comma now i'll find the
column number
i'll again use
my match function to do it so this time
i want to find the
location of department
so i'll give
department that is ab1 as the reference
comma the lookup array will be from a1
to ad1 which are the column headers
comma 0
and i'll close the brackets if i hit
enter
it gives me sales so you can see here
from the table zampa is from the sales
department
so in this way you can use index match
function to find the row number the
column number
and the value you are looking for now
we'll talk about countif countifs sum
ups and average of functions
so you can see i am here in a new tab
now to check these functions i am using
a coronavirus data set you can see it
here
it has a date column then we have
divided the date into day month year
number of cases deaths countries from
which these cases and debts came from
we have the continent and few other
information
so first let's see
what countif function does so the county
function counts the number of cells
within a range that meet the given
condition
so we'll see these functions by taking
an example
so we have a question here we want to
count the number of times afghanistan is
present in the data set so i'll consider
my g column that is countries and
territories
so i'll write my countif function i'll
give my range from g1 to the end of this
g column
i'll give a comma
go to the top
now my criteria will be afghanistan
if you want you can use cell reference
as well
i am typing the country name manually if
i hit enter
it gives me 446 so in this column that
is the g column afghanistan is present
146 times similarly let's count the
number of times india is present in the
data set
so i'll use the county function again
i'll select the same range we give a
comma now my criteria will be india you
can see here india is present 155 times
moving on the next function we'll talk
about is count f's so tiff's function
counts the number of cells specified in
a given set of conditions or criteria
so our question is count the total
number of days in which the cases in
india have been greater than 100 so to
do this
count if's function
i'll select my criteria range
first i'll select the d column
comma
my first criteria is we want to check
for india
and then
my second condition is that the number
of cases has to be greater than 100
so my next criteria range will be the
cases column
comma
and my condition is
greater than 100 close the bracket
hit enter the result is 68.
so a total of 68 days india had
more than 100 cases the next example is
we need to count the number of days in
which the deaths in united states have
been greater than 200. so for that
i'll use the
count ifs function i'll give my criteria
so this time i'm taking my first
criteria as the cases
comma so the cases have to be greater
than 200.
close the bracket hit enter
so you can see the total cases in india
till
third of june have been
more than 2 lakhs now i want to find the
total debts in the united states till
the 3rd of june
i'll use the same
sumif function
now my
first criteria will be the g column
comma
i'll give my second value as
united states of america i'll use the
same format using underscore
states
of
america
comma
now the second range will be the deaths
column
close the bracket hit enter you can see
the total deaths in the united states
till third of june have crossed
one lakh similarly let's now
see our sumifs function so the sumifs
function adds the cells
specified in a given set of conditions
or criteria so we have a question here
we want to find the total cases in
france
on those days where the debts have been
less than 100
so this would be
those days instead of whose okay so
let's see our sumps function now
first we need to
give the sum range
since we want to find the total cases so
we'll give the sum range as
the column e comma now the second
criteria is the countries column so i'll
give the g column and we want to check
for france give that criteria comma the
second criteria is i need to find only
for those days where the debts have been
less than 100
so i'll give the deaths column comma the
criteria should be less than 100.
close the bracket hit enter
this is the result so the total cases in
france on those days where the deaths
have been less than 100 is
20
638.
now let's talk about the average if
function so the average of function
finds the average or the arithmetic mean
of the cells specified by a given
condition or criteria so our question is
we want to find the total average daily
cases in india this is till the 3rd of
june so i'll use the average function
and my first criteria i'll select is the
countries column and my criteria will be
india and then i'll give the range
that is the e column which has the cases
if i hit enter
so these are the daily average cases in
india till the 3rd of june next
let's talk about some date and time
functions in excel
you can see here i am in my date and
time sheet
so
let's start with the today function
the today function returns the current
date
or today's date
so if i write
equal to
today close the bracket hit enter it
will return me today's date which is
28th of july now you can use the now
function which will return the current
date and time value
so if i write equal to
now
if i hit enter you can see it has
returned the current date and the time
so this is basically the system date and
time you can see it here now there's
another function called time the time
function converts hours minutes seconds
given as numbers to an excel serial
number formatted with a time format so
you can see here i'll write the time
function now let's see i'll give my
hours as 20 so it's in 24 hours format
let's say a minute i'll give 40 and
seconds i'll give 20. close the bracket
hit enter the time is
8 40 pm
now you can subtract
the now function from today function to
return the time value so let me show it
to you here
i'll write my now function and i'll
subtract today if i hit enter
it returns me the time this is the
system time now
there's another function in excel called
date diff function which returns the
difference between two dates in terms of
years months and days
now here i have a date of birth which is
30 december 1994
and we have today's date i have used the
today function
if i want to find the age i can use the
datedif function so i'll write date diff
and
in that i'll give my
first date value as the date of birth
which is 30 december 1994
comma
my second date value will be today's
date which is 28th of july
now i want to find the age in terms of
years so within double course i'll give
y i hit enter
it gives me 25 so it has subtracted our
first date value and the second date
value to return the year now the dated
function will always return a whole
number you can see it here this was a
whole number you can use the year frac
function in excel to return the year
fraction representing the number of
whole days between the start date and
the end date so i can use the year frac
function here
right here frag my start date will be my
date of birth
now the end date will be today's day
comma basis
i'll give
1
which is actually it will
divide the actual number of days by the
actual days in a year right enter
it gives me my year fraction which is
25.5763
now let's say
i'll replace one with
let's say two
if i hit enter it gives me
25.95 you can see it here if you give
two it will
divide the actual days by 360. now the
default value is zero moving ahead
we have the
weekday function
now the weekday function returns a
number from 1 to 7 identifying the day
of the week of a date so
let me use the weekday function i'll
give my
serial number as today if i hit enter it
gives me 3.
now
let's say
i want to use the weekday function again
i'll
use
my cell reference e2 which has the
today's date comma
now the return type
i'll give as 2
which means
it starts from monday through sunday so
the first day of the week starts on a
monday and ends on a sunday tip 2 close
the bracket hit enter it gives me 2.
the second day of the week
then you can have your day function
month function and year function
let's explore them one by one so the day
function returns the day of the month it
will have a number between 1 to 31
so 1 means
the beginning of the month and 31 means
the last day of the month
so if i use my day function on
e2 which is today's
date
if i hit enter
it gives me 28 that is 20th of july
similarly let's check for month
i'll give the same cell reference hit
enter it gives me 7 which means the july
month
now let's find the year give the cell
reference hit enter
it returns me the year that is 2020.
now you can extract the hours minutes
and seconds from a time value so
i'll use the r function to get the r
value from
the current time you can see it has
returned 14 which means it's 2 pm now
let's find out the minute also i'll use
the minute function give my
now function hit enter
gives me 19. so it's 2 p.m
and 19 minutes now let's find out the
seconds also i'll give my now function
to get the second also there's another
function in excel called
days
360. so days 360 function returns the
number of days between two dates
based on a 360 day year
so we assume that in a year all the
months have 30 days
so i'll use my
days 360 function
i'll give my
start date
as my date of birth which is b12
comma
the end date
i'll give today's date which is in b13
and the method i'll use is
true which is european method
you can see what the european method
says
says the start dates and end dates that
occur on the 31st day of a month will be
equal to the 30th day of that month
close the bracket hit enter
it gives me
the total number of days that were
between
my first date that is the starting date
and the end date similarly now let's use
d360 once again
i'll give my start date let's say 25th
of june 2020 and my
end date will be today's date so you get
the total number of days that is 33
similarly we have eo month which means
end of month so end of month function
returns the serial number of the last
day of the month before or after a
specified number of months so i'll use
my your month i'll give my start date as
b12 which is my date of birth
and then i want the number of months to
be 10 hit enter you can see it has given
us the next day when the month is ending
so it is 31st of october 1995.
coming to weeknum function the weeknum
function returns
the week number of the year so i'll use
my weeknum function and my serial number
will be today's date comma
the return type i want is
2 so i want my week to begin on a monday
so i'll give 2 close the bracket hit
enter
it gives me 31 so
today's date that is 28th of july is the
31st week of the year let's explore a
few more functions
we have network days and work days now
these are advanced functions
of date and time in excel
now
the network days function returns the
number of whole working days between two
dates
so network days automatically excludes
weekends that is saturday and sunday and
can optionally exclude a list of
holidays supplied as dates
now i have listed down the list of
holidays this is from the u.s calendar
and the list of holidays are for the
current year that is 2020.
so first let's use our network days
function to find the number of working
days between two date values
so i'll write
network days
and let's say i'll give my first date or
the starting date as
1st of july
2020
and i'll give my second date value
as 31st of
july
2020 close the bracket hit enter it
gives me 23.
now let me show you the calendar now
this is the july calendar
if you can see
the first day of july starts on
wednesday
and it ends on friday and in between we
have one two three four five six seven
and eight so total we have eight
weekends
so our nets skipped counting these
weekends
so
since july is at 31 days month it has
subtracted those eight days those were
on weekends so 31 minus 8 is 23 so in
total we have 23 working days in july
now let's say i want to include the
holiday calendar also so i'll use the
network days function again i'll give my
starting the workday function returns
serial number of the date before or
after a specified number of workdays the
excel workday function takes date and
returns the nearest working day in the
future or past it can be used in
logistics to calculate shipping dates
delivery dates that need to take into
account working and non-working days it
automatically excludes weekends that is
saturdays and sundays
so let me use my workday function i'll
give my start date as
1st of july
2020
and the number of days i'll give us 5.
close the bracket hit enter
it has returned me a serial number you
can convert this into a date value so
our next working date after 1st of july
is 8th of july if you see the calendar
we started on first of july so counting
5 days after 1st of july so 1 2 3
4 and 5 so the next working day after 5
days will be 8th of july so it has kept
counting the weekends
4th of july and 5th of july similarly
i'll use the workday function again this
time i'll give my starting date
as 1st of july only and now i want to
find the next working days after five
days and i'll give my holiday list close
the bracket hit enter i can convert this
into a date value you can see it has
given us 9th of july because 5 days we
had a holiday that is 3rd of july which
was an independence day finally let's
move on to our next and the final
section in this tutorial for functions
and formulas we have some financial
functions so these financial functions
are commonly used in banking and
financial sectors let's have a look at
them one by one first we have the pmt
function now the excel pmt function is a
financial function that returns the
periodic payment for a loan the pmt
function can be used to figure out the
future payments for a loan assuming
constant payments and a constant
interest rate so i'll just show you the
arguments the pmt function takes you can
say takes rate in pr or nper pv fp and
type so rate is the interest rate for
the loan nper is the total number of
payments for the loan pv is the future
value of the total value of all loan
payments now fv is the future value or a
cash balance you want after the last
payment is made by default it is 0 type
it is optional when payments are due so
0 means end of period 1 means beginning
of period now let's use the pmt function
to find
the future payments for a loan so i have
my data here on the top
i have my rate as five percent i'll use
cell reference a2 comma
then i want my npr or number of period
so i'll give myself b2
comma
the present value
is my loan amount
that is 2 lakhs
comma
i don't want any future value it give it
as 0
close the bracket hit enter
you can see it has returned us the pmt
amount or the principal amount
now you can see it has given us
a negative number the reason being the
amount is getting deducted from our
present value so to solve this issue
you can give
a negative sign here so if i copy paste
the formula again let me put it in this
cell
equal to i'll paste it
now if i
give a negative sign now i can edit this
instead of 4 i'll give 12 because
we want to find it monthly so we'll
convert our annual interest rate to
monthly interest rate now
and i'll multiply the npr or the number
of periods into 12 and i'll hit enter
so this is our future value or the pmt
monthly moving on
now we have a table here you can see
there have been a series of cash flow
over a period of time
now using this table
i want to use my irr and x irr function
so the irr function in excel returns the
internal rate
of a series of cash flows so if i want
to find the internal
rate of return i'll use the irr function
and
i'll select my values from
b16 to b21
close the bracket
so this is my irr value that is 22
percent
if i want to find the x irr value i'll
use the x irr function that returns the
internal rate for a schedule of cash
flows that occur in irregular intervals
now
for using the x irr function i'll use
this table now you can see it has
irregular cash flows
over a period of time
so let me use my x irr function
i'll give my values ranging from
f
22
to
f27
comma the dates i'll give from
e22 to e27
close the bracket hit enter
this is my x irr value up next
we'll see how to find out the future
value
so for using the future value we use the
fv function in excel
that returns the future value of an
investment you can use the fb function
to get the future value of an investment
assuming periodic constant payments with
a constant interest rate also
so this is my table
so we have an annual interest rate of 10
percent
years we have eight and yearly payment
we have one lakh
now to find the future value i'll use
equal to fv
rate i'll give g4
which is ten percent
comma nper i'll give g5 which is the
number of years that is eight
and yearly payment i'll give one lakh
which is g6
comma
present value
zero type is also zero
hit enter
so this is my future value which is 11
lakhs
43 588.
similarly if you want to
find the present value so you can use
the pv function which returns the
present value of an investment that is
the total amount that a series of future
payments is worth now
so let me use the
pv function
i'll give my rate as 8 percent which is
g13
comma my number of periods is 5 or you
can assume 5 years
comma my pmt or payment per period is
10 000
comma
future value is 0 type is also 0
so this is my present value
up next we have the net present value or
the npv function
so the npv formula or the function
calculates the net present value of an
investment based on a discount rate and
a series of future payments having
negative values and income having
positive values so you can see in the
table here
our investment has a negative value
and our incomes have positive values and
we have a discount rate of 10 percent
now let's find the net present value we
use the npv function now the rate i'll
give is 10
comma how to add multiple columns in
excel now without further ado let's get
started with the practical mode now we
have started our excel worksheet and
here you can see we have employee
details on our worksheet now all of a
sudden uh you wanted to add employee
second name as well or a last name right
so you're a beginner and you don't know
how to add a column or you know you
might be a little ambiguous right so
instead of using this simple step you
might end up creating a whole new sheet
or maybe other approaches as well which
are time consuming so let me give you
this simple step all you have to do is
select the column so here you wanted to
add a last name right so b is your
column with the first name and here you
wanted to add a second name or the last
name which is in between the columns b
and c so remember that excel adds a
column always towards the left side of a
column so here if i if you wanted to add
a column next to v then you want to
select the column c and
right click and select the insert option
so that it can be added in between b and
c which is adjacent to b so let's look
at it right so you have added the
next uh column or a new column right
next to the column b and it's in between
the designation and employee name now
you can add your in a second name so
that's how you create a new column in
excel
now in case if you wanted to you know
create multiple columns altogether so
here we have or here we needed a second
name also
here you have a designation and you
wanted to add another column which you
know assigns manages to the employees
right so let's delete it uh delete the
second column and let me explain you how
what i want to do so here you wanted to
add the second name of the employee and
also the manager of these employees
right so here you wanted to add two
columns altogether right uh and now you
might be wondering could i add two
columns together uh or will it work only
for the one column thing right no it
works for two columns and also more than
two columns altogether so you wanted to
add two columns here right so select the
two columns you can you can select or
you can click on the column c and hold
that left key and drag it along the
right side okay so here i have selected
two columns and here it's three right so
you can see here uh it's one zero four
eight five six seven six r cross 3 c
that means you have selected three
columns if i navigate out of the four
you can see we have selected four
columns right
now
right click and select on insert and
you'll have
four columns in between employee name
and designation now you might have to
add your second name
manager's name manages employee id you
know and the department everything or
you can add anything or any number of
columns in between the existing columns
so that's how you add columns in excel
comparing two different columns or
multiple columns happens to be an
important job when you're working in
data analytics as you have to come up
with some decisive decisions based on
the data
now if you had to do it manually then
you might end up taking hours or even
days based on the data set you're
working with but if i say that you can
do it within minutes then it would be
interesting to work with right now we'll
be doing the same now we'll work on our
sample data set right on my screen
so here we have column one and column
two now our job is to compare the column
one and column two and come up with the
result now the first and the simplest
way to do it is use the built-in
condition formatting which comes with
excel by default
now all you have to do is
select all the data
and navigate to home and in the home go
to styles group and select conditional
formatting
and in conditional formatting you can
see highlight cells
so in that you can use duplicate values
when you click on duplicate values a
small pop-up window will come on your
screen and here you have an option of
choosing whether duplicate or unique so
duplicate means you're comparing the
cells and you can see there are some
duplicate cells which are present in
column one are also present in column
two now you can also check how to
uh you know find out the unique values
which are only present in column one but
not in column two so you can just press
unique and there you go you can find it
now you can also try to you know change
the color by filling with green for the
unique columns and duplicate cells with
color red
now this was the first method and you
can also work out some different ones
like you can just directly
press equal to and select the cell
and
equals to and the next cell
press enter
and if there is a match it will give you
true if there is no match then it will
give you false now you can drag it down
and see which all are matching and which
color are not
now you can also make some minute
modifications to this
so
if in case you didn't find the data then
you can say not found so for that
you can try
if and inside brackets
and then
you can give the value as not found
if true it's found first you have to
give the true values so for true you can
write it as found and in case if it's
not found then you can write it down as
not found
there you go close the bracket press
enter
and there you go if there is a perfect
match you will have found and if there
is no match then you'll get not found
now so far we have discussed comparing
two cells using conditional formatting
and also by using equals two operator
and trying to uh add some tweaks to the
equals to operator by involving with f
operator and apart from those we also
have another way to compare two columns
in excel so another way is using the
lookup functions so we'll use a simple
vlookup function to compare both the
cells
so for that let's type in equals to
vlookup
space and
select the cell you want to
check for and then
the
range of elements you want to
compare and then i'll press f4 to log
them
now
you want the data from column one
and now you want the exact match so zero
press enter
so there you go
so
the elements which are present in column
one and column two are been displayed
here so but in case if the elements are
not found you'll get an error so let's
look at that simply drag the
formula to all the cells and there you
go so the elements which are matching
will give you the proper result but the
ones which are not matching will give
you not applicable or error message this
can be fixed we can make some minor
tweaks to the same formula
so
we can add if
error
comma
simply
write in as not found
and close the bracket
so that should do
so we have closed the bracket and press
enter there you go now simply drag this
and
soon you can see the data which is
having no match is shown as not found
now
uh there is another possibility okay
let's get back to
another different sheet so this should
work
so uh we already have the formula so
let's erase that first
i'll erase the whole data
and even this one
yeah now we have the clear column four
so here you can see we have for india
and here you can see we have just four
and similarly here you have mahendra and
mahindra and here you have mahendra
right
so in some situations you might have to
compare
two different columns
but the names might be a little
different right so for example uh if
you're working with oracle and if you're
working with oracle america
and you have in the first cases oracle
and the second column is oracle america
then
those are one and same but you have some
minor text changes right just like here
you have for india and here you have
four
so what if you had such kind of issues
so you can also make some minor tweaks
to it so using the same lookup formula
you can add equals to
vlookup
and
also the comparison cell which is this
one
and you're not you're not stopping there
you're trying to add
the wild card here so the wild card is
hast which means if there is anything
like
if you get the comparison between the
first cell and the second cell which
matches and if there is anything extra
rather than the actual cell please try
to consider it so that's what we are
going to do so after ending entering the
wildcard symbol you'll select the range
of columns which you have to
uh you know fetch the data from
and then try to fix them using function
key f4
you're looking from the column number
one and then you're finding the exact
match now you can close it and enter
now let's try to drag it
there you go
so you have the data mahindra and
mahindra
hyundai india honda india how to freeze
rows in excel
now we might want to start our practical
mode so currently we are on excel and
this is a spreadsheet data
so here you can see
columns and rows so especially the
fourth row and the column c
right so uh currently we have data on
our spreadsheet and it is exceeding the
number of rows currently visible on our
screen right so when you scroll down you
can see that the header or the headers
of all the columns are getting vanished
or scrolled up along with the data right
and you might want to keep that so that
you'll have reference to every single
aspect of or every single cell data
you're referring to right so for that
reason you might want to freeze this
and also you might have a doubt what if
even even i had this data in the column
section right and what if i had to
freeze that and you know when you scroll
this and keep that data
set on the column as it is right so we
can also do that let's look at both of
them
so
there is a simple process to do that all
you have to do is select the cell
or for which you want to you know set
the or freeze the column adjacent to it
or the row adjacent to it right so
currently you want to let me expand it
so currently i want to freeze this
particular row right and this particular
column so the cell i would be selecting
is the first cell here that is
d5
right so when i select this particular
cell i can be able to freeze this
particular row and this particular
column
so now you need to navigate to the
toolbar and then select the view
menu and inside view option you can see
there is an option of freeze panes right
so
click on the drop down so you can see
three different options as we discussed
earlier we can either choose to freeze
an entire row that is the second option
or you can freeze the entire column that
is the third option or you can freeze
both that is the first option
right freezing rows and columns so let's
select this one and see if our rows and
columns are frozen or not right so now
let's scroll down and you can see our
row is successfully frozen there right
and similarly scroll towards right and
you can see our column has been
successfully frozen right so this is how
you freeze rows and columns or you can
freeze panes in excel so with that we
have come to an end of this tutorial on
how to freeze rows or how to freeze
columns or how to freeze both the pins
in excel spreadsheet lock or protect
cells in excel now let's get back into
the practical mode and start our
microsoft excel now we are on the
microsoft excel and this particular
spreadsheet is related to employee
details
yeah now the screen is visible a bit
better
now let us imagine that this is our
confidential data
and you want to edit only two columns
that is the designation column and phone
number column now let us imagine that
the company has finished one annual year
and now there are some promotions
happening in the company and let us also
imagine that the phone numbers of the
employees provided by the company have
undergone some changes
so now the minor edits that you want to
make are related to the designation
column and phone number column now you
can see that all the columns that is the
blood group new salary salary hike
current salary and name of the employee
serial number employee number everything
is editable so in such kind of scenarios
when you pass on this data there might
be a possibility where your colleague or
subordinate might end up making some
mistakes right so you want to avoid that
so you can do that by locking the cells
now let us rename the sheet
now the sheet has been renamed
successfully so now you can log the
cells by the following process
so in this process you have two major
steps first one is to log the cells and
the next one is to protect the cells by
a password
now when you select all the cells in
this particular sheet you can just click
on this edge here and you have all the
cells selected and now right click
somewhere on the sheet and you can see
an option called format cells
so in this particular option you have
some options provided which is number
alignment font and you want to go into
the protection part so you can see
by default excel
keeps all the cells locked
now we want the phone number and
designation to be unlocked okay so let's
cancel it for now and get back to the
sheet and select the columns d
and i
and now let's right click and
go into format cells and in the
protection option make sure that you
uncheck the locked icon
now select ok and now
okay so you cannot include the merge the
cell fine we have a cell here which is
merged okay let's remove
that okay now again select the entire
column
right click
get into format cells
and uncheck the lock option select ok
now we have finished the first part that
is locking all the cells which you don't
want to get edit and unlocking the cells
where you want to make some edits now
the second stage is protecting the sheet
now right click on the sheet name and
you can see an option called protect
sheet click that and now here you can
see select log cells and also select
unlock cells so let us provide a
password here so
let us use some simple password so that
we don't forget that so i will be
selecting one two three
and now select ok
re-enter the password to proceed now let
us type one two three again
now select ok and now the sheet is
protected
now we have successfully
locked and protected all the cells in
excel
now let us verify that the cells you
wanted to protect are really protected
and locked or not so we have unlocked
phone number and designation and
everything else is locked now let me try
and edit the blood group so when i
double click or try to edit this
particular sheet then i'll be receiving
a warning from excel it says the cell or
chart you're trying to change is on a
protected sheet to make a change
unprotect the sheet you might be
requested to enter a password
so it says that this particular cell is
locked and you cannot edit it now let us
try to edit the phone numbers which we
kept as unlocked
so you can see i can really edit the
unlocked cell here now let me try to
change this phone number let me enter
some random phone number
so you can see the cell is editable
now let us go through the designation
column and try to
edit this particular column now since i
said that there is a promotion happening
in the company so the deputy ceo is now
the current ceo of the company
and the software developer happens to
become the senior software developer
and the tester as well
let us imagine that he will become the
senior
and so on
okay
so this proves that this particular
sheet is editable not the entire sheet
but only the sense that we kept in the
analog mode
okay
now this is how you lock and protect
your cells in excel
how to merge cells in excel
so let's get started and let's begin
with our practical mode so we are in
practical mode and we have started our
microsoft excel and you can see on my
screen we have the sales data of one
single employee in the month of january
okay so this is the sales data of john
in january sales
now let us imagine that
we have the same person's or same john's
data of sales of all the three months
okay so here we have the sales data of
john for january february and march
and you wanted to club all these three
months and write it down as quarter one
right
so let us try doing it
now you can see that
only january is replaced as quarter one
and february and march are still
remaining the same
so let us try to delete them
so we have deleted them and i think now
it looks like uh this is a sales data of
one single quarter that is quarter one
but again
quarter one is under column b and anyone
who looks at it feels like this data is
of january february and march and all
the quarter one details are only present
in b column but c and d are completely
you know different from this one right
so you don't want that kind of an
impression on your uh you know the one
who are presenting to you so in those
situations you want to merge all these
three columns and make sure that the
quarter one is present somewhere in
between the cells so that all the data
looks relevant and uh it defines that
these data elements belong to photo one
right so there is an option in excel to
do that so select all the cells that you
want to merge and go into home button
and in home button get into the
alignment group and select merge and
center so you can do it directly also
you have a couple of more options there
is merge and center merge across merge
cells and unmerge so we'll go through it
one by one so first we'll go through
merge and center
so there you go the cell's got merged
and it has been aligned into center
now again if your manager or anyone
superior to you wants this to be you
know independent like they want it to be
in terms of january february and march
so that they can have access to it and
month-wise so you want to unmerge it
back right how to do that now so the
same menu and select unmerge and there
you go you have your data back in the
original form again all you have to do
is you know rename a few cells
there you go
and you have it back right so in a few
situations okay you can also add the
borders so that it looks more relevant
now um
let's try to merge this again and watch
and center yeah
now again uh
let us imagine that you are going
through an appraisal cycle and you also
wanted to add some comments about the
sales happening in your company uh
regarding uh all the employees right so
also we have that here now let me expand
a little bit
yeah okay
so again let's merge and center
now
uh you wanted to you know
you wanted to take a review of your
level one level two and level three
managers
so you have all the three uh
rows here but you can see the cells are
not merged
and you wanted to merge every single row
so merging and centering everything row
wise would be a little time consuming i
mean three columns is okay but what if
you had like uh you had to take a review
from
a couple of more managers like five to
ten right
or imagine that
you wanted to write some random comments
apart from review you wanted to write
some random comments based on month-wise
uh sales or something like that so it
would be time consuming right so apart
from that you have another option where
you you know select all the cells and
come over here and select the option of
merge across
and all the cells will be merged all
together at once and you will be having
those individual rows where you can
write down your reviews like review one
and so on review
two right so this is how the option of
much across works and we already have
them through the
merchant center and merge is completely
similar to margin center so this is how
margin center merge sells and
merge across and unmerge cells and excel
works how to convert rows to columns in
excel
so for that we might want to get started
with our practical mode now you can see
i'm on my excel worksheet and i have one
table on my worksheet right now
so
you can you know transposing or you know
converting rows to columns is a very
simple task i'll explain you in two
different ways
so the first way select all the cells
that you have on your sheet and
press on ctrl c so it will give you the
copy option
and then you can also paste in the same
sheet or if you want you can go to a
whole new sheet and
select the paste option over here but
before selecting the actual paste option
you can see a small drop down icon click
on that
and navigate to paste special
and in this you can see transpose option
click on that or you know make sure that
it's checked and press ok now you can
see all your columns have been converted
into rows and all your rows are
converted into columns so this was the
first way and
what as the second way you ask me so
it's really simple
select one cell somewhere
and you know you can or let's create a
new sheet as well so here you can you
know write down the formula as transpose
and select the array which you want to
transpose
so this is the array
so transpose is basically an array
function in excel so once you are done
with your selecting your data
press enter there you go so all your
rows are now columns and all your
columns are now the rows how to add
filters in excel
now it is really simple to add filters
in excel so we are on a practical mode
right now so on my screen you can see an
excel spreadsheet of sales data so here
you have various columns regions
category state subcategory sales
quantity and much more right so now let
us imagine that we want to add filters
on the region part so we have south west
east etcetera right so we want to you
know let us imagine that you want to
extract the data of only west region and
you wanted a filter so doing it manually
could take a lot of time so using
filters will be helpful now select one
cell on the headers part
and select the filter option in the data
toolbar you can see the date option in
the toolbar right so click on the data
option and navigate to sort and filter
group and in that select the option of
filter now you can see the filters are
been added to all the column headers
region category state subcategory sales
quantity right now we wanted the west
category so when you see or when you
click on the drop down icon you can see
all the options are selected right the
central east west south every everything
right but now we just want best one so
click on west and select ok there you go
so you have everything from the west
region now let's imagine that you wanted
to
look into uh office supplies only or
technology only right you can do the
same with the technology and press ok
and now you'll have all the technology
related sales in the west region right
so that's how you use filters in excel
or that's how you add filters in excel
so slices in excel are software filters
used along with excel tables or excel
pivot tables over a large amount of data
not just filtering out data but slices
also help you with an easy understanding
of the information being extracted and
displayed on the screen
now microsoft excel slices are
compatible with windows and macintosh
operating systems now let us understand
how to implement slicers in excel so for
that we might want to get back to the
practical mode that is starting our
microsoft excel
now we are on our excel sheet and as you
can see on my screen there is some data
available on the excel spreadsheet and
this table is not just any table
this table from microsoft excel is been
converted into an actual table as you
know by default excel considers all the
data which has been inserted into the
spreadsheet as a database and to
implement the slices in excel we might
want to create or
convert the format of database into a
normal table for that you can select all
your data and just press ctrl t
and that will allow you an option called
convert the data into table
now since this table is already
converted as a table we can directly
start implementing or inserting slices
into the spreadsheet
now for that
select all your data
then go into the insert option
and in the insert ribbon you can see the
filters group and in the filters group
select the option called slicer now you
will be provided with multiple options
since we have the columns employ id
employee name zone designation
department salary employees date of
birth and employee state of joining so
we can choose any of the options
available according to our columns and
create the slices
now let me select the first one that is
zone next designation
department and let's also select
employee name
now press ok and there you go we have
our slicers
now let us try to rearrange these slices
all you can do is just select and drag
them up
and done
now let us imagine that we want to see
or take a look at the employees who are
working in the east zone then we have
all the information displayed on the
screen who are working in the east zone
they are jack tony banner fred etc and
their department designation etc etc all
on one single screen so this really
helps you while you're presenting your
data in a presentation
now for a change let's try to select the
department
now if your client wants to select the
data
from only analytics department then you
might want to select on the analytics
key on the department slicer and there
you go you have an employee called luke
hopps who works in the east zone and his
department is analytics and his
designation is contract based and the
salary he is getting is 65 000.
now similarly
uh you can see that we have only
selected analytics and
your client also wants data from it
support now you can see that analytics
is gone
but what if you want both analytics and
id support then you have an option
called select multiple
then you can select analytics and it is
supported if you want hr you can also do
that
and in the zone if you want
west along with east then you can do the
same east and west and you have all the
employee details
and at the designation let's try to
select
senior trainee
okay select multiple senior trainee and
manager so that's how you do it
so that's how it's done and that's how
you implement slicers in excel to
simplify the filtering options using
slicers during a presentation and with
that we have come to an end of this
tutorial on slicers in excel
sumifs in excel
so what is sumifs in excel
now you might want to calculate uh the
total sum of sales right so let us
assume that this is your entire store's
sales data and you wanted to calculate
the entire sum of sales so there is a
sum function in excel where you just
have to you know select all the cells
and apply some function onto it and
you'll get the sum of all the sales
right so with something like this you'll
select all the cells and then you'll
apply a sums function and you'll get the
sum here and average everything right so
this is fine but what if you just wanted
to find the sales that are happening in
only western region as you can see our
column f is based on region so we have
four regions south west east and central
so your manager asks you to find the
sales happening in suppose say a west
region so how do you calculate it would
you manually go into each cell and check
if it's worse than calculate that will
be time consuming right so what if you
had a method which could do it for you
just in a matter of few steps or few
clicks right so that's exactly sums so
it will basically add a condition
calculate the sum of sales where the
region is equals to west simple to like
or similar to sql query right so that is
exactly what we're going to do in excel
today that is using summits now let me
add here sales of
west region
now in the next cell let's add a sumifs
function remember there are multiple sum
functions in excel so when you type in
s-u-n you can see so many options based
on sum right you just have some followed
by that you have some if
it is just some if not some f's today we
are concentrating on some f's so
not just somewhere we'll go to some f's
so we'll be having an option of placing
multiple if conditions there so let's
also try that more on that later now
let's press tab to select our sumifs
function
now okay we forgot another important
step so before we apply sumifs we need
to convert our table into
a table format yes it looks stable but
right now it's not in tabular format it
is in the format of database we know
that microsoft excel considers its data
as a database by default so to convert
the database into table just click
anywhere on the data and press ctrl t so
that you'll have a new dialog box and it
will ask if your table has headers just
make sure that you have ticked in it our
table does have headers so select ok
now our database has been converted into
a perfect table and it's ready for
applying summers function so now you can
see our database has been successfully
converted into a table now let's begin
with our summits now again remember we
are using some f's here not some f or
sum
so select sum if and press tab
and we have our sums function now the
first step which column are we looking
at what are we finding out right which
is the sum range what sum do you want
for now we need
some of sales so select the sales column
and we have a simple key function here
let's hold ctrl again press shift and
hold shift together so we're holding
ctrl and shift key together and now we
are pressing lower arrow key once yes
the entire sales column has been
selected comma
now where do you want to look so we want
to look i mean which part of the table
you want to fetch right so this is the
region part we want to fetch right now
so again hold ctrl and shift together
lower arrow key the entire column is
selected
now the next last part so we want to
look into the both of the columns that
is sales column and region column now
which type of data you want so for now
we want to western type of data that is
the sales data which is happening only
in west right so we'll select this cell
with
the data as west or you can also
manually enter it for now let's select
the data so i'm selecting the cell f7
which has a data as west
right now let's close the parenthesis
and press enter so there you go you have
the sales happening in the western
region now you can also try to format it
in the form of currency so let's use uh
dollars
since it is based on american states so
let's use dollars so there you go now we
are having the sales data of west now
let's try to copy the same to all the
four cells and
for now here let's type in east
and this can be
south
right and this can be your central
there you go
right
now you can also copy the same formula
and make minor edits to it so here
instead of f8 you can select a east
so where is east here
and press enter so you have the sales
related to east now let's try to edit
f9 with south
select south region enter so you have
south sales and what remaining is
central so let's edit central as well
and press enter so there you go right
now you have all the separate sales data
from west east south and central
now again
uh you might want a bit more granularity
in data right or in your reports right
like you wanted to find the sales data
happening in west and you wanted to find
out the category based on only
furnitures so your manager will ask you
okay a fantastic job so now just give me
another minute detail on the data i want
to calculate the sales happening on list
based on category furniture
right so he wants furniture or he wants
to offer supplies only right you can
also do that it's not an issue at all
now let's try to copy this cell and
paste it here and sales invest let's add
another input here on furniture
right now you wanted to calculate the
sales happening in west region only on
furniture so you can also do that now we
can use the same formula as well just
copy paste the formula here right and
you can add a few things here when you
try to add a comma
it will automatically generate the next
criteria so it is expecting that you are
looking for adding another criteria
right now which column you want you want
category so let's select category you
want to select all the cells same trick
control shift lower key
and again press comma
and you wanted to select only
furniture so select on furniture cell
then now press enter so there you go we
successfully have the sales data from
west region based on category only
furniture so that's how you do sum-ups
in excel you can also add a few more
details to it like in furniture you can
also look only for tables so here you
can see in west region we have furniture
sales data and we have sales data of
west region based on furniture which
includes only tables you can also do
that using summers function in the same
way all you have to do is select the sub
category column and select the cell
which has the data as tables
sake in excel
so for this tutorial we'll be
considering the students database
now let's get back to the excel
so now we are on the excel sheet and you
can see that in this particular excel
sheet we have some student details we
have the serial numbers names role
numbers class blood group and some
subjects like math science computer
statistics social gk and the final marks
obtained percentage and total marks
right
so let us imagine that uh
a company has come for an interview
so all these students are going to
attend an interview and the minimum
percentage to attend the interview will
be like 75 percent so you can see that
we have 75 here and all the students
have got above 75 except for the one
student who watches mike
right so for mike to attend the
interview he needs 75 percentage or apa
so
he can make some modifications in one of
these subjects right so there is always
an
exam after the exam called as
improvement exam so if you can
like to score some extra marks in the
subjects which you have scored less so
that you can make up to the percentage
what you're expecting you can do that so
here in this particular sheet
uh mike has six subjects right and in
six subjects you can see he has code 76
91 45 71 94 and 62. so out of these he
have scored less in one subject
compared to all the subjects one subject
is really low that is computers
so
what if he can give an improvement exam
and increase his percentage to 75 right
so that can be done so if we can do some
brute force methods like we can change
the marks like 55 and then check this
particular one so it's getting 74 right
so using the brute force method will be
a little bit lengthy
so
you can do this because it is just a
small
table which has least number of data and
you just have one single cell to modify
so that can be done in small tables but
what if you had some table with hundreds
of rows or thousands of rows that will
be time consuming right so for that we
have some
inbuilt functionality in excel that is
called
goal seek in excel
so for now let's eliminate the marks
here
so we have eliminated the marks and the
upgraded percentage is 65 now we need
the target as 75
okay
so let's
write it as
mike's target right we need mike so
mike's
new target as
75
[Music]
okay
now to make sure that we need a mark
here which can get mic to 75 percentage
we will use the data operation so here
on the toolbar which has file
home
insert etc we have one other option
called as data
so when you click on data from toolbar
you'll have this ribbon and in this
ribbon we have various options so when
you come into forecast group we have an
option called what if analysis when you
click on what-if analysis you will have
a set of options out of which we have
goal seek
now for goal seek we need to select a
table cell that is this particular table
cell that is m9
so we need the value 75 here right so
what is the cell that you need to change
here for that you need to select this
one and select this particular cell here
right and now you can select ok
now you can see that excel has
automatically run all the permutations
and combinations and has come up with a
number so that the overall percentage of
mic will be 75 percent right so the
expected marks that
mike should be getting in his computer's
improvement exam should be equal to 56
or greater than 56 to get the final
target as 75 so that he can attend the
company's interview so this is how we
use goal set or goal seek in excel how
to create drop down list in excel now
for that we might want to switch to the
practical mode
now we are on our excel spreadsheet and
here you can see i'm trying to create an
calendar for the employees in the
company where you might have to you know
write down the
day and month and year or week of your
birth date or maybe your joining day or
maybe also your last working day right
this might be useful for all the
employees to you know
avoid them from writing it down manually
so how do i create it so it takes a few
simple steps all it takes is some data
validation methods and also there is an
exclusive video specifically made on
data validation in excel link to which
is in the description box below or you
can search it on our official youtube
channel
now you can see that uh the word
calendar is on the first cell that is a1
but we have four cells below it that is
a3 b3 c3 and d3 so you might want to add
this to all the cells right like maybe
in the middle so for that you can do the
option of margin center also there is a
tutorial on version center about all the
options available in this particular
thing so you can go through that also
and yeah we have done the first step now
all we need is day month year and a week
so in a calendar or in a month you'll
have days from 28 29 30 or 31 days right
so
let's create a list or the drop down
menu for that so that whenever you click
it right so whenever you click on that
particular cell you will have the list
of
all the days available right so
let's get started with that
let's create a new sheet so why are we
creating a new sheet you won't want that
all the numbers in your calendar sheet
right over here right so for that so we
are creating a new sheet and all the
data will be available here
so here let's write down the days first
and here
the second number also you can use the
option of flash fill so that you can you
know uh
reduce the effort here so you can see
the flash full option over here all you
need to do is select the cells and drag
them down
until you get your required dates right
so let's keep it to
31 days like you have the days
so these will be
your days and
here
now the next option was month right yeah
month and year
now using the same flash fill option you
will
you know add the months into your sheet
so this will be
sunday
so excel has this smart flash full
option where you can just drag the data
and everything will be filled according
to your requirements so sunday to
saturday
now the next one right that is your
month
so same as the before process will
create
january
and you can use the flash fill option
and all the way up to december now the
last one was the year
so
in 1990
and
1991
so you can select the cells and flash
fill
up to
2022 maybe
yeah 2022 should be good enough
now this is the flashful option you have
here and also we have an exclusive
tutorial on flash fill all together you
can go through it for a detailed
explanation as well now coming back to
the original sheet
so this is where you create your
drop down list right so select the cell
where you want to add the drop down list
navigate to data and then here is your
data validation menu
so we have a variety of data validation
options over here there is an exclusive
tutorial on that you can go through it
for now we will look into the list
option only
because we want to create a drop down
list right so here it will ask for
source
click on the source here the source bar
right
now navigate to sheet number two where
we have the days options
select the range
so this will be your range
and select ok
also you can add some message here right
what you can do is
uh in case if there is an error or
something right you don't want that to
be happening so all you need to do is
write down select from drop down
select from drop down only
so this could be a message select from
drop down only the title is
select options or just options
in case if there is an error you can
write down your title as invalid data
and you can write down the messages
please select
drop down only
so
in case of someone tries to write as 32
or 33 to check the integrity of your
data validation then they will encounter
an error and an error message and then
they must be understanding
what exactly they try to do and if it's
correct or wrong right so this is to
make sure that whatever the data you
enter is correct and valid
so okay and here you can see select from
the drop down list only options with
option list has title and let's try to
enter 32 right and when you press enter
you will see
an error
so the error messages invalid data
please try to select from drop down only
so you can go for a retry and select the
drop down right
so let's eliminate them and
now select something from the drop down
so let's take it as
maybe 10
right so this is how you clear the day
one now let's try to do with the month
same data validation option
settings will be list
and source will be
this one
i think i made a mistake here so let's
cancel this and go back to sheet2 and
rename this as our week
yeah now coming back to the month again
it will be a list
and the source will be in sheet 2
navigate to the sheet 2 and select your
range
and the input message the same options
select from drop down only
error alert title will be invalid data
this one will be
please select
from
drop down
only
okay and that's done
now let's continue with here as well
let's quickly do the same
it will be a list
source will be
in sheet 2.
this is your list press ok
and lastly the week
same
process
it will be a list
source will be in your sheet too
the input message
options
title invalid data
let's drop down
only
right so your drop down list is ready
now so the month will be anything so
currently we have me
and the year can be anything anywhere so
let's take it as 1997
and we can be
you know the adjacent week and so what
was 10th of may 1997
let's check our calendars
it was a saturday
so it was a saturday and that's how you
create a drop down list in excel and if
you want you can also add borders to
your calendar
right
so that's how it's done
how to calculate h and xl so for that
let's get back to the practical mode and
you can see now we are on our excel
spreadsheet and you can see we have a
column of date and on the column b we
have age now how do you calculate the
age using the date of birth so this is
completely simple all you have to use is
the dated if function or if you also
call it as date diff function based on
your choice we also have a specific
entire tutorial based on date diff in
excel for further information that video
will be linked in the description box
below you can go through it or you can
use the end screens and i cards link to
this video to get back to the tutorial
based on date diff in excel now let's
calculate the age of these dates or
these people with these date of births
so all you have to do is
type equals to and type
dated f
and open a bracket we need three
parameters here that is the date of
birth
that is the first parameter now the
second one is the
today function because you're
calculating the age of these people as
per today right so we have a today
function in excel press on tab to select
it and give a close bracket now come up
and if you wanted to calculate the h in
terms of days you have to
you know give d as the input
yeah here it should be d as the input
and don't forget to use the double
quotes here and if you use the single
quotes they might be an error so use
double quotes if you want it in the days
part you can give days and if you wanted
in months you can give months for now we
want an ear so we will be giving y as
the third parameter and press enter
there you go we have the h here in 26
years you can drag the same function and
you have the ages here as you wanted
right so this is how you calculate age
in excel how to calculate time
difference between two different timings
using excel
now let's get on to the practical mode
now we are on our excel spreadsheet as
you can see on my excel spreadsheet let
me expand it
we have two different timings that is in
and out so here we are considering a
scenario where we are calculating the
total number of hours worked by an
employee in an organization
so the end time will be the time where
the employee logged in and the out time
will be the time when the employee
logged out
so here we have made some minor cell
formatting so when you right click on
any of the cell you can get back to the
formatting sales option and in that
option we have selected the am pm so
there is also another option of choosing
the 24 hour timing that is 13 20
13 30 so this represents the 24 hour
format
but since we are you know working on
office timings let's keep it as am pm
okay so there you go so we have our
timings of in and out now to calculate
the time difference between the in time
and r time so this particular
calculation is completely simple all you
have to do is press equals to select out
time minus select in time so there you
go press enter and you have the total
number of hours the employee has been
working in your organization so here
also we have made some minor cell
formatting
so usually it comes out as am pm right
but instead of that we have made a minor
cell formatting we have navigated into
time and we have selected the 24 hour
formatting so that we have just ours in
our output so that's how we have
calculated the time difference between
two in times and out times of an
employee using excel calculating
percentage in excel
now let's get into practical mode
so on my screen you can see a simple
spreadsheet with student names and their
marks on my sheet
so we will be calculating what are the
total marks obtained by the students in
overall subjects and calculate what is
the percentage now we will carry forward
a few simple inbuilt functions in excel
to calculate that
first we will be calculating the sum of
marks so here
equals to
sum function
and select the range of cells
close the bracket press enter
so you have the sum now
so we have to calculate it repeat so by
clicking on the same formula now we have
the total of all the subjects for
individual students and now let's
calculate percentage so usually we use
the you know divide by option that is
divide the total number of marks
obtained by the total number of marks
available that is we will be dividing
4.7 by 500 and then we will be
multiplying that into 100 so that's how
we calculate the percentage
so
cell
g2
divided by
cell h2 press enter and you will end up
with you know
the decimal format
that's perfectly all right now we have
also extended the same formula for all
our cells
now select this overall column or select
the highlighted cells
right and get into the data type here
you have general so that's why we have
got that
decimal format but when you press
percentage you'll have the actual
percentage of all the students according
to their marks achieved
so that's how you calculate percentage
in excel how to calculate average in
excel now let's get started with the
practical mode
now you can see that i have sales data
on my worksheet so
uh let us imagine that your manager
asked you to find the average of sales
happening in your company right so let's
navigate to the bottom most cell and you
know write it down as average here
okay average sales
so here this is a cell where you want to
keep your average right so here we'll be
writing a small formula that is average
and
tab to select it
now you must select the array of data
right
so
this is my array since average is an
array function and now press enter so
there you go you have the average sales
data that happened in your company round
off formula in excel
now for this particular tutorial we will
be using the student data set
now let's get back to the practical mode
and start our microsoft excel
now we are in the microsoft excel and as
you can see on my sheet okay let me
expand this
so as you can see on my screen we have
the data set belonging to students so we
have 10 students and every one of them
has name role number class blood group
and marks etc and at the end we have the
percentage and as you can see we have
the percentage in terms of float values
and we have a lot of decimal values like
8 and above so what if you wanted to
just have one or two digits after
the actual percentage like 80.6 or 80.66
right it would be a little bit more or
good to read right so that's what a
roundoff actually means so now let's
work on having rounded off values for
the percentage now let's create a new
column
let's name it as a
round
of
percentage
great
so to actually perform the round off
formula we do have a predefined method
for that
for that you just have to type in
equals to
round
and there you go we have round up and
around down so both of them perform the
same operation let's select a round up
and
this is the m column and the row number
is siri
so we'll have to press m3 and the number
of values after the decimal point for
now let's select
one
and there you go press enter and the
value should be rounded off now 80.66 is
being rounded off to 80.7
now when you drag the cell
to the all the rows then you can see all
the values will be rounded off
here you can see
75.16 has been rounded off to
75.2 and 82.33 has been rounded off to
82.4 so we end up with having rounded
off values how to format date in excel
now we might want to get back to the
practical mode so you can see on my
screen we are on the excel spreadsheet
and on my spreadsheet you can see
dates in column a and a different
formats in column c d e and f
respectively
now by default the data type or the data
present in the a column will be
considered as general and there are a
few situations where even if you try to
format the date in your format like you
know the customized format you may not
be able to do it because it's still
under the general data type so for that
for being on the safer side what we will
do is select the data and navigate to
the data toolbar and in that you have
the text to columns option press that
and remember to have the delimited icon
you know you might be having the
dash as your icon or slash as your icon
for the delimited thing and select that
and next next and here you can see right
it's in general mode so you can press on
date and dmi will be a date format that
is date month and year now click on
finish so it's been formatted now
now let's copy the same data and paste
it in all the four formats so that we'll
see the different formats that we can
change to or customize to
right
so there you go let's expand the columns
a little bit
now we have day
month and year
so now you might want to change a couple
of things right for example you wanted
to change okay let's see the menu so the
way is to select the cells and right
click and select the format sales option
and in here you can see the date
function and in here you can see
different types of modifications that
you can do to your data right
so
[Music]
you might want to also change your dates
based on the location so right now we
are in india and imagine if you wanted
to you know change something based on
u.s or if you are if you are having your
client in us and he wants the dates and
u.s format you can also change that so
here you can see english united states
and press on that press ok and you can
see it's been changed to us format where
you have years in the first place
months in the second place and dates in
the last place right
and now let us imagine that
your client does not want the dates all
he needs is just months right you can
also do that get back to the format
sales option go to custom and here
instead of uh you know a month date and
year you all you can do is just write
down
month and year and select okay so you'll
have only month and year not the dates
now your client is being a little more
you know he wants a little more detail
and he wants you to add a lot of
granularity to your data which includes
day
time etc everything right so you can
also do that so the same way go to
format sales custom and here
i think it's in date itself
so
let's navigate a little
yeah here so you have the day date
month and year press ok so there you go
right so that's how you can do it
and now let's try a little bit more
if you have a few more options pending
so go to format cells
and
custom
and you also have timings
so here you have date month year and the
timings
press ok and they have all the timings
as well so since these dates are you
know i created them just a few moments
ago to keep it simple so i did not have
to add the
diamonds here so if you are keen about
adding the timings you can also do that
for example if you wanted to add the
timings of the employees logged in and
logged out you can also do that using
the same format
dax and excel is a sophisticated
formulas type language that comes in
handy while working with relational data
and extracting information via dynamic
aggregation functions dax in excel
stands for data analysis expressions
dax functions are completely familiar to
the general and default functions that
are available in excel
now tax allows users to perform slightly
escalated and advanced and custom
calculations upon various data types
like character data date time time
intelligence functions and many more and
in tax there are a variety of functions
such as backstable valued functions
backs filter functions dags aggregation
functions time intelligence functions
date and time information time logical
variant and many more
now in today's session we will look into
one such type of dax function in excel
that is dax date and time function in
excel
now without further ado let's get into
practical mode
and we have started a microsoft excel
inside excel we have opened a new blank
worksheet now navigate to data option in
the toolbar and in that go to
the powerpivot window
now we have entered the powerpivot
window and inside that you can see the
option of get external data click on
that and you can see a variety of
options that is you can get the external
data from a database you can get from
web servers that is from
data service and you have also other
forms of data sources and existing
connections for now we will take other
forms of data that is a microsoft excel
data which is in our local system
select next now provide the location of
your folder just browse
and we will select dax employee data
open
and there you go we have our data
connected to our powerpoint window click
on next
and there you go you have the selected
table and views click finish and you can
see the data getting imported into your
powerpivot window
there you go by default if you want to
add any tags related functions into your
power period window you will have an
external added column over here which
looks something like this if there is
not an external column you can also add
the column it's not a big trouble now we
have some data here that is the employee
id employee name designation of the
employee department of the employee
salary
and joining date etc
let's expand this view and see what's in
what's more in it
so this column is the date of birth and
this column is the employee joining date
right now we have so much of data now
let us imagine that we want to calculate
the retirement age of all the employees
so now let's rename the column to
retirement
date
so we have our new column that is
retirement date now we will make use of
dax date time functions to calculate the
age and find out the exact retirement
date of that particular employee so let
us imagine that every employee will
retire after the age of 65 so we have
our date of birth of every employee and
the joining date of every employee now
we'll come up with a tax detail time
function and calculate the age and then
we will find the retirement date of that
employee
now every tax function starts with the
same method or the same way as the
simple excel default method starts that
is by starting with an equals two and
then
we will find e data
e date
and
and now our first parameter that is the
start date that is the employee uh
the date where the employee joined the
organization so our sheet name is sheet1
now our joining date is in the f7 column
select f7
press tab to select it and comma
now how many months so each and every
year will have 12 months so 12 months
into the age that is 65 star 65 and now
you can close the
uh function and press enter and then you
will find the retirement date of that
particular employee
there you go so we have the employee
dates that is employee retirement date
for all the employees so the first one
that is jack has the retirement date of
19 february 2085
and similarly jennifer has her
retirement date at 15th of august 2084.
so that's how we use the dax functions
in excel so this is one of the several
dax functions in excel that is dax date
and time functions in excel stated f
function in excel
now we might have to switch to the
practical mode for that now we have
started our microsoft excel and here we
have our empty worksheet so dated if
function is majorly used to find the
differences between two individual
dates so it is also called as dated if
by a few people and a few people also
reference it to date diff that is date
difference so anything is good now to
find the difference between any two
dates let's select a few dates
so the first date would be
let us imagine that you're an employee
and you wanted to find out how many
years that you've been working with an
organization
so for that you might want to need today
and the date where you join the company
right so it might be native joining
and today
so what's the difference
right so let us imagine that you joined
the organization somewhere around 2010
0 1
0
5
2010
and
today so for today can you can give any
particular date
let us imagine that
today is first of january 2021 or 2022
now we have our both the dates that is
the joining date and
the current date which can be the
current date so
the day can be anything so you might be
watching this on a different date as
well so the date of that day for today
would be a little different so we'll
imagine the today's date as an imaginary
read now we might want to find the
difference that is in terms of years
so you wanted to find the difference in
terms of fears so here you can find the
difference in terms of years days and
months as well so currently let's try to
find out the difference in terms of
years so for years you might want to
specify the third parameter in the
dative function as y if you wanted
months you have to give
the m as the third parameter and if you
wanted to find the days you might want
to give d as the third parameter
uh so we have discussed the third
parameter so what are the first two
parameters right so the first two
parameters are the first date and the
last date so the first date in this
situation is your date of joining and
the last date or the final date
which you want here as your today so
let's find the difference so for that
equals two
so it can be dated if or date diff
sedate f and
the first date which is the a2 and comma
the last state that is b2
and
your parameter third parameter in terms
of years that is why close the bracket
and press enter so there you go you have
your date here so it's been like 11
years that you're working with your
organization so that's how you find out
the differences so we have 11 years
because
we did not finish the
12th year completely so if we had given
the month as
maybe 6. where we have finished our
total years
then
it will automatically change to
12 years
so that's how you work with dated f
function in excel how to create a pivot
table in excel
now let's get started with the practical
mode we are on our excel spreadsheet now
creating a pivot table is just away from
a few clicks trust me it's just a couple
of clicks and you'll have your pivot
table ready to operate now click any
cell or select any cell on your
spreadsheet which has the data and
navigate to insert menu on the toolbar
and select pivot table and that's how
simple it is
now automatically excel will choose your
data you can see the lines over here
dotted lines that means the excel has
already selected the range of data that
you want to put into your pivot table
and you can either select the existing
worksheet or a new worksheet i'll select
a new worksheet over here and just press
on ok and there you go you have your
pivot table ready now here you can see
your pivot table is a little empty all
you need to do is drag and drop the data
elements that you want on your pivot
table
so here you can see on our spreadsheet
we have some
business data related to a store which
has furniture and states and sub
categories of the furniture and all the
you know in in category you have
furniture office supplies technology etc
right so those have some sub categories
as well and different states and the
regions as well and the quantity total
sales happen right so using this
business data we can find out some key
insights of this particular data using
our pivot table right so here we'll add
the data now let me drag the region into
rows
click and drag
and let me drag
categories into columns which are the
different categories which are involved
in sales data and values what are the
sales happened right and
there you go
you have furnitures offer supplies
technology as the three different
categories and those are the sales
happened in central is south and west
regions and this is the grand total and
incident of regions you know you have
all the regions over here right so
central east south to west or instead of
uh
all the regions or instead of all the
categories you can you know
place a specific category in your pivot
table for example let me push the
category into the filters and here you
can see the total sales happened in
those particular regions now what if
someone asks you to find the sales of
only furniture right so your manager
comes to you and he'll ask you getting
the sales of only furnitures you can
select that and there you go you have
the furniture sales in all the regions
right or you can also do the vice versa
you can also drag
regions into the filters and if you
wanted to find out the region wise sales
of furniture you can also do that right
so here we have furniture and here you
have
all the regions and let us try to find
the sales of furniture in the central
region and there you go right so this is
how
the pivot table works and you can also
remove the regions for example if you
wanted to remove a certain element from
filters or anywhere if it has columns
rules anything you can just drag and
drop it right so that's how it works
and also you can increase the level of
detail or improve the granularity right
so here we have
categories on our
you know columns so you can also include
subcategories into the columns
right
and
and you have the region wise sales
so in the region filter select all
press ok
and in the category
select all
press ok
and you have the furniture here of a
supplies here and technology here and
also if you want to include the quantity
how much or how many number of uh you
know things got sold in those particular
categories and sub categories you can
also do that so here in the furniture
section books these are the sales and
this is the number of quantity or
elements sold in the in those particular
you know sectors so
you can you can also improve the level
of granularity you can also include the
level of detail using pivot tables in
excel now here we have four different
sheets of the sales
so the first sheet is the west zone
next is south zone east zone and central
zone so all this data belongs to one
single sheet that is super store dataset
so i have categorized or i have taken a
part of the data which belongs to
central region south region west region
and east region now we are going to use
all these four sheets and create one
single sheet which is the pivot table of
all the four sheets
now without further ado let's start the
process now for that we might want to
use the shortcut key that is alt d
now press p
now this starts the pivot chart wizard
now here we have to choose the option
multiple consolidation ranges
then click on next
and here you can see the pivot table is
clicked by default now we'll go to next
now here click i will create page fields
or the pivot chart wizard will
automatically create if you want that to
create for you
now click on next now here let's select
the range
now i'll be selecting the range
add it
now next we'll select east
followed by that we have south
and finally we have best
now we will name these according to the
regions
so the first one will be west
next one will be south
next one will be east
and the last one will be central
click on next and here select new
worksheet and finish
and there you go you have the pivot
table here now you might want to change
the summation value
so click anywhere on the pivot table and
change it from count
to
sum
so that you have the summation of the
total number of sales sub category sales
and grand total of sales etc
now
here you can see all option now let's
select central and you'll get the
details of the central region the grand
total and the sales happening quantity
of sales etc now here you can you can
see the furniture office supplies
technology and the grand total all in
one single sheet now let's get back to
the original sheet
so as you can see this is the original
sheet and in the original sheet you can
see various more categories
which is
the
which is the shipment mode customer
customer segment country city state
and you also have
product name subcategory etc so if you
had added all these into this sheet you
can also create a separate option of
adding my new details to your pivot
table
so that is how the pivot table is
created using multiple sheets pivot
charts in excel
so how to create a pivot chart you ask
it is really simple all you need to do
is just follow few steps and you have
your pivot chart ready which is
completely interactive now all you have
to do is select any cell in the data set
you have and rush into the insert
toolbar then in the group of charts you
have an option called pivot chart select
on it now you'll be asked to select the
data range and you can see excel has
automatically select all the range that
you want to include in your pivot chart
then
you have another option which is asking
you to either create the pivot chart in
the current worksheet or a new worksheet
for now let's select a new worksheet
and there you go
voila the pivot chart is completely
ready you might ask me this is
completely empty
yes the default pivot chart what you get
from excel will be completely empty but
you can add the legends and all the data
that you want to add on paper with chart
just by dragging and dropping the data
from the right hand side of your excel
sheet that is from the pivot chart
fields so you can see we have various
options region category state
subcategory sales quantity etc
now
i'll add region
i'll add region to access
and comparatively we will see
the sales that are happening in those
particular regions by dragging sales
into values
now you have all the data in the form of
pivot chart which is completely
interactive which represents the sales
happening in those regions now you can
also select a particular region right by
default all the regions are selected but
if you want to select only central then
you can do that by deselecting
everything and select only central and
select ok and there you go you have all
the data related to the sales happening
in the central region
now if you want to you know kind of see
all the uh categories of sales happening
in all the regions you can drag the
category into values again and
in the region part
okay i think we have to add category
into legends yes now select a region
cell that is all regions
and select ok and you can see
the category wise sales in all the
regions at one single go and i hope you
did not observe it clearly uh
the excel also gives you the completely
prepared pivot table as well right which
is also interactive you can also get to
choose the data from here as well and
select ok and you'll see that being
reflected on the pivot chart so here you
can see both pivot table and pivot
charts are completely interactive
charts in excel
now let's quickly get on to the
practical mode where we will have some
data sets over which we will be trying
to apply the charts
now there are various types of charts in
w and those are the pie chart the column
chart the bar chart column versus line
preview chart and sparkline charts so we
will discuss one after the other first
let us discuss about the pie chart
so as you can see we have a small data
set on my screen which i have personally
created and
this deals with the companies and this
deals with the shares of the automobile
industry so now for this let's create a
pie chart
select all the data and then get into
the toolbar and inside the toolbar you
can see various options and inside that
we're gonna use the insert option
and when you select the insert option
you will have a ribbon here and inside
the ribbon you can see groups tables
illustrations add-ins and here you go
these are the charts so now we needed a
pie chart so select on that icon and you
have various types of pie charts you
have two dimensional pie charts three
dimensional pie charts donut type of
charts etc right so i would like to go
over the three-dimensional pie chart as
it looks a little more appealing and
easy to understand
and now there you go this is the title
of the chart and these are the legends
of the chart and this is the chart area
and these are the values
now we can uh you know kind of add the
data labels as well so you can just have
to press the
plus icon over here and you'll have the
options you can add the data labels
which will give you a lot more
interesting values
and
you can also turn this around
as you can see we on double clicking any
part of the pie chart you'll get this
option which is called as format data
point and
let's imagine that you wanted to show
the information related to
this particular one which is a volvo
which has the picket share so this is in
front right now now what if you wanted
to show the information related to data
which is over here right for that you
can select this particular arrow key and
you can just twist it and there you go
it is coming in front
this will be a great way of presenting
your data to your clients
right
yeah
and there is another option where you
can
directly explode this like you can pick
it out you can see this right point
explosion where you can split it out and
you can show that especially like you
can highlight it and show it so that's
the you know a great way of presenting
your data so that's how you can work
with pie charts in excel now let's
quickly move to the next one that is the
column chat
and in the column chart we have the data
related to some company and the profits
of that company based on a year so you
can see that the year has started from
2008 and it has gone until 2021 and
these are the profits of that company
year after year so since we are dealing
with column chart i'll tell you the
simplest way to create a column chat
there is a shortcut key for that
which is alt f1 and there you have the
chart right on your screen
now you can expand the chart just by
dragging it like that and
you can see that there is some problem
with this chart that is we have numbers
here instead of years right you can see
that the first column is the years which
is 2008-2021 but here you can see we
have one two three four which is not
proper right
so to change the axis that is you can
see the axis which is one two three four
from one two three four to the years
2008 2009 2010 11 etc you just have to
make one change here and also you can
see i have pressed the plus icon over
here which will open
the option where you can
include the access titles
if you have and data labels everything
right so for now i think i'll keep it as
it is so you can include the data table
as well as it is here and you can
include that in the chart there are
various options that excel provides you
so now let's focus on changing the
access from one two three four to the
ears for that you need to select the
chart design and inside the chat design
you have an option called select data
press that and here you have various set
of options you can see profits you can
see ears now we'll select ears and we
will remove that
and now you can see the edit option here
right
select that and now
it will ask you which
column to be selected for the access
range for that let's select this and now
let's select the ears here
and
press ok
and there you go
again press ok
so there you go you have the ears over
here instead of the numbers which you
had in the first place
so that's how you create the column chat
and we have the next type of chart which
is really simple
now you know you kind of change this
chart directly into bar chart there is
no big deal in that
uh
for that you just need to select the
change chart type option over here
you're just changing the chart type and
you can get the paragraph over here
column and bar graphs are completely
same to each other only that you can see
these
bars in the horizontal way rather than
in the
vertical wave and let's do that
let's not create a new thing for that so
yeah there you go when you select the
change chart type option you have
various set of chart type options on the
menu bar over here so what we needed was
the bar chart now let's select that and
there you go
let's select ok and you have the bar
chart
right and
if you want you can include the data
labels which look a little bit more
interesting you can also include the
data table as well
okay for now i think we have to expand
the chart to get the clear view
yeah that's how you do it
right now let's move into the next type
of one yeah we dealt with the bar chart
so we'll directly enter into the column
versus line chart
so we have similar kind of data we just
had year and profits in the previous
part now we also have included the
expenses right we needed another column
to showcase the line chart compared to
the columns right so for that i've
included a new column that is expenses
all as well
now just let's select the data
and let's select the option
alt f1 to create our chart
right now automatically uh excel has
provided us the column chat we have the
columns of expenses we have the column
of profits and we also have years
now let's change the data as we did
before select uh here and remove it and
then
edit
select edit and select the ear
that is from here to 2021
select okay and we have the ears over
here
now what we needed to do is
change the chart type right select the
change chart type option and since we
wanted to create a column versus line
chart it is a combination whenever you
want
one or two types of charts included in
one single chart window then it has a
combo option so here we need to select
the comp option and inside that we have
various types of combination charts we
have clustered column we have clustered
line on secondary axis we have clustered
stat areas clustered column and the
other one is custom combination so let's
go with the first one that is clustered
line
let's select that and there you go we
have the line graph with the column so
that's how we create the column versus
line
and if you want you can include the
data labels and you can include the data
table as well yeah
okay i think we need to expand the
canvas a little more to get a clear view
yeah
so you have legends over here you have
the data labels and accesses everything
and chart title you can always change
the chat title so for now let's uh
rename it as
profits versus
expenses
yeah that's that's how it goes
done okay i think i made a spelling
mistake
here yeah it's clear now
now the next type of chart we're going
to deal with is the pivot chart
so
we have dealt with pie chart column
chart bar chart and column versus line
now pivot chart is a little bit
different it's like you're going to
create some active chart which responds
to the variations you're making to your
data so to understand that better let's
create a practical chart over here
i select all the data
okay
yeah i have selected the data
now
[Music]
to create a pivot chart
let's select
the insert option from the toolbar and
inside the ribbon we have charts group
and inside that we have pivot chart
now let's select the preview chart
option
and there you go
now it's asking for range and we have
selected the range over there
and
we are not going to create a new
worksheet for the entire chart we are
going to create the
chart inside the existing worksheet
itself so for that let's select the
area where we want to select the
chart to be present now for that let's
select this and
yeah select okay
okay there is some error
let's cancel this and try again
let's select the data
and preview chat again
we have selected the
range
here
that's how you select the range
and now select the position where you
want to create it existing worksheet we
have selected that and press ok yeah
that's that's the way we've got our
preview chart over here and you can see
our pivot chart is completely blank
right now it will respond to the changes
you make to your pivot chart for now we
have
serial numbers and these are the names
of the
guys who have
okay so these are the names of the guys
who who have some dealerships for
various car makes such as ford ferrari
honda kia alfa romeo bmw etc etc
so uh we're gonna change or we're gonna
see
um
you know we're gonna make some chats of
the persons who own the cars
or the car brands or dealerships in
various regions so we're gonna work on
that now let's drag in the name
and uh let's drag region
and
cards
and the units
yep
so we have our
chart over here column chart which has
the different different names and
the dealerships and sum of cars over
there right so you can see that we can
also change some values over here what
if we wanted to know only
the details regarding jennifer you can
do that you can unselect everything and
you can just select jennifer and press
ok now you'll have the details of only
jennifer of having the car brands
so we have the regions as well so
jennifer owns dealerships in two
different regions that is south and west
and the sum of units and count of cars
as well
so that's how the pva charts are used in
real time
and now let's select sales and drag the
sales as well
yeah it's been dragged and you have the
sales of
jennifer
the details of her sales
and let's move the chart a little bit
and you have the plus icon where you can
include the data labels for a better
information
yeah so that's how you use the pivot
charts
so we are on the last type of charts
which is the sparkline chart now to
create a sparkline chart we need to get
into the insert option and inside we
have the ribbon and inside the ribbon we
have the group that is sparklines
now
to generate a sparkline chart we need to
select this particular column and then
select the
type of spotlight you want to create for
now let's create the
column type of sparkline chart
yep
we have to
club these
cells together first we forgot that
because we're gonna insert the sparkline
chart right above here
now for that
let's merge the cells
[Music]
yeah
so we wanted to create the
sparkline chart of column type and now
it's asking for the location where we
want to create this part line chart so
this is the location now let's select ok
and there you go we have the sparkline
chart right over here
now you can see that we have a negative
point here so if you want we can change
that from negative to positive
and it will automatically update that
and if you want to add the access to
this particular chart you can select the
options part line and there you have
certain options like high point low
point
and if you wanted to add some margins
and you can also do that
and the data type access and there you
have the access
show access yeah you have the access now
and you can have the high point and low
point for that as well which is the you
know the biggest change and the smallest
change in this particular
segment that is few furniture yeah
furniture had the highest sales in
january and uh homer plans had the
lowest sale and you can also change the
color
and
let's type of change
the color again yeah we have a different
color over here which resembles a little
bit more better or you can also go with
this one
and if you wanted to add the same to all
these tables you can do that just by
dragging it
and you have it for all the six months
now if you wanted to add some new data
in this row or you wanted to add a new
complete row then you can do that as
well and change that and bring that
change implemented in these charts as
well
now let us try to add a new row here
which includes the miscellaneous
we have that data right over here let's
select that
copy and
let's paste it over here
so there you go we have the extra row
here
so yeah now we have added the
miscellaneous row and right now we have
the sparkline chart for only four
columns or four rows that is furniture
technology home appliances and office
needs and miscellaneous is missing now
to add that as well let's select
sparkline
and inside sparkline just select edit
group location and data
and now let's select the entire data
and now select ok
there's something wrong
again
start line
edit data
select range
this should be helping
yeah there you go we have all the five
rows now
including furniture technology home
appliances office needs and
miscellaneous
lookup function tutorial in excel what
is excel vlookup
vlookup stands for vertical lookup
vlookup lets you search for specific
information in your spreadsheet
it allows you to search for a particular
value in a column and returns another
value from a different column but of the
same row
vlookup takes advantage of vertically
aligned tables to quickly find data
associated with the value the user
enters now
let's look at the syntax to write a
vlookup function so vlookup takes four
parameters or arguments you can see it
here there are four arguments
in the velcro function
so the first argument is called the
lookup value
the lookup value represents
the value that you are searching for
next is the table array the table array
represents two or more columns of
information the third argument is called
the column index number
now this represents the column number in
the table from which the value must be
returned the first column is 1 the
second column is 2 and so on and then
we have the fourth parameter which is
called the range lookup now this
parameter is optional now range lookup
is used to find an exact match
so if you want to find an exact match
you need to enter false or zero
meanwhile if you want an approximate
match you need to enter true or one if
getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
now let me give you a brief overview on
what's going to be in our demo
so for our demonstration
we'll use a sales data set you can see
the data set on the left
using this data set
we'll understand how vlookup performs an
exact and approximate match we'll see
how vlookup is case insensitive
then we'll perform a wildcard character
search
we'll understand how to handle errors
when a match is not found and finally
you will look at two way lookups
now here is a small example of how
vlookup works
so we want to find the units sold by
morgan
using the data set on the left
so here you can see i have the data set
it has
some rows and columns so these are the
columns which are order date
region there's a representative column
item units there's unit cost and total
and from this table i want to find the
units that were sold by morgan if you
look at the table at the bottom you can
see the representative name morgan and
morgan has sold 30 units
now i want to find this value using the
vlookup function so here on the right
you can see i have my lookup value which
is morgan and this is my vlookup formula
and using this formula i am getting the
result as 30. now let's go to our excel
workbook and perform all the demos one
by one so this is my excel workbook that
we are going to use for our demo
and here is the data set we'll be using
now this is the same data set that you
saw
a while ago
so this data set has seven columns you
have the order date the region
representative's name item this units
unit cost and total which is basically
the total or the amount of sales that
was generated
we are going to use a chunk of this data
set and perform our vlookup analysis
so let's see our first example and the
problem we have at hand
let me go to the exact match tab
all right
so here
i'm going to use this chunk of data
which is actually taken from the
original data set so we have taken the
first
11 rows from the data set you can see
from row 2
till row 12
is going to be our data set that we'll
use
so we have a question here
we want to find the items sold by
thomson
so here
thomson is my lookup value which means
looking at thomson i want to find the
item that is sold
so if you consider our table here you
can see we have the representative's
name thomson
right here
and
from the table you can see thomson sold
pencil
and i want to get this value which is
pencil using my vlookup function
so let's go ahead and write our vlookup
function
i'll consider this as my lookup value
and here under item i'm going to write
my vlookup formula
to write the vlookup formula i'll write
first equal to
and
i'll write vlookup now if i hit tab it
will auto complete
all right now let's
give the parameters so first is going to
be the lookup value which is nothing but
thomson so i'll just select this cell
which is j17
comma
now it's asking to give the table array
so the table array is the table from
which you want to retrieve a value
one thing to keep in mind is that the
value you are looking for should be the
first column of a table and
you can select the table array till the
end of the data set or till the column
which has the value you want to find so
here i'll select my table array starting
from the representatives column till
the end of the item column
which is going to be my table array
then i'll select
the column index number so the column
index number is based on the table array
you have selected in this case my column
index number is going to be 2 because we
have selected just two columns and the
value which i am going to find is in the
second column so i will give 2
comma
now the range lookup i'm going to give
is false because i want to find an exact
match so either you can hit tab
or you can write 0 which means false
if i close the bracket and hit enter
it will return me the item that thompson
had sold which is pencil you can verify
from the table that thomson had sold
pencil all right
now let's try to change the table array
and see what result are we getting so
this time i'll slightly change the table
array so again we are trying to find the
item that thompson had sold so i'll
write my formula equal to
vlookup i'll hit tab to autocomplete
i'll give my lookup value as thomson
comma
this time i am choosing my table array
starting from the representatives column
till
the end of the data set which is
till p12
again my column index number is going to
be 2 because
if you consider this table array the
item column is the second column in the
selected table array so i am going to
write it as 2
comma
the range lookup i want to give as false
because i want to find the exact match
if i close this and hit enter you can
see it has returned me the same result
that we saw earlier
now suppose
let's say this time i want to start my
table array from the region column which
is this column
so i want to select my table array
starting from the region column now this
is going to show me an error because
your table array should always start
from the lookup value column so if you
consider thomson as the lookup value
my table array should always start from
the representatives column so let's just
try this example
so i'll write vlookup
my lookup value i'm going to give it as
thomson comma
the table array as i mentioned earlier
i'm going to choose from the region
column
and let's say i'll select till the item
column give another comma and this time
my column index number is going to be 3
because
since
the table array has three columns and my
item column is the last column so i'm
going to give my column index number as
three
comma i want to get
the exact match so i'll give zero if i
close the bracket and hit enter you can
see it has given me
an error
okay
now let me just show you another method
to use vlookup in excel
so here on the top you can see there's a
formulas tab
and under formulas tab under function
library you see
we have an option to select lookup and
reference if i click on this
and if i scroll down below you can see
there's an option
called vlookup
let's choose this
all right now here
you can give
your lookup value your table array
column index number and the range lookup
under this function arguments dialog box
so here i want to select my lookup value
as
thomson my table array is going to be
from the representatives column till
let's say the end of the data set
my column index number is going to be 2
i'll write 2
and range lookup
i'll write as
false because i want the exact match
if i hit ok you can see
it has given us the exact same result so
this is one of the other ways to use
vlookup in excel now
let's move to the next sheet which is
regarding approximate match
okay so sometimes you might have cases
where you don't have the lookup value
present in the table in those cases you
can tell vlookup to return an
approximate match
now one thing to keep in mind is that
your lookup value column should always
be sorted in ascending order while
trying to get an approximate match so
here we are going to use this table and
my lookup value column which is going to
be the representatives column is already
sorted in ascending order
and let's see the question we have here
so i want to find the item sold and the
unit cost for mat
so my lookup value is going to be mat
now if you see this table i don't have
the representatives name
mat anywhere in the table now using an
approximate match i want to find the
item and the unit cost so let's do it
so here under item i'll write my vlookup
formula
so i'll type vlookup i'll hit tab to
complete it
and this time my lookup value is going
to be matte so i'll select the cell
comma
my table array i'll select
from the representatives column till
the end of
item column because i want to find the
item value format
i'll give a comma
my column index number
as per the table array is going to be 2
comma
my range lookup this time i'm going to
give is true or 1
so i'll write 1
close the bracket
hit enter
all right it has written me binder was
the item sold by matt
now let's try to figure out why vlookup
returned binder as the item
now let's say you were asked to insert
the name matt to the representative
column in alphabetical order so where
would you place it
ideally you should place between qival
and morgan
since this column is already sorted mat
should appear before morgan and after
kibel so in an approximate match vlookup
will consider the previous highest value
in this case the previous highest value
before matt is ql
and hence vlookup returned the
corresponding item purchased by kival
which is binder now similarly
if you wanted to find the unit cost for
mat
again
vlookup will return
the unit cost of kibale which is 125.
let's just try it out so i'll write
vlookup
my lookup value is matt comma
my table array for this time is going to
be from representatives column
till the unit cost column i'll consider
i'll give a comma
now the column index number as per the
table array is going to be 4 i'll give
another comma and this time
i'll double click true because i want an
approximate match where close the
bracket hit enter you can see it has
returned me
125 which is actually
kevl's unit cost okay
we have another question
and this time i want to find the units
sold by rob
now rob is going to be
my
lookup value
if you see the representatives column we
don't have rob
now let's see what vlookup is going to
return as the item for rob so i'll write
vlookup i'll give my lookup value as rob
comma
my table array
is going to start from the
representatives column
i'll select till here i'll give a comma
the column index number is 2
i'll give another comma
i'll double click on true
so close the bracket hit enter you can
see vlookup has returned me pen now
let's understand why vlookup returned
pen for rob
now if you are asked to insert the
representative's name rob
into this column so ideally rob would
appear somewhere between morgan and
sorvino because
since this is
sorted in ascending order rob is
actually greater than morgan and is less
than sorvino so as you know
vlookup in an approximate match returns
the previous highest value which is
morgan here
and the corresponding item for morgan is
pen and hence vlookup returned pen for
rob all right
now moving to the next sheet
which is another property of vlookup
which tells vlookup always looks to the
right this means that your lookup value
must always be on the left
and the value you are going to find out
should always be to the right of the
table now consider this scenario
where your lookup value is on the left
in this case
it is the representatives value and i
have taken sorvino for an example
and we want to find the order date for
sorvino
now if you consider this table your
lookup value which is so we know is
actually this column the representatives
column and we are going to find out the
order date
so your representative's name is on the
right of the table
and the value we are going to find out
is on the left of the table
now as per the property vlookup only
looks to the right
so if i use the vlookup function for
this example here
i'll write vlookup
i'll give my lookup value as
sorvino
comma
my table array i'll consider from the
order date because i want the order date
till
the representatives column
i'll give a comma and this time
my column index number is actually the
first column if i consider my table
array as the first three columns
selected
and my range lookup is going to be false
if i close the bracket hit enter it
returns me an error the reason is
vlookup always looks to the right and
this time the value we were trying to
find out was to the left of the table
now
if you consider
the opposite case suppose you have the
order date and you want to find the
representative's name you can do that
easily because your lookup value which
is the order date is on the left and
your representatives column is on the
right so let's just try this i'll write
vlookup my lookup value is going to be
sorvino's order date so i'll select it
from the table
i'll give a comma
my table array will start from the g
column let's say i'll select the entire
table
comma
and my column index number will be 3 if
you consider these
as my table array
comma my range lookup is 0. if i close
this hit enter you can see we have got
so we know corresponding to the order
date
all right now let's move to the next tab
now this tab says
vlookup returns only the first match so
we have a question at hand the question
is
find the units sold by jardine
if you see this table
we have the representative's name jarred
in twice you see here
and if you look down we have jardin here
as well
but the item sold by jardin at the first
instance is pencil
and at the second instance it's desk
now as per the property vlookup always
returns the first match now ideally when
we write the vlookup function and look
for the units sold by jardine
you will see
vlookup will return
36 instead of three
let's just try it out
i'll write the vlookup function
my lookup value is jardine
comma
my table array
i'll select from the representatives
column till the end of
units column
i'll give a comma
my column index number based on the
table array is 3 i'll give another comma
now i want the exact match so i'll
select zero close the bracket and hit
enter
as you can see it returns me the first
match of jardine which is
36
so vlookup did not consider the second
match
now similarly
if you consider this table
we have jones repeated thrice so you
have jones here
we have jones
here for the second time and also we
have jones for the third time
and let's say
you want to find the unit cost for jones
so if i write the vlookup function
i'll consider my
lookup value as jones comma
my table array
i'll select from the representatives
column till the end of unit cost column
i'll give a comma
based on the table array my unit cost
column is at the fourth index so i'll
write 4
comma the range lookup is zero
if i click on this
and hit enter you can see it here
vlookup has returned the first instance
of jones and it did not consider the
second and the third instance so our
unit cost
for jones is 1.99
because vlookup only returns the first
match
okay
moving ahead to the next
example we have here is vlookup is case
insensitive
if you consider this table
i've added another
row in green
so if you see here i have a
representative name called gill which is
in proper case or
popularly known as sentence case here
i have added
gil's name in
capital letters or all in uppercase
so i want to find the total revenue
generated by gil the total revenue is
basically the total column let's do it
i'll write vlookup
my lookup value is gil which is actually
in uppercase
i'll consider my table array from the
representatives column till the end of
total column or the sales column
based on this selection my column index
number is 5
comma the range lookup is false so i'll
just double click on false
close the bracket hit enter
you can see it here
our vlookup function has returned the
total as
539.73 which is actually
the value for this row so clearly
vlookup did not consider gil
which was present at the bottom of the
table in uppercase
so this shows that vlookup is clearly
case insensitive
all right
now moving to the next example
the vlookup function supports wildcards
which makes it possible to perform a
partial match on a lookup value
for instance you can use vlookup to
retrieve values from a table after
typing only part of a lookup value to
use wildcards with vlookup you must
specify the exact match by giving false
or 0 for the last argument that is range
lookup
now we have a question here
i want to know how much sales did the
representative whose name starts with ki
make now here sales represents the
total column actually
so
i want to find out the person whose name
starts with ki
so if you consider the representative
column i have one representative whose
name starts with ki that is kivel
so
using ki as my lookup value i want to
find the total so let me show you
how to use wildcard characters and find
the value using vlookup
so write my function vlookup
okay now in lookup value i'll give ki
after that
i'm going to write amber sent
followed by
double inverted commas
then i am going to write a star
and close the inverted comma
this means
the value starts with k
amber scent actually represents
concatenation
and star represents anything followed by
ki
so this is going to be my lookup value
in total
i'll give a comma
next i'll select my table array starting
from the representatives column till the
end of total column because i want to
find the sales
i'll give another comma
my column index number based on the
table array we have selected is 5
comma
the range lookup is 0
because i want to find an exact match
close the bracket hit enter you can see
it here
vlookup has returned me
999.5 which is actually
kevl's total
now there's another way to do it
instead of
selecting the cell in which we have the
lookup value i can directly
write it in the vlookup function
so i'll write the vlookup function
something like this
so my lookup value
i'll pass
ki within double inverted commas because
ki is a character value
so within double inverted commas i'm
writing ki
followed by amber sent which is for
concatenation
followed by
a star
within double inverted commas so this is
going to be my lookup values
this in total means anything that
appears after ki will be considered as
the lookup value
again the table array i'll select as
these rows and columns comma my column
index number would be five
comma the range lookup is zero
if i close the bracket hit enter you see
we have the same value so this is
another method or another way of using
vlookups
okay
now moving ahead let's explore another
feature of vlookup so if the vlookup
function cannot find a match it returns
a hash and a error now if you want you
can use the if any function to replace
the has any error with a friendly
message so suppose
you want to find the region in which an
order was placed on 10th of may 2018.
now if the order date is not found i
want to return a message that is invalid
date
so
if you look at the order date
column we don't have any value for 10th
of may 2015. you can see these values we
don't have any value corresponding to
this date
so
if my vlookup function cannot find this
lookup value i'll return invalid date
so let me show you
how to write this
i'll type my vlookup function
i'll give my order date as 10th of may
2015
as my lookup value
and then
i'll consider my table array starting
from the order date column till the end
of region column
i'll give another comma my column index
number would be 2 this time based on the
table array we have selected comma
i want an exact match
so i'll give 0 close the bracket and hit
enter
there you go it has written me an error
now i want to convert this error to a
friendly message saying invalid date so
let me show you how to do it i'll do it
here so to return a valid message
i'll use the if any function
and within infinite function i'll give
my vlookup function
so let me type if na
i'll hit tab
now for the value parameter i'll use my
vlookup function so my lookup value is
going to be
the orderdate
comma
my table array i'll select from the
order date column till the end of region
column comma
my column index number is going to be 2
comma
my range lookup is 0
i'll close the bracket give another
comma
now if this expression results in an
error i want to display a message that
is invalid date so i'll put invalid date
within double quotes
since it is
a text message
i close the bracket
hit enter
you can see
the result which is invalid date
now moving on to the final section of
the demo
we have two way lookup
now in the vlookup function
the column index parameter is normally
hard coded as a static number however
you can also create a dynamic column
index by using the match function to
locate the right column
and this technique allows you to create
a dynamic two way lookup matching on
both rows and columns
now let me first show you how a
match function works so suppose
i want to find
the index where unit cost column is
present
so here i'll use the match function
i'll give my lookup value as the unit
cost column name
comma
suppose
i'll choose my lookup array starting
from representatives column till
the unit cost column comma i'll give my
match type as 0 for exact match
if i close the bracket hit enter it
returns me 4 because
my array was selected from the
representatives column till the unit
cost column and in this array
unit cost is at the fourth index
all right now using this idea let's
solve the following problem
i want to find the cost of each item
sold by morgan
so let's write our vlookup formula
i'll write vlookup
my lookup value is
j5 which has the
representative's name as morgan comma
my table array
i'll select from
c2
till
f12
i'll give a comma and this time
i know that my column index number is at
4
but i'll be using the match function to
find the same
so i'll write match
my lookup value is
unit cost comma
my lookup array
is from
c1 till
f1
comma my match type is 0
i close this bracket
give another comma
and i'll give my range lookup as 0
close the bracket hit enter you can see
for morgan the unit cost is 19.99 you
can verify from the table for morgan the
unit cost is 19.99
all right
now
we have another question here
i want to find
how much sales did andrews make in the
central region so here
i have
two lookup values one is central one is
andrews now looking at these two values
i want to find the total
to solve such problems
let me first create
another table
i'll place the table somewhere here
okay so let me just paste the table here
all right now i'll create another column
where i'll merge the values of region
and representatives so here
let me create
another column okay
i'll just name this column as
region
rep
all right
now this column
i'll use the concatenation operator so
i'll select
east
use ampersand and then select jones i'll
hit enter
now the same thing i'll just duplicate
it
for the other rows as well
so i have my new column created now
using this table i can easily solve the
problem
now to find the total
i'll write my vlookup formula
so my lookup value
will be a combination of j11
ampersand
k11
comma
my table array will start from the
region rep which has the values of
region and rep combined till
the last column
and from this table array my column
index number is 5
and my range lookup is 0
but close the bracket hit enter you can
see
for central region which is this one
and for andrew's
representative the total is 149.25
all right now we are done with our demo
let's have a quick glance at what all we
did in this demo
okay so first of all we saw our data set
which was a sales data set that we used
then we started with our first example
to see how vlookup performs an exact
match
we also saw how using the formulas tab
and lookup
and reference you can
write vlookup in
another way so you can use the function
arguments to give your vlookup
parameters next we saw how vlookup
performs an approximate match so we had
mat and raw which were not present in
the representatives column
after that
we saw an important property of vlookup
that is vlookup only looks to the right
followed by
vlookup only returns the first match
following which we saw
that vlookup is case insensitive so here
we had added a new row where gil was
present in upper case but still vlookup
found the total revenue for gil which
was in sentence case of proper keys next
we saw how we can use wildcard
characters to
use vlookups
and here we saw how to use
an if-funny function
along with vlookup
and finally we saw how to use two-way
lookups choose from over 300 in-demand
skills and get access to 1 000 plus
hours of video content for free visit
scale up by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more now
we are on the sheet of microsoft excel
and here you can see some data on my
sheet
that is employee name employee id and
salary
so here we are going to perform more
horizontal lookup but before that let me
show you that this particular drop down
menu so this particular drop down menu
has all the names of the employees in
this particular table and we have
created this using data validation in
excel
if you want to create the drop down
menus just like these then feel free to
check out our data validation in excel
tutorial link to which is in the
description box below now let's try to
implement hlookup in excel so here we
have employee name but we want to find
out the employee id so for that let's
create the hlookup now for that equals
to hlookup
now the first one is the lookup value so
this one
is
the cell which is the employee name now
after that the table array we have to
select all the table arrays here
now
the row index number so the employee id
is in row index number two according to
the table so for that provide two and
close the bracket and before closing
brackets you might want to give the
exact match so for exact match select
false
and close the bracket press enter and
there you go
and if you select
jack then you'll find the employee id of
check and if you select jury you'll find
the employee id of cherry reflecting
here now similarly let's find out the
salary of all the employees using
hlookup
so equals hlookup
and lookup value that happens to be the
name of the employee
now the table array
and next we have
row index number that is salary happens
to be the third row in the table so
three
and
exact match
close the bracket and enter so now if
you change the values in this particular
drop-down menu you will find the
employee id and their particular salary
so jack happens to be carrying the
employee id as 1001 and his salary is
ten thousand
so similarly let's try to find out
peter's employee id and salary
so there you go one zero zero five and
fifty thousand salary so that's how you
use hlookup in excel here you can see
the first chart so this particular data
is converted into a table format to
avoid confusion while you're fixing the
data so here you can see the name of the
employee employee id department salary
and date of joining and here you can see
the salary column and the bonus
percentage of each and every employee
based on their salaries
now coming to the new data table and
here on the table 2 which is an updated
table here you can find we are going to
find out the department of the employee
and the current department of employee
and the bonus percentage based on his or
her salary so why are we finding current
department again
so here you can see that we have an
intern emily who has joined in the year
2020 but recently she got promoted as a
developer so her department has been
changed from department intern to
department developer in 2021 so that's
what we're gonna find out here in the
current department using x lookup now
let's start to implement x lookup so for
that
equals to x lookup
and for lookup you can see if you need
to find out the lookup value lookup
array written array and all the other
two are
not important right now but you can use
them to get some exact matches in the
future we'll also use that in the future
for now let's try to use the first three
parameters that is lookup value lookup
array and written array so the lookup
value is the name of the employee mary
and lookup array is right here which is
this one
now we're going to select the lookup
array
then comma and
we're going to look up the department so
this is the department
lookup array
and that's all we need
close the bracket and press enter
okay i think we missed out the lookup
value
so the employee or the lookup value
which we required was missed so i've
added it here so that is the lookup
value the first one which is mary and
there you go
press enter and you have the department
here now let's add it to all the rows
and here you have all the rows and all
the data related to all the employees
now we will find out the current
department as you can see here you have
emily as intern which is the older data
but what if you needed the latest data
that is the developer in the year 2021
right for that you might want to to walk
the x lookup formula a little bit so
let's try that
x lookup
lookup value which is the same
and comma
now where you have to look for the array
that is lookup array this one
and the return array which happens to be
this one
and next
you can find the exact match for this
one so that's all right exact match and
here comes the important part where you
have to search last to first by default
x lookup searches for first to last that
is like this in the starting place to
the last place so that's the reason why
we had emily as intern so now if we give
last to first then it retrieves the
latest theta where emily will be shown
as developer now select that and now you
can close the brackets and press enter
so let's add that to all the rows there
you go now you can see emily clark peter
and james all they have got their
updated job profiles as you can see in
the original data emily is a developer
now so is clark who was originally a
tester and he got promoted to
development team in 2021 similarly peter
became a senior finance executive in
2021 and james the manager of sales now
let's try to find out the bonus for all
these employees based on their salary so
this one is quite simple
so x lookup
now the lookup value is their existing
salary
comma
and the bonus part so the lookup array
is the salary range
then here is another important point
so here you might want to find the exact
match but finding an exact match will
not help you here you might want to
declare another type of value where you
can get exact match or next smaller item
so you'll understand it why i'm
selecting that
so now let's close the bracket and enter
so
so now we have the bonus values now
let's add the bonus value to all the
factors all the rows i mean so you can
see we have different variety of
salaries that is
twenty two thousand thirty nine etc but
here in the ranges we have provided 10
20 30 40 and 50. so what if the value is
between 30 and 20 that's when you want
the
less number right that's when you want
the number which is equivalent to 30 or
less than 30 which happens to be 15
percent so that's how it has worked here
that is 0.15 bonus to the actual salary
what exactly is we stack
so let's get started with the practical
mode now we are on our excel sheet here
you can see the employee names and
employee ids of different employees from
different zones let us imagine that the
blue one is from east green one is from
west and the black one is from or the
purple one is from
south and the orange one is from north
so
this data is a little small but what if
we had a data with hundreds or thousands
of rows including all the employee names
employee ids or another relevant data
type like sales of an employee and his
employee id
and he was supposed to combine all the
data from all the four different zones
into one single sheet it would consume a
lot of time right so
recently
microsoft has released some latest
updates based on arrays and datas so one
of those is vstack function in excel so
how to use it
since it is a latest function i
recommend you to go to the file menu and
in the file menu you can navigate to
account and in the account you can see
the option of update options
then you can select update now and your
microsoft office will be updated to the
latest version and you will get access
to the latest functions in excel and all
the other office related things like
problem presentation etc
now we are going to implement the vstack
function in excel it is completely
simple all you need to do is equals to
stack
and then select the data
remember to select the data from column
a
and cell 2 or the row 2 we are not
selecting the employee and employee id
we are just selecting the data now
separate them by comma then again this
one here this set and again this one
and again lastly this particular last
set
now close the bracket and press enter
and there you go you have all the
employee names and their respective
employee ids all together in one data
set so this is how you use vstack
function in excel
hyperlinks in excel
now hyperlink is something which is
clickable and when you click on it it
will redirect you to a different web
page to a different worksheet or a
different location in your local system
so there are a variety of options and we
will explore all of them using excel
now creating a hyperlink is really
simple we have multiple ways now let's
write some text on the excel worksheet
i'll write simply long
now creating a hyperlink is really
simple you have multiple ways the first
simplest shortcut is
clicking on the cell where you want to
place the hyperlink and holding control
key and pressing k
now this will enable the hyperlink menu
box or the dialog box this is the first
way and let me close it
now again we have selected the cell
there is another option where you have
to click on the insert menu on the
toolbar and navigate to links group
click on the link option
and you will again have the dialog box
of the hyperlink in excel
and the third way is right click on the
cell
and you can see the link option the last
and this will enable the hyperlink
option in excel
now
let's create a hyperlink the simplest
way again ctrl k
now we have a variety of options that is
existing file or web page place in this
document create a new document and an
email address so we will address all of
these
one at each time so first one existing
file or a web page
now you can select an existing pdf file
or any file in your local system and
hyperlink or create a hyperlink to the
text or you can select a website a link
and place it over here and create it as
a hyperlink
let's explore both the options
first let's try to explore the web page
option so since i have written as simply
learn let's use the website link of
simply learn and create a hyperlink
let me open google
new tab and let me type simplylearn.com
let me copy the hyperlink
and now let's get back to the excel
workbook now here let's place the
hyperlink
now you can press ok
and there you go the hyperlink has been
successfully created now this link is
clickable when you click on it it will
redirect you to a new simply learns home
web page right so this is how you create
a hyperlink to a website now we shall
explore another option that is using an
existing file right let's create a new
text box here let's name it as existing
file and okay existing file should be
good
again the same you can either click
uh you know right click and select
hyperlink or ctrl k
now let's select existing file or web
page option
now here you can see navigate key press
on that and let's navigate our files
let's select all files here remember to
select all files
okay by default it shows as office files
now let's explore
our file option
so let's select a fundamentals of
computer programming option
which is a pdf file
press ok and there you go we have
created a hyperlink so when i click on
this you can directly navigate to an
existing pdf file in your local system
and it will be open as a web page
click on it and you can see the pdf file
now close
now another thing when you navigate onto
this you'll see the lengthia http uh
address and same happens here right so
if you're a little uncomfortable
watching this lengthier link you can
also edit it you can choose the option
of edit hyperlink
and
see the screen tip option
click on it
and
here
you can change the texture display
option
and write it as
click here
to no more
press
okay
again press ok and now if you navigate
onto it instead of seeing a lengthier
hyperlink what you can see is click here
to know more okay i think i made a
spelling mistake
so i think i forgot an e
somewhere over here yes
click here to normal
and press
okay
right so here you can see click here to
no more let's try this again over here
so
edit
edit hyperlink screen tip option and
instead of the lindier text box or
hyperlink you can write as click to open
notes
or pdf
click ok
and click another okay and you are done
so instead of seeing that length here
hyperlink you can see click here to open
pdf
right so so far we have explored two
options that is existing file
and
existing web page
right now let's try to explore another
option again
uh hyperlink right click hyperlink and
here you have seen places in document
all right so which is like uh okay let
me
show this to you instead of telling you
so here what it is doing is you have the
cell a5
and you want it to refer to a1 or any
other cell in the same worksheet so you
can do that right so now for your
reference let me cancel it and let me
create a new sheet
and here
navigate me to here right let me write
this navi gate me
to here
okay
so now what we will do is
so here we will create that navigate
link
from using the hyperlink option
place this in this document you can see
the sheet to option and the cell
reference is a1 where we have written
navigate me to here so when i click this
a5 cell
okay let me also rename it
write it as navigate cell navigating
cell
right now
let's create that
control k
let me select sheet 2 and the selector
is a1 press ok
now what did what what's the change
right when you click on this you will be
redirected to sheet2 cell a1 navigate me
to here right so
this can be like a shortcut when you
have multiple sheets like hundred sheets
then you can you know have a certain
different column over here and
add the navigation address to all those
cell links you can just click on that
cell and go into the different sheet and
to the specific cell which you have
given the address in our case i have
given sheet to address cell a1 right so
this is another trick now
let's get back to the hyperlink thing
again
uh ctrl k and another option is create
new document
so you might have been through
you know option of uh having
let's say some cheat sheets or
uh clip-on clipboards right
so uh let us imagine that you're working
through
a huge worksheet and you wanted to you
know
have a track of everything and keep
notes updating right so it might be a
little complicated to understand so let
me show it practically so let me write
it down as clipboard or sticky note
right
okay i think this has a hyperlink
lettuce okay this can be used no worries
back to
hyperlink option again
create new document
now
here you can create a variety of
documents right so it can be a text
document it can be an excel document it
can be a pdf document right for now
we'll create a text document okay
uh we'll name it as a tracker
dot txt
so this should create us a text document
and the location can be anything so you
can you know
take it as a desktop documents download
so let me take documents here
and select okay so i'll be having this
tracker.txt located in the documents
folder
and you can also choose to edit the
document later or edit the document now
let us select edit the document now
press ok and there you go
so you have your
text tracker here so let us imagine that
we have worked on the excel sheet and we
wanted to write on us a sticky note so
that we can remember what we have done
on the excel sheet so update one
and update to
now you can close it so it will ask for
a save option save it
and down and let us imagine that you did
something else and you also updated
something else on the sticky note i'm in
excel sheet and you wanted to update
that on your sticky note so click on it
and you'll see a minor notice over here
from microsoft excel based on potential
security concerns you can select yes and
you'll be having access to your text
document again and write down your
update again here update three what you
have written right in the latest update
would you have
and you can save it and close
so that's how you keep track of your
sticky note and you'll have all your
updates right
now getting back to the hyperlinks again
uh the last one is email address
so you can also try to add okay let's
imagine that you're working with a
colleague and every time you make an
update in your excel sheet or anything
and you wanted to send them out an email
right so it would be a little
time-consuming that you open your
email and compose something and send it
over here but what if you had a one
single click and access to the email
compose option right that can be done so
let us write down
actually
about me with the spelling
so again the control k and hyperlink
select email option
and you can write down your email
which can be anything so you can write
down your friend's email address
so i'm just writing down some random
email here
friend at gmail.com and
you can write the subject about update
and
press ok
this will navigate you
to the gmail option or the mailing
address options
click on it
and you'll have a variety of mailing
options outlook
office 365 yahoo icloud google etc so
you can select any one of those since we
have written as gmail.com we'll navigate
to gmail and all you have to do is login
you know all the formalities and you're
good to go with emailing
so let's get this for now so you're you
know how to do the rest parts so so far
we have you know covered all the
hyperlink options in excel that is
existing file or a web page place this
in the current executing worksheet or
document creating a new document for
your update thing and also including the
email right so so far we have covered
everything around hype link in excel and
if you have anything to know more about
or if you feel that we have missed out
anything important regarding hyperlink
in excel you can feel free to let us
know so next thing is how you actually
activate the macros in your excel
it's a simple uh tab that you need to
add
in the ribbon section which i'll be
showing you across
and this will enable the macros on your
excel so you go to files
go to options
and then you need to customize the
ribbon click customize ribbon
and then there is a developer tab which
you see here it should be activated so
you just need to select that
click on the
tick mark and just click ok
so this will add a developer tab here
and
this will enable the macro so now you
you have your data and you can run
macros or record a macro and run it
on your excel
there is also an option to do it a
different way right click on any of the
tabs on the ribbon customize ribbon and
you can
add or remove
your macros from here so this is two
ways that you need to that you can
activate your macros so how you record a
macro is the next thing
so here i have a work orders sheet that
i receive every day or one of you will
receive every day and
how you record a macro you have certain
set of tasks that you do
and
you know this report has so many things
that are obsolete which you do not need
which has to be put across to your
management or your
for your use so how you record or
start a macro you go to the developer
tab and start recording a macro as soon
as you click on this record macro button
it will start
recording your keystrokes on the mouse
mouse clicks
and you can save that and run it as a
script in the next sheet that you do
so
this is the sheet that i have
and
we'll try to run a macros on this and
see what it does
so here i have and
this actually works this way uh i need
to go to the developer tab and start
recording a macro
so when i click a record macro it
starts uh recording my mouse clicks and
keystrokes so in this sheet i have to
you know remove some columns and
the columns that are obsolete and the
data that looks
weird here should be removed and all
what i need is the work order number the
district and the tactician name and the
kind of service that we provide and
the requested workday
the cost
and the payment so this is what i want
and i do it every day when i received
the sheet and i have to
make these changes and send it across to
the accounts team
so what i do is i simply
automate this by running a macro
so
i go to
let's see how it records the macro
i click record macro i save it as work
order
accounts
i'll add a little description like
work order
for
account
cost
click okay
and
see what i do is basically i
add the borders first
so that the data looks proper
and then i do not want this column i
delete it
i do not want the number of technicians
that are there
i do not want all these and i also want
the labor hours the account and what
kind of payment this is very crucial for
the
scheme i do not want any of these
obsolete data
so i just delete this
okay
and then
i just want to have some cosmetic
changes done so
i make sure this
doesn't have any border
and
that's it this is the task that i
perform
every day i still don't need this
and i go to the developer tab and click
stop recording so now i have the macro
save
and when i have it i have
you know automated these all these steps
in one simple click
and how i execute it in another sheet so
i will show it across to you
the next thing so here i have the next
report that has to be uh changed or
formatted and send it across so i simply
go the next morning and go to the
developer tab
and
go to the macro and i have this macro
save which we ran the just now and i
simple with a single click i will be
able to do these daily tasks
and execute in a flash so i just click
run and it does the rest for me i have
my report ready and is in a proper
format that is required and it can be
sent across so here as we see it is done
in a single click by running
a simple macro continuing our
work on macro we can simply do this by a
single click of a button by adding a
button so
what you have to do is go to the
developer tab and in the control section
you will see the insert add
your macro and assign it so as we have
saved it work order accounts as a macro
and when i just
assign that macro to this button
i can edit the text by
making
things work order
accounts just to make it simple
okay
and
now if you see if i just click this
button it will run the macro
and format our sheet
so this is how we
run the macros in a single click of a
button by adding the button
there is another alternative way to go
to the macros in instead of the
developer tab and you go to the view
button
and then go to macros at the end
you can view macros you can record and
you can edit your macro so when i click
view macros it will show you what are
the macros that i have and that i can
run and you can simply run it
alternatively
and you can record a macro as well
instead of from the developer tab
if you just click on record macro it
will do the same functions that we do
from the developer tab
the next thing is to edit the macro how
do you edit your macro you have
to use a simple application in excel
which is the vba visual basic
application to edit your macro you go to
the developer tab
and then click on visual basic this
literally opens another window
like this and you will see the module
that you have been working on
and you can edit the
macro here
so as we see
if you go back to the excel
we see that
our sheet we have been working on
the sheet and it has the column still k
and the actual sheet is this
so if i go to the visual basic
editor and
i'll make sure they know i remove the
columns that are existing from the
column m
and i just delete that
and i click
run
i go back to my sheet and you see
these changes are not there
okay
this is your old
macro and this is our new macro
as we see this sheet has the rush column
which is the priority
of my orders
so these are the things that we can edit
with the vba
what is vba visual basic application it
is basically a visual basic application
language uh that is used for macros in
excel
so what it basically does visual basic
for application is a programming
language of excel that helps you
automate task by writing macros we have
seen how we use macros how it simplifies
our tedious daily tasks
by running a simple macro
now to help us
you know
write these macros and help us get the
best use of our
abilities to
ease our work and automate our task we
use vba
so
why vba there are many advantages of
using vba and why we prefer vba in
macros for excel
so basically it is a very simple
language it saves time in pro performing
tedious tasks you have number of tasks
that you do every day as we have seen in
the previous section
how we uh you can simplify your daily
task by just running a simple macro and
this vba helps us in performing those
steps
in a very simple manner
another thing is it supports
english like statements there are
multiple statements that you can use and
which are very basic english language
statements
and this can help us or it is very easy
to program or
code or edit these commands you can
select a range you can it is like
if an else statement
and things like that we will look into
those in details in the next sections
now one more thing is it improves the
functionality of excel by allowing you
to make excel behave the way you want
there are multiple functions that you
perform in excel like selecting a number
of rows or columns or
selecting a set of cells
in particular you do it on a daily basis
so these things can easily be performed
and easily be edited and executed by
using vba we will look into those in
detail now what is the vba editor
interface this is particularly uh
an interface which you will have uh look
in detail
where where you can edit your commands
or your codes for your excel
now how this is uh achieved we will see
it here
now these are the this is basically the
vba editor interface where you can see
the uh
this is the toolbar section where it
shows all the options where in undo or
save or file they will see those details
in the next section this is basically
the toolbar section of the vba editor
interface the next thing is the menu bar
menu bar as we all know it is simply it
shows you the menu wherein you have all
the options like file edit view insert
insert is the one very important uh menu
bar option
and when you can insert different
modules and buttons and all we'll look
into those in details run is one more
important thing all these things fall
under menu bar
the next thing is the vba code window
maybe a code window as it says is the
code window where your actual code
resides
wherein you can go into it and edit the
code or write the course and select the
different range of functions that you
can perform and this is basically the
vba code window
where you
edit your or write your codes
the next thing is the project explorer
project explorer is simply like a
windows explorer but this is in
particular is specific to your
vba
wherein it shows the different options
that are there the
excel sheets or the worksheets that
you're working on or the modules that
you have saved and so on basically it is
an explorer for your vba like a windows
explorer which is for the file explorer
the next thing is the properties window
properties windows shows you the
properties of the worksheet that you're
working on for instance here we are
working on the sheet 2
and it shows the properties what are the
kind of
[Music]
worksheet that we have the page breaks
the right to left whether it is enabled
or not the name of the sheet and so on
whether it's visible and things like
that
the next thing is the immediate window
and the
watch window
now what is the immediate window
immediate window is basically a tool or
a window wherein you can run and execute
simple
lines of course individual excel code
that you can run it will allow you to
test individual lines
which is very useful and handy when you
are writing and debugging codes
the output if the
lines that you execute can be seen here
in the immediate window whereas watch
window watch window is similar to it but
it displays the value of the watch
expression in its current current state
so this can be extremely useful again
while we are debugging the vba code
adding a watch is a great utility and we
will see uh the use the
advantages of having a watch window in
your
vba interface
so these are the things that we'll learn
and look into it in detail in the coming
section now we continue our topic for
visual basic for application
for macros and
uh i'm going to show you how to
you know run some codes and
macros and codes and
perform some simple to complex tasks
using the vba for macros
so
there are two ways to open the visual
basic application and the first thing is
you can run alt f11 click on the sheet
and then just press and it will open the
visual basic for application
window or alternatively you can just go
and click on the visual basic and it
will open the
sheet for you i mean the code window for
you and as we have discussed before
these are the windows that we see this
is the code window and this is the
project explorer
and
this is the immediate window
and we you can run some
testing codes immediately it will show
you the output so here we see the
project explorer window where we see the
modules in all
for our visual basic for applications
so as we see the code is empty here
we'll try to record a macro and see how
the code develops okay so i just go here
and click record macro
and i save it as
a format
and
columns
okay
this quickly can i just save it click
okay
and it has started recording so now what
i'll do is as
make it simple and i just delete some
columns here
[Music]
i do not need this
i delete this
derivate i want this i want the amount
of payment
parts cost labor hours i do not want
this
number of technicians forget it
okay
and i go for the left and see what all
do i need i need i don't need this
i delete all these and
i just expand this so that it's clearly
visible
and then i want to change the format i
mean the hot
so
i select this
[Music]
and i change it to time stream
okay
go back to my developer tab click stop
recording it is saved
okay now go back to my
code
and see
the
macro here
so we see the macro here and we can see
in detail what it looks like so
we see the code what it's doing and what
the macro
run has generated the code with so we
see we have basically the name of the
macro is format columns and what it is
doing we're just selecting the columns
and
deleting some we're checking the range
on some columns e select that is the e
column that we have selected
and then again so on
and
the next thing is the font selection
that is mentioned
we are changing it to times new roman
size is 11 so
it is basically
a basic vba code so it starts with the
sub and it should end with msu so this
is the code or a format of the vba code
that it looks like and we'll try to do
some basic functions with the
vba and discuss this in further details
so for ease of explanation i have picked
up a blank
spreadsheet and
i'll try to explain some basic uh
functions and
the commands and the codes that we use
to
accomplish the
task that we with vba
so as we see this is the blank sheet and
i have selected a new module for it
so here i start the code and as it says
it starts with sub and
i am specifying the
module name as
number
so i'll just try to make it quite simple
and
you know so we as soon as we enter the
sub it sends with the end sub and so
this is the
start of the code and this is the end of
the code and whatever is there should be
here and this is the name of the
code or the macro now uh i'll explain it
further about the dim statement why is
it used and what does it use for
so dim is basically a keyword which is
the
short form of dimension and it is used
to declare variables in the
vba so here i am trying to specify a
variable called x and how i'm going to
do it i
will
have it as a number or an integer or
anything so here in this example i'll
put it as an integer or a number okay
and as i put as it populates the prompt
so i select integer
and for example i select the number to
be
500
okay
and here i'm trying to assign a
variable integer
a cell a value of
500 with a dim keyword
so
where exactly i want to put this you
will see it when you execute the code
okay
range
i am selecting
it should be under course where i'm
going to put the
value of x as and i close the bracket
and
what should be the value
we will
value should be x
so now as i click
run sub
or you can do it with the
by running the alt
f5 key and it will run the
code so you see here in the excel sheet
it executes the value of the cell b5 to
be 500 so this is one simple function
that you can do
with the uh dimension keyboard or dim
keyword
and you can assign the value as integers
now proceed we proceed further with
certain more examples some more examples
and how we assign the string value as a
as a text or
something else okay
now i'm going to show you what dim can
be executed
used as so set variable stream can be
used as a
double
when double is basically a longer form
of single variable it usually takes more
space but uses
needs more larger numbers okay and then
you can set
double and i just don't specify it and
you can use date
it basically stores the date values okay
and then again string so what string
does if you use string it stores the
text it can contain numbers it will have
some text as calculations or anything
can be performed so these are the basic
thing that i will cover
and
you can also use different uh
values for it so i will discuss this in
the next example
okay
[Music]
so in the next example i'll try to set
or
use a string value for it and
i put it as a string
such string
[Music]
value
this is my name
so as soon as i hit enter it ends with
the answer prompt and now i can give my
code
so
i put it as dim book as
string
okay
now
i'm trying to use
to name a country or put a value
of a country to one of the
cells so
let's see
how it goes and
i select country
and in country i select
mark
[Music]
okay
now what is the value or the cell that
basically takes the or we will put the
name of the country as so i have to
specify a range and as soon as i hit
it goes and i have to specify the
the cell here so here i put it as g
and
four
okay
so i close it
and i put a value what value i am going
to assign it is a country
okay
now
i'll try to run this code by simply
and see
g4
the name
populates as a country here so this is a
dim keyword you being used as a string
in our vba code
so
uh we can also use uh
vba to you know pop up a message or an
alert or a kind of a button or a message
pop-up pops up when you execute this
code so this basically can be uh
executed using uh
the
code here which i'm going to put
and we use the
okay let's give it a value
i'm going to name it as double value and
again the name keyword
it usually takes more space and larger
numbers and
we'll try to assign it okay now i'm
going to pop up a message in there which
says value of a is so and so so i'm
going to give value of a as
2 5 0
okay
and how i it pops up a message okay
so there is a message box
which you know can be used and it will
give you a value i mean it will prompt
you to enter the value what kind of
button you want and
you you can enter the text and you can
enter the value so here i'm going to
write a code which
you know which gives a pop-up message a
message box saying that the value of a
is so
i'm going to put it in percent
code
so it actually takes the value of e
okay
now that's it and let's try to run this
and you will see a message copying
message box popping up
okay so the value of
the message box
pops up saying the value of a is 250
so
in the next example i am going to
write a code wherein you know you can
give a value or a string you can assign
it to a selected cell and this basically
used when you
have some
you know when you have a
task of you know giving a value to a
particular cell or you have to assign a
text
or say something about a report okay so
this let's see how it goes and we use
the
i will say
it as
fun with some procedures
[Music]
this is the name and
again dim
so here i am going to i am going to give
a user input and it will be as a
string
okay you can give anywhere i mean any
string or any statement what my user
input will be i will define it here
[Music]
is the
report
for
eeq
let's make it simple
okay
and where i'm going to put it is
in the active cell or the cell
that i
have it
select okay what will be the value
the value will be the user input
i have defined user input as
this is a report for vba so this cell
turns into you this is a report for vba
i run this
and you see this
so in some cases you need to run this
and
you know it makes life quite simple when
you use vba
as we have seen before we have used
message box now i'm going to use the
same message box
to
display my name or you can use it to
display your name so let's see how it
goes
i'm going to name it as
name
okay and it's very simple you have to
define a message box
which displays your
name
and i'm going to put it under course
that my name is
[Music]
and we'll try to
run it
see
here so it pops up a message saying that
my name isn't fun so this is a message
box that you can display and i can do
anything with this
[Music]
this is
[Music]
okay i run it again and it pops this
message so these are the things that you
can use to customize or you know when
you open an excel sheet or try to run a
workshop or a report and it pops up a
message customary welcome messages that
you can customize or
you know define a
report or kind of
data in it and this can be used using
run using the message box
now i have another good example wherein
you know you can write a code to
tell excel what is the value of
a cell or what is the number that is
there in the cell so
here it is
i put the sub
okay
number
and
it will again
populate a message box
which
will set it to
the
the entered
[Music]
value
is
and it should tell me
which or i specify which cell it is that
we are going to find the value of okay
so i give a range
of
i have to give it in codes
i'm going to
code completed
and it should tell me the value
of the number that is present in the
cell
a1
okay
it ends let's try to run it
run it and it will give me the value so
this is how we can use excel to
determine or show or populate a message
box which will give us the value of the
number that is there in the cell so here
i can change it to
a
4
as well
and try to run it
and it will give me the number so
this is simple way of you know
populating a message box which will tell
us the
value of
uh let me show you one more simple
example where in a message box pops up
on a welcome message that can be pop
set when you open the uh excel or
worksheet so
so let's uh
name it as auto
open
[Music]
and then
again message box i want it to populate
and
what does it say
i put it in quotes welcome
to
our
worksheet
of workshop
[Music]
it's very simple you just run it and
[Music]
see
it pops up a message saying welcome to a
workshop so these are the
one more this is one more way where you
can you know run the code or to simple
welcome message on
excel
next i'm going to show you a code
wherein you can give a value or assign a
value to a particular cell by simple
curved
so
we name it as add value
now i specify the range i mean where
i am going to specify a cell
where
the value will be given to the
cell
i am going to
give it as v5
okay so put it in codes close the
parenthesis
what is the value that i'm going to give
value equals
2 5 0
okay so now with this code i mean i'm
going to assign a value of 250 to the
cell b5 let's see
run it see
again i do it to p10
okay
so this is how you can assign a value to
a particular cell
now i can run uh the same thing and give
a range of cells i mean
let me make it very simple here
i give it as
b1
through
b
five
as
four five zero so
let's see what it does see here i'm
going i'm specifying the range to be b1
through b5 so it is doing it for the
whole range
okay
and
and then i can give a another set of
range here
like
let me specify it
range to be
[Music]
c
one
i have to give it a course
give me an error
symbol colon
c4
and i separate it with a comma and i can
specify another range so the next one
will be d1
to
d4
and then i close the codes
close the parenthesis
however the value that i give is
let's say
two three zero
and i try to run it
so it gives the value
of c1 through c4 and d1 through d4 as
230 as we specified it in the
code
so this is one of one more example
wherein you can assign values to the
uh
so range of cells or cells and with the
vba
one more thing i can
you know assign a value to a particular
cell by specifying these cells it's very
simple just specify the cells like
oh six
comma
seven
okay
and
i close the parenthesis
i assign a value to it
value equals
10.
let's see
see
here it assigns the value to that
particular cell that we have specified
row 6
and columns
okay
so this is one more example wherein you
can assign values to particular cells
okay in the next example uh there will
be a scenario where you need to select a
range of cells in the sheet so this can
also be done this task can also be
performed using vba
so
i will show you how
this is our
let's say select a
what i'm doing is i'm specific range
because i need to select a range of
cells okay
now i'm going to set the variable as
set example where i'm going to define
the range of the cells that should be
selected
so let's say a
1
to
t
5
okay this will be the
selection
and what i'm going to
set the value okay i am going to set the
value
example i'm going to give it a value of
256. so
let's see how it pans out
okay so here i'm selecting a
set of
cells a range of cells and i'm going to
assign a value
with this function
so this makes it quite simple and this
will be used in a regular daily task
when you know there is there will be a
scenario where you
have to select a set of cells and give a
give a value to it so you can do it with
a click of a button with the vba
now i can simply tweak this with the you
know by just selecting it so
there is
i'll remove this
and
instead of assigning a value i'll just
put an option to select it
now let's just run it and see what
happens next
okay
so this is one way of you know just
selecting it okay and then you see it
becomes easier for you to copy paste and
do some functions so you can select this
and you can assign a value and you can
also give a set of values to a
particular range or cells with these
codes
now what if i want to do a selection of
the same
rows and columns in the next sheet
and i can do this with the
set of another set of commands so i will
show you how
so here let's say you know we set the
same thing
and we specify the worksheets okay
worksheets
i want it in sheet2 okay so i just put
it as g2 and i activate it basically
activating it and now i am going to
specify the worksheet
2
and what is the range that i'm going to
select the same thing okay
the range will be
a1
to
d5
okay
what i'm going to do i'm going to select
it
okay
and see what happens here
okay
so here i am selecting the worksheet too
and i'm activating it and i'm going to
assign range and i'm going to select it
so i can just
copy the same or select the same set of
cells
in the next sheet
okay now when there will be
uh as i said there will be you know by
requirement where you need to copy some
cell contents and paste it to another
location so how you do that it's uh
again a simple code that you can write
and let's say
let's say it has a
copy
and paste i'm just making it simple by
giving something that we can understand
and relate
[Music]
okay
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
select this range
and i'm going to copy it and paste it
somewhere here okay
so let me just remove this
and
i'll show you
first we have to specify the range where
you want to copy
the cells okay so let's say it is again
a1
it should be in course
five
of course
and i am going to select it okay
then
what i'm going to do is
once you select this the selection that
you have
should what should be the function and i
am going to specify the selection
and the function should be
copying it
okay
so i just
said that
and where i'm going to paste it so i
have to now specify the range
where i have to
paste this selection
and you can just mention the
column here let's say
g
10
okay
and close it
i'm going to select it
and then where i'm going to paste it i
can do it in this sheet okay
active sheet
and paste it
so
we are selecting a range of cells
selection
and that selection what we are doing is
we will copy it
and now we are going to specify the
range where you are going to select it
and then
paste it
quite simple
let's
okay
see
and
you can just change it so it is visible
on this
okay
so
this makes
quite easy
and you can run it
the next scenario will be like
when you need to
get the count of the number of cells
like you have to have a selection and
you need to count the number of cells so
this can also be done and it's quite
easy
i am going to show it to you
let's say the sub the
account
cells
should always be relatable so that you
know you remember and you understand
what is
the output and why you're using it and
i'm going to set a
variable let's say
i'm going to set an example for this and
what we're going to do is we are going
to specify a range first okay we will
specify the range of
the cells that we are going to
that we need to count basically
so i'm going to set a variable as a
range and
then
what we are going to do is
example
and we will specify the range here
you can specify the range or your
selection where you count the when you
need the count of the number of cells
so a1
[Music]
d5
now how you want the output you want it
you want a message box to pop up
so you will set a message box
and
what should it give you will give you
the count of the
variable that is the variable is here is
examples okay so
it will count the number of cells in
this
area
okay
let's see it says
okay here i think i'm listed so i just
specify the
number here
and let's see so it gives you the number
of
count in this 20 okay
now let's see i want to
six
so it gives you the selection so it's
quite simple it will be very useful in
our daily task and then you need to
count the number of cells so this is one
way to get it
well i can further tweak this and to
determine the
or count the number of rows or columns
so it's again very simple i just need to
do some changes here i have to set the
column count
so if i want to
calculate the number of columns
just
[Music]
let's see how it should calculate or
give the message
the number of columns here
see it gives there are five columns okay
one two
one two three four five okay so it gives
us the number of columns here
if i change it to
should give
me four followers
okay similarly you can count the number
of rows here
just change it to rows
see
it says six rows are there
okay
should give me number
see
so this way you can calculate the number
of
count the number of
cells number of columns number of rows
with this
the next thing i'm going to talk about
is the if statement if statement is one
of the
most widely used statement and
whoever is in programming are very much
familiar with this function so what it
does is we specify a condition if
condition is met then the output output
should be such and such we can specify
the condition and it will check
whether that condition is there and if
it is
uh
space i mean if it is
achieved then you will have to specify
the output as well so this can be
achieved with the
if statement
okay and it is very easy because it is
it understand the basic uh english
language so it's not very complicated
and i'll show you how
so the syntax can be like this if
suppose you specify a condition
and if that condition is met
then the result you specify the
condition and the result
okay so this is one thing and then you
can specify the
s or else condition
where you know you specify the condition
2
then
the result should be
this
so here you are going to
specify two conditions or multiple
conditions where you specify
this and if it is there then result will
be this if it is this condition and then
the result will be something else
let's take an example wherein you have
to you have some scores or marks
and you have to
select a result you can't do this
manually
entering so just you can write a code
suppose for example
i have it here
okay let's
and
i specify as
a
statement
okay now i have to specify the
variables now i have two variables i
have a score and i have a
result and the score is an integer the
number and the result is a string path
of a
so i specify this okay dim
score
i specify it as integer okay
and then
there's another variable that i have to
set
result
as
string
okay
now what the score will be the score i
have to specify the range
score i'm giving it as a range i mean
it's in my
cell a1
okay
i specify the range
what is it it is a value
okay
sorry
should be a dot
okay
and then i'm specifying a condition here
if
score value the variable
is greater than or equal so as i said
it's quite simple and it takes the basic
english
language functions
then
the
result result is another variable that i
have said result what it should be it
should be
in quotes
pass
okay
so
if this condition is met then the result
will be this okay
and now where i want to specify my
result i should give a range for that as
well
so i give it in the next column or any
one
this is the basic
example
value should be
the result
okay let's see how it drops
see
says pass
change to 40.
it doesn't give me anything because i
have specified only one condition here
okay
change of 75 let's see how it runs
see
so this way it's very basic condition
that you are specifying you are
specifying two variables the score and
the result
and then you are giving a value for it
and you are specifying the condition if
the score is greater than then the
result should be passed
now in the next uh section uh
we will simply tweak this and use an if
then else statement we'll attach an else
statement with it and see we'll specify
another condition and see so here again
we'll use two variables that is the
score as integer and the result as a
string and let's uh stick to the same
values
now
i'm going to specify it and if the score
is greater than 60
then
the result
so the result will be passed as it is
before
and then
i'm going to specify another condition
else
the result should be
should be
[Music]
and now
i have to put it to the end if statement
i have to
specify the nsu and the result will be
again in the value i mean the range will
be v1 so let's see if it is more than 60
then it is passed otherwise it is fake
okay this pass let's see
40.
run it
okay so we are specifying two variables
again we are giving at a range and we
are specifying one condition if this
condition is met the result is passed
otherwise else it is fail
so another set of example
uh the next statement that we use or we
are going to discuss is the
loop statement that is the for loop
statement and why we use it there are
there are situations and
tasks that you need to execute and
you need to do it several number of
times
these are basically executed
sequentially it means one after another
so the first statement or the function
is executed and the next
is taken up so
and then the next and so on so
these loop statements allow us to
execute a statement or a group of
statements multiple number of times many
number of times and this happens only
when the first task or the first
task is done
and it executes that and it goes to the
next one so here we'll discuss a simple
example
of the
for loop statement
so let's see how it
works
and i'm going to set up a
loop statement okay again the
i'm going to make it as loop 1
so here it is i have to specify the
variable that is dim
and i'm going to specify x as an integer
okay i'll try to execute it and then
explain it what happens and how it
executes okay for x equals to 1 to
24 okay let's see
and
i'm going to specify the range
range as
so what i'm going to do is basically i'm
going to fill the
column a
from 1 to 24 with some value 1 from 1 to
24 with the values of 1
through 24 okay
so i'm setting up a
range
and
how it ends is
it gives me a value
now it excuse this and goes to the next
so i'll explain you how so we are
setting up a loop we are setting up an
integer a variable x as integer and we
are setting the value of x to be 1 to 24
so here
for 1 it executes the first thing is it
it takes x as 1
and it fills in
a1
and then the next value of x will be 2
and it goes to a2 and fills the value as
2. so just let's try to execute this and
you will see
the
row column a filled with 1 through 24
see
it's quite simple it executes one
condition
and then goes to the next and we are
defining it with the number of values
and the variable as x and the number of
values is going to be 24
okay so this is one basic example of a
for loop statement
now let's do some more addition to this
example by
you know executing another set of per
loop
and giving the output and we'll code the
output to be the color code advance in
the column b so how we do it it's a
basic simple example that i'm going to
take and again
what i'm going to do is i will have this
values here and i'm going to color code
the
b column with certain color index for
each number there will be a different
color so let's see
and
what i'm going to do is i'm only going
to change the
b
and what action is going here we put up
a value now we're going to
select it
and with this selection
what i'm going to do is it should select
it
and
it should color the interior with word
with the color index
okay
and the value of
x
and then i'm going to specify the
pattern what uh pattern it will take for
the
box to be colored and i'm going to put
it as a solid
it will fill the whole thing with the
solid and then i just executed see
it takes this
color b
let's code it like this
so these are the simple things that you
can set up with the
codes and for loop statements
so there are numerous examples and
exercises that you can perform tasks we
can perform with the vba
and this can be found in detail
now next exclusive advanced courses
now at times you might be working on a
really important spreadsheet on your
excel or you might have the sales data
of your company or some confidential
data of your organization
and you might have shared the file with
your junior or you might face some
pocket issue and you forgot to save or
you missed to save your data
and what to do if you cannot save your
data and how can you recover it right so
this might be a really big hassle today
we are exactly going to discuss the same
and see how to do it in multiple ways so
excel comes up with an option to
automatically save the data also it will
try to warn you that your data is not
being saved would you like me to save it
or not right so we'll do the first one
so here you have the auto save option
you can either say ok to it or you can
ignore it in case if you ignore it if
you choose to ignore it or if you choose
to manually save it and then if you want
to close the file remember we haven't
saved the file if you wish to close it
excel will automatically come up with a
dialog box asking you want to save your
changes to your data.xlsx
that means it is asking you if i have to
save it or not
let's try to ignore this and
forcefully let's try to close it you can
go to task manager option here we are
trying to simulate the option of parker
tissues
so we are forcefully closing excel
without saving any data
so we have closed it now here you can
see we do not have excel running in the
background now when you directly open or
try to start excel when you get the
power backup again and if you want to
open that same data file it will ask you
the document recovery option it says you
have closed the file without saving the
changes and you can choose to you know
come back from the same place where we
left last time okay
now that was the pocket issue and now
let's see uh another way okay let's
imagine that somebody uh eliminated a
few important data files from your
organization's confidential data
employee id employee name etc and again
let's simulate the force
close of the excel
now we are closing it again without
saving no data has been saved
now it will also ask the same
data it has another version here the
original one
which wasn't saved so here you can
recover the same file again however it
was initially so you can save it and it
will get back to the original place
so this was one way also we have another
few multiple ways just we have to
navigate to file and here you can open
and in the open menu you have a button
called recover unsaved workbooks not
just the current workbook it will also
have all the remaining files
which are related to excel that are not
saved
so here you have a few workbooks which
was not saved this is one option and we
also have another option
we can just navigate to info
and there you have another option called
manage workbook and in the manage
workbook you have another option called
recover unsaved workbooks which will
also redirect you to the same file that
is microsoft office unsaved files and
you'll have all the ncaa workbooks which
are related to excel so this is how you
can recover the unsaved data in excel
using multiple ways first thing excel
will automatically ask you if you have
to save the file or not and in case if
you forget to save it you can
directly recover it by default by excel
it will automatically show that some
folder was not saved on the left side of
your excel spreadsheet by default and in
case if you missed out on that one you
can manually go to file and you can
either choose open option or info option
to recover the unseen folders from your
default file location from your pc that
is microsoft office unsaved files etc
which will have all the list of all
unsaved workbooks related to excel
excel supports a number of shortcut keys
that you can use to speed up your work
and make your work efficient
these shortcuts make working with
spreadsheets a little easier now the
question arises do i need to memorize
the shortcut keys the answer is no
the keyboard shortcuts in excel helps
you perform data analysis better and
faster but it would be an advantage if
you can remember a few of them
now
let's begin by looking at some of the
important workbook related shortcuts
so we will see how to create a new
workbook open an existing workbook and
save a spreadsheet so that you don't
lose any data or calculations that you
have done
towards the end
you will see how you can toggle between
different sheets in a workbook
now to open an excel workbook on windows
you can just search for excel here
you can see
this is the excel app
and click on it
and you can see there's the home tab
new tab from here you can open any
existing workbook as well so let me go
to the new tab
and open a blank workbook
now mark here on the top it says book
one
dash excel
now
if you were to create a new workbook the
shortcut is control plus n
now
mark this
so if i hit control plus n
you can see it has opened a new workbook
called book2
i can show you to you here
you can see there are two workbooks book
1 and book 2.
so the shortcut to open a new workbook
is ctrl n
now if you want to open an existing
workbook that is present in your system
the shortcut is ctrl o
so if i hit ctrl o
you can go to browse and check for
your excel file that is present on your
system let me go to the desktop and
search for
excel workbooks
you can see i have two excel files here
let me select the kovid 19 file and
click on open
i'll enable editing
there you go
so we have our existing workbook opened
on excel
now if you want to save a workbook or a
spreadsheet
the shortcut is control plus s
now this is very simple you use it in
other editors as well
now suppose
i
duplicate this column
i use ctrl c
go on top
and hit ctrl v
now to save this spreadsheet i'll just
press ctrl
s you can see the workbook is saved
now you can also click on
this one which says save control s
so i don't need this column actually so
let me go ahead and delete this column
and now to close the current workbook
the shortcut is control plus w
so if i hit control
w
it will ask me do you want to save this
file or not
i'll say don't save and it will close
that current file
next if you want to close excel
the shortcut key is ctrl f4
now if i hit control f4
you can see my book one is closed so i
can go ahead and close the workbook
now let me go ahead and open a workbook
again
so i'll search for excel
and click on it
i'll go to a blank workbook
now if you want to move to the next
sheet you can use control page down
now in this current workbook we have
only one sheet
now let me create
two more sheets and come to sheet1
now if you want to move to the next
sheet the shortcut is control page down
so if i hit control page down you can
see i am in sheet 2 now
if i again hit control page down
i have come to sheet 3.
next if you want to move on to the
previous sheet
the shortcut is control page up so let
me hit ctrl page up you can see i am in
sheet 2 now
and if i hit control page of once again
i have come to sheet1
now to get a little more clarity on this
let me open a workbook that has multiple
sheets or multiple tables
so i will hit control o
and i look for my sample superstore data
set
click on it
you can see
this data set has three tables the first
one is the orders table
the second one is the returns table
which has the detail about the orders
that were returned
and the next table is of people table
that basically has person and the region
to which the person belong to
so let me come to my orders table
now if i want to move to my returns and
people table
for that i can hit control page down
which is to move to the next sheet
so if i hit control page down see i am
in the returns table now
if i hit control page down once again i
have come to my people table
if you want to move back i'll hit ctrl p
drop
you can see i am in my returns table
if i hit ctrl p once again
i have come back to my orders table
now there are a few other shortcuts that
i want to tell you here
so suppose you want to switch between
different tabs that are present in the
ribbon you can do that as well with the
help of shortcut keys
so in excel this is the ribbon which has
different tabs like the file tab home
tab insert draw page layout
and so on
now currently we are in the home tab
if you want to move to the data tab
the shortcut is alt a so if i hit alt a
you can see we have come to the data tab
now if you want to go to the view tab
the shortcut is alt w
you can see we have come to the view tab
and if you want to move to the formula
tab the shortcut is alt m so if i hit
alt m
you can see we have come to the formula
tab
now let me open another excel file well
we have listed all the shortcut keys
that we are covering in this video
so let me go ahead and do that
so i'll go to file
and under open
i'll click on browse
and
under desktop
i look for my excel shortcut keys file
and click on open
so this is the excel sheet we have
created for you for your reference
you can pause the video to note the
shortcut keys we have covered so far
if you want to get access to this excel
sheet please share your email address in
the chat section we'll send it to you
over email
so far we have covered all the workbook
related shortcuts
so these are the shortcuts we have
covered so far that i am highlighting
here
now let's move back to our slides
and see what we have next
so you can see we have our cell
formatting shortcuts up next
now here i will tell you the different
shortcuts that can be applied to a cell
such as editing a cell aligning cell
contents adding a border to a cell
adding an outline to all the selected
cells etc
so let's go ahead and do these
operations
so
i'll go to my
book one
and the first shortcut that we'll see is
how to edit a cell
for example
there are certain values
such as 10
20 30
and
if i scroll down
like this
and now if you want to edit the cells
you can just
select that cell here i have selected
a4 cell you can see on the top
and hit f2 to edit the cell
so if i hit f2
you can see i can edit the cell and make
it say 40.
similarly i'll hit
f2 again and make this as 50
and so on
now
you can also edit the formula that is
present in a cell so let me use a
formula say we'll calculate the sum
and
i'll choose
a1 to a8 and find the sum now if i
select this and click on f2
i can change the formula as well
let's say average
i'll hit enter you can see it has
calculated the average from a1
to a8
now if you want to copy paste cells the
shortcut is very simple is ctrl c and
ctrl v
now suppose i want to copy
cell
a4 i can just hit ctrl c
and i'll hit ctrl v to paste it
similarly you can also select a range of
cells and hit ctrl c
and ctrl b to paste it similarly
you can also copy paste
different cells
from other worksheets so i have come to
my sample superstore workbook and let me
select a few cells
and
i can copy it
by hitting ctrl c i'll move back
and i can paste it ctrl v
next if you want to bold and italicize
the font values in a cell you can use
ctrl b and ctrl i respectively
so if i want to bold
suppose
the headings or the column names i can
use ctrl b
you can see it's bold
and if i want to italicize certain
values let me select this one i can use
ctrl i to italicize it i'll hit ctrl i
you can see
it's italicized
now you can also underline the cell
contents so let me show you how to do
that for this purpose we use control
plus u
so
let me select this cell
and i'll hit control u you can see
it has added an underline similarly let
me do it for one more cell
i'll hit control plus u you can see it
has put an underline to this cell as
well
now if you want to fill colors to
certain cells
the shortcut you can use is alt plus h
plus h
so let me show you
if i select this cell and hit
alt h
you can see it has
it has prompted me to select a color
i'll select this blue color
and you can see
you have filled a color to this cell
similarly
you can fill color to a range of cells
as well i have selected these cells and
let me hit alt
h
and this time i'll select this green
color
you can see we have filled all the cells
with green color
now
if you want to add a border to a cell
the shortcut is alt plus h plus b
now let me select
this cell 40
and hit alt plus h plus b
so it has prompted me to select the type
of border that you want
now let me select i want a top border
you can see
here
it has put a top border to cell b5
and now let me choose
cell e6
and
again hit alt
h b
and this time
let's say i'll select all borders
you can see the cell has all borders
across it
now if you were to remove the outline
border the shortcut is control plus
shift plus underscore
so if i want to remove this top border
from cell b5
i'll hit ctrl shift underscore
you can see the top border is no more
there
similarly
let's remove all border from cell e6
i'll hit
ctrl shift underscore you can see the
border is gone
now if you want to add outline to
selected cells
the shortcut is control plus shift plus
ampersand
so let me select
the cells that i had colored just now
and if i hit ctrl shift ampersand
you can see it has added a border
to the selected cells i can show it to
you here as well let me select it
and hit
ctrl shift ampersand
you can see it has added a border
to all the selected cells
another thing i want to show you here is
if you want to move to the previous cell
the shortcut is
shift tab
so if i select this cell and hit
shift tab it will take me back to the
next cell which is e8
if i hit shift tab again it takes me to
c8 next is b8
then it's a8
now if you want to move to the next cell
the shortcut is
tab so if i hit tab
will take me to the next cell
now
if you want to select the cells on the
right
the shortcut is ctrl shift right arrow
so initially if i select cell h2 and now
i want to select all the cells on the
right i can just hit
ctrl shift right arrow so as you can see
it has selected all the cells on the
right
similarly
if you want to select all the cells on
the left
the shortcut is ctrl shift
left arrow
as you can see it has selected all the
cells
now if you want to select the column
from the selected cell to the end of the
table
the shortcut is ctrl shift down arrow
so
i'll hit ctrl shift down arrow you can
see it has selected the entire column
now if you want to select the data above
the selected cell
the shortcut is ctrl shift up arrow so
i'll hit ctrl shift up arrow you can see
it has selected all the cells that were
present on top of it
yeah
let me again take you to the excel sheet
that is all the list of shortcuts
discussed in this video
so i'll go to file
and
i'll open excel shortcut keys
so now we have looked at all the cell
formatting shortcuts
that i am highlighting
again
if you want to get access to this excel
sheet please drop in your email id we'll
share it over email
next we'll be discussing about some
additional cell formatting shortcuts
so up next we will see some additional
cell formatting shortcuts
here we will have a look at how to add a
comment to a cell
so comments are used to give extra
information about the cell value
you can also learn how to find a value
and replace it with another value in the
spreadsheet
then we'll see how to activate a filter
insert the current date current time and
also add a hyperlink to a cell
finally we'll see how to apply a format
to the data in a cell
now let me go to my sample superstore
data set
this is my sample superstore data set
now if i need to add a comment to a cell
the shortcut key i will use is shift f2
so let me select brucina hoffman and hit
shift f2
you can see
my comment box has appeared
now let me give a comment like
brocina
is
from
l.a or los angeles you can see bristina
hoffman
is from los angeles now if i select this
you can see
our comment
next
if you want to display find and replace
a value from a cell
or a range of cells you can use control
plus h
so
let me
select control plus h
you can see
our find and replace
box has appeared
and here
if i want to change
the name of say suppose
brucina
to something like
angela
i'll first select for
brocina
so here i am
typing what i need to find that is
proceena and i'll replace it with
angela suppose
now i'll hit replace all
you will get a pop-up say all done we
made 48 replacements if i click ok
and select close you can see
the name brocina was changed to angela
excel is another important feature which
is
to filter your data based on certain
values
now
let me show you how you can apply a
filter
so i'll select this city column
and i'll go to my data tab
and here you can see we have filter i'll
choose this
now we have applied a filter to our
city column
to show you more
you can see here it has all the
city name listed
and if i uncheck this select all
and i'll select certain cities and click
ok
it will filter my data only for those
cities
use ctrl z to undo
it and now
if you want to activate a filter
the shortcut key that i'll use is alt
down arrow
so if i hit alt down arrow
you can see my activate filter box has
appeared
choose cancel
if i click on a particular cell in this
city column
and hit alt down arrow again you can see
the list of cities
here
now i'll move back to my
book once
and
i'll show you how you can insert the
current date
now to insert the current date in a
particular cell the shortcut i'll use is
control plus semicolon
so now if i hit control plus semicolon
it will give me the current date
you can see this is our current date
that is 9th of june
similarly you can go ahead and get the
current time as well
so the shortcut for that is
control shift colon so if you hit
control shift colon it will give you the
current time as well
also
excel allows you to insert a hyperlink
now in order to insert a hyperlink
you can use control plus k
so if i hit control plus k
you can see the insert hyperlink box has
appeared
now you can give any address here so let
me
go to
google and
say w3schools i'll copy this link and
i'll paste it in the address section
and here on the top where it says text
to display
i'll write
w3
schools
website
now if i hit ok
you can see we have inserted a hyperlink
and if i click on this it will take me
to the w3schools website
so it opens up in my google chrome you
can see this is the w3schools website
similarly let me insert one more link so
i'll go ahead and click control k
and this time let's say i'll
choose
simply learns website
i'll select this website address and
here in the address section i'll paste
the
url
and on top i'll write
simply learn website
which is my text that it will display i
click on ok
if i
click on this cell
it will take me to my simply learns
website
going back
now i'll tell you how to apply certain
formats so let's see how you can apply a
currency format
so you can see
we have some numerical values here i'll
select these values and if i hit
ctrl shift dollar
now these numbers have been converted
into
currency format
we have all
in the form of rupees
similarly
if you want to
convert a particular cell value say 0.3
into
percentage you can use
ctrl shift
and percentage symbol so it has
converted into 30
suppose it's
0.6
and on this if i select control shift
percentage
it has converted into 60
another shortcut key that you can use is
alt q
or alt plus q
this will go to the tell me what you
want to do box so if i hit alt q
you can see
it has taken me to the tell me what you
want to do box if i select a pivot table
it will ask you to give the range
and select
where you want to place your pivot table
and hit cancel
now moving ahead
if you have enjoyed watching this video
so far consider subscribing to our
simply learn youtube channel and hit the
bell icon to never miss an update
let's see what we have next
so now we look at some of the important
row and column formatting shortcuts
here we will learn how to delete rows
and columns hide and unhide selected
rows and columns as well as group and
ungroup rows and columns
i'll
go to my sample superstore data set
now
if you want to select an entire row
i'll click on a particular cell
and if i want to select
row 7
i'll just hit shift space
so you can see it has selected my entire
row
similarly
if you want to select an entire column
you can hit control space so if i hit
control space it has selected my order
date column
now to select the entire worksheet
you can use control shift space
so i'll hit ctrl shift
space you can see
it has selected my entire worksheet
now if you want to move to the edge of
the worksheet you can use ctrl right
arrow
so this is the edge of the worksheet
now
if you want to delete a column
you can use alt plus h plus d plus c or
alt h d c
now let's say i want to delete a
specific column
let me choose a column
say the discount column i want to delete
it
so i can use alt htc
so let me press alt h dc
you can see the discount column is gone
i'll use ctrl z to bring it back
now
if you want to delete a row
you can use shift plus space to select
that entire row so let me hit shift
space now i have selected my row
10
and then if i hit control minus it will
delete row 10
and see row id 9 is deleted if i
undo it
i have it back
moving ahead
now if you want to hide a selected row
the shortcut is ctrl 9
so let's say i have selected
row 11 and i want to hide it i can just
use ctrl 9 to hide it
now you can see we have hidden that
particular row
now if you want to unhide that selected
row
the shortcut is ctrl shift nine so i'll
hit ctrl shift nine
to unhide it
you see we have that row back
similarly
you can also hide a selected column
now to hide a selected column let's say
i want to hide
first name column so i can use
control 0.
so if i hit control 0 you can see we
have hidden the first name column
now to unhide that selected column we
can use control plus shift plus 0
or control shift 0
so if i hit ctrl shift 0
you see the shortcut did not work let me
try it once again ctrl shift 0 it's not
working
so for that you need to change the
settings by going to the control panel
so let me
search for my control panel
i'll select it
and now
i'll search for
language here
let me
search for language
i'll click on it
i'll go to advanced settings
and then
i'll click on
change language bar hotkeys
in this
here i'll select change key sequence
and then
under switch keyboard layout
i'll choose
not assigned
and click on ok
i'll apply and click on ok and then i'll
close it
now if i hit ctrl shift 0 it will unhide
my selected column
moving ahead
now if you want to group rows or columns
the shortcut key for it is alt shift
right arrow
now suppose i have selected
these two
cells
and i want to group these
cells so i can hit
alt shift right arrow so you can see the
group box has appeared
and i have selected rows if i click on
ok
you can see here we have grouped both
the rows
now
if you want to ungroup the rows
the shortcut for it is alt shift left
arrow so i'll hit alt shift left arrow
and select rows i'll click on ok
to ungroup the rows
now let me take you back to a reference
sheet
so now we have covered all the row and
column formatting shortcuts that you can
see here
now let me move back to our slides
now we are into the final section of our
shortcut keys
here we will cover the shortcut keys you
can use in a pivot table
in microsoft excel a pivot table is a
table of statistics that summarizes your
data
for example you have sales data for
different regions and for different
products
using a pivot table you can summarize
the data by region and find the average
sales per region the maximum and minimum
sales per region total sales made for
each region and for each category of
products etc
it allows you to summarize and show only
relevant data in your reports
i'll create a pivot table and show you
different shortcuts to group pivot table
items and group pivot table items
then we'll see how to hide pivot table
item
create a pivot chart on the same sheet
and create a pivot chart on a new sheet
now let me go to excel and create a
pivot table using my coronavirus dataset
so
[Music]
i'll select file
and i'll open a file
i'll choose my covet 19 dataset
so you can see we have our coronavirus
data set
it has the date column
the day column
month
year
the total number of cases that have come
up in each country
the total number of debts that were
reported
country territory code
and we have the continent as well
now let me show you how you can create a
pivot table first
so i'll select my table
and under insert
i'll choose
pivot table
i have my
table range selected
then i'll choose
existing worksheet to place my pivot
table
i'll select a cell and click on ok
just squeeze this
and
i'll
sort in this column as well
now
i want to drag
my countries and territories onto rows
so you can see we have
all the countries here
and then
i'll drag
the cases column onto values
and similarly
the depths column onto values as well if
i close this
and let me squeeze it further
you can see we have our pivot table
ready
it has all the country names
and the total sum of the cases and the
total sum of debts that were reported in
each country
let's use this pivot table and
apply some shortcut keys
now first to group pivot table items
the shortcut key that i can use is
alt shift right arrow
so let's select a few
items from this pivot table i have
selected four
rows
and if i hit
alt shift right
arrow can see we have created a group it
says group 1 and it has
4 countries and the total cases as well
as the total number of debts
now
if you want to ungroup the pivot table
items you can use alt shift left arrow
so let me use alt shift left arrow
so first i have to select this group and
use alt shift left arrow
you can see we have ungrouped the pivot
table items
now if you want to hide a pivot table
item you can use control minus
so let's say i want to hide the values
for afghanistan i'll use control minus
to hide it
see afghanistan is no more there in this
pivot table
to unhide let me just use ctrl z it's
back
similarly
if you want to create a pivot chart
based on the pivot table on the same
sheet you can use alt f1
so let me hit alt f1
close this
and let me hit alt f1
there you go
we have our pivot chart
ready on the same sheet itself
so you can see there's a blue line and
there's orange line as well
the blue line represents the number of
cases and the orange line represents the
sum of deaths
this chart depicts that united states
has the highest number of cases as of
now
and then you can see we have
hungary iraq then there's portugal
and other countries as well
let me delete it
also if you want to create a pivot chart
on a new worksheet
the shortcut you can use is f11 so you
just have to hit
f11
so let me hit f11
you can see here
it has created a new pivot chart
on another worksheet
it has a sum of the cases and the sum of
the depths
with that we have covered all the
shortcut keys that can help you speed up
your work in excel
if you think we have missed out on any
shortcut keys then please put it in the
chat section as well as in the comment
section of the video
now with that we have come to an end of
this session on data analytics with
excel hope this session was informative
and interesting if you have any queries
regarding any of the topics covered in
this session or if you require the
resources that we used in this session
then please feel free to let us know in
the comment section below and our team
of experts will be more than happy to
resolve all your queries at the earliest
until next time thank you stay safe and
keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here
you